foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thanks
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
today Magnus Carlsen takes on his former
World Championship Challenge
in a big winner semi-final but it is all
eyes on in the losers bracket four
players two will be eliminated and while
Hikaru Nakamura alireza and lazovic have
a spot in the Toronto Grand Final it is
go big or go home for Anish giri who is
looking for that final qualification
spot and he's battling it out today
against world number three Hikaru
Nakamura it's going to be Brute Force
welcome to the AI cup
execute an attack and finish the game
this is the chaos button that he's just
pressed what has this kid got in store
he's so good he's so good at thinking on
the Fly Jack made on the board
oh hello
he is so stressed out he knows he's so
close in this one this is a game-ending
move
it's been a dramatic start with
entertaining a chess and the Fight
Continues for that final spot that final
seat into Toronto and to call the action
in the studio as always with me
Grandmaster David Howell and into TM
Simon Williams
Simon it was a day of high quality chess
what was the big highlight for you from
day one I'm I think there was loads of
good games going on but it was probably
nepo I was really impressed with the way
he played
um he defeated a niche and made it look
very very easy and he's gonna need to do
that again today against Magnus because
uh obviously he's got had a couple of
games with Magnus before but he's got to
turn it on today and that's going to be
one hell of a match I don't remember the
last time these two played but that is a
big big matchup that's coming up David
what about you what was your big
takeaway from day one yeah for me it was
uh the play of Magnus Carlson who was uh
in sparkling form it was Maxine
vashlagraph who played some real
beautiful games there to take down
Countryman alireza ferrugia and of
course napomnioshi to go through Anish
giri so convincingly uh just some great
games
create games and if you missed
you missed from day one
if you're doing and second take a look
at all that happened
Magnus magic is always in the end game
that Magnus is able to weave his net
trick his opponents and we talk about
the power of the two Bishops it's level
pawns here but the only imbalances that
white has the bishop pair and look
suddenly trading off and he's going for
that remaining black hole on H7 that's
it
we have a result
wow signed
Magnus gives a check the white king does
move could this check have been blocked
by White's Bishop as well maybe and
Magnus gives up his queen queen C3 now
is he still alive here he's still alive
but Magnus is really struggling to keep
things together look at those black
bishops now they're skewered against
each other on the C file the valuation
bar going up again did it was it a dream
we have a result really it just he
played King to G2 and it ended in a draw
I am shocked
[Music]
what is happening here WAFF is
randomizing he's gambling
there we go Knight to H5 it's very
linear it's very direct and suddenly
look at hikaru's reaction not H5 landed
on the board he looked away and disgust
and he now realizes the bishop to F5
does not work that's why the bars got so
excited Hikaru in huge trouble not
coming around with the shake of his head
resigns and Magnus Carlsen taking the
match and just
and a blunder because prawns H6 is a
killer blow black king now forced onto
the back rank if it had taken that pawn
Waits Queen would have zoomed into f8
with a devastating check Shaq is going
to be going through it's been F6 came
over yeah there's no way you can stop
all the threats there Queen G7 will win
the game now we saw the headshake from
lazovic we saw Mama draw of his eyes
darted off to the side I think he was
checking out his opponent's camera there
a result Queen F6 and Dennis lazovic
resigns a mamidara of Shakira after a
stunning Armageddon takes the match
um the shock attack continues with that
win in the winners bracket along with
Maxine Basha lagrav Magnus Carlson and
Jan napomnushi while we've got our four
players facing elimination in the losers
round one but it is maximum pressure on
Anish giri who is on his final life and
he plays against the Hikaru Nakamura
that's going to be a tough tough match
we saw the bracket there Simon who do
you predict will go on to go through uh
today and survive elimination
um you have to go for Hikaru uh he's got
a massive score against the nation day
he's gotta though play better than
yesterday he didn't play very well
yesterday has to be said
um and in the other one I think it's
gonna be really close between Dennis and
ferrugia they played in the last
championships and uh farouza got the
victory but Dennis was winning that one
so I'm actually going to go for young
Dennis just to mix it up a little bit I
mean if he keeps this solid style he
might might maybe frustrate uh farouza
so uh tennis yeah why not let's go
Dennis
it's gonna be a fun fun battle to watch
between these four players a lot on the
line for Anish giri only a tournament
which we will suffice and get him that
spot into the Toronto finals we also
have two big matchups David in the
Winner's bracket who would you predict
as the players who will go on to play in
the winners final tomorrow yeah also a
lot of stake here between Maxine
Bachelor grav and Shakura mamador of
both players itching to get to those
finals in Toronto and both players
showing top class form yesterday I'm
going to say that one's too close to
cool I'm expecting some fire on the
board uh no matter what but maybe
fashion the graph as a small favorite
and when it comes to Magnus Carlson and
Jana punishi Magnus has got to be uh
he's got to be the favorite but Jan has
also been in good form lately he needs
to hope that Magnus has an off day yeah
also wrapping up his match against Anish
Guri on day one in just three games but
today it has to be a psychological
battle for Jan who is playing against
Magnus Carlson Magnus beat him in the
speed Chess Championship quarterfinals
with an 11 Point margin and that's not
the only one that hurt
foreign
[Music]
this one has reached Boiling Point now
it's just given up a pawn for free he's
still got his pen in his hand he's
trying to figure out what the point is
after 22 minutes the move is on the
board he's finding all his moves so
quickly yeah very impressive I'm also
very surprised by Young apologies last
move he's gone for a queen trade oh he's
retreated it I think he's missed a great
opportunity there in these World
Championship matches you do not get many
chances or three you need that movement
through just over three seconds left
what's happening is Magma's winning he's
winning the computer says Checkmate in
38 the first decided game and we hear
Applause from Dubai there we go the
White Queen going as close to the White
as possible and resignation it's over
Magnus Crossing is up by two points look
at this you guys
touch that piece and then he made that
move hold on that is an insanely
important moment we had a huge blunder
game nine is over a terrible blunder by
Anna Paul niacci fire on the board a
little bit different than everything we
expected there this is quite Ranch yes
yeah he's putting pressure wow we do
have G freeze G3 really being played
yeah there's chosen to fall on his sword
this is just a blunder and Madness is
and he finishes it well Magnus Carlson
he wins game 11. he defends his title
the Norwegian winning his fifth world
championship match
a historic moment in the Chess World
with that win Magnus Carlsen won his
fifth world championship match and also
well it could have very well been it
could very well be his last World
Championship match at least it is for
now and today he faces his former World
Championship Challenger one more time
Magnus will take on Jana ponushi and
this is their head to head David is this
a grudge match for Yan for sure one of
the biggest moments of his life biggest
moments of his career for janaponishi
and Magnus was the one to get in his way
the one to stop him we shouldn't forget
as well there's some history here
they're exactly the same age born in
1990 they've known each other for years
they've become friends worked together
so there's definitely going to be mind
games and uh for Jan a score to settle
it's that same year as you as well David
was that right so that was a good idea I
believe a good year for chess but I mean
I think Jan has some some possibilities
to win that one I mean he's got to play
as well as he did yesterday and I think
he's just got to keep the pace up
um but obviously I'm still going to pick
mags because it's Magnus right so here
always wins yeah it's hard to bet
against Magnus regardless of who he
plays and where he plays it's going to
be a tough tough battle for Jana pamishi
but these are the only two players who
in day one scored their match victories
in just three games it's a match that
we're really excited about but not just
that one Maxime washer lagrav who played
a fantastic match against alireza a very
exciting battle will take on Shakura
mamajarov who needed an Armageddon to
beat thanis lazovic Simon looking at
their head to head what can we expect
from this battle I think this is going
to be really exciting chess because they
both got very uncompromising Styles Shaq
loves sacrificing uh mvl loves tactics
you can see on the scoreboard there the
uh mvo has a slight lead I put in a
slight favorite I think because he's
very good at calculating and maybe has
uh The Edge or Mama jar off in
calculating but manager is a very
natural player so if Mama jarov gets his
piece flowing yeah it's going to be
close and fun definitely yeah and one
thing to mention is that both these
players were in top form yesterday we
saw the accuracy levels both in the mid
90s there and uh for anyone especially
who plays complicated attacking chess
that is super impressive if they can
keep up that form today uh it's going to
be a joy to watch
and chakra has confidence of taking it
to the Armageddon it reminded me a lot
of the 2018 World Championship Match
Magnus versus Fabi the last game David
just deciding that you know what my odds
are the best in speed chess yeah showing
confidence backing yourself and uh not
being afraid of the clock ticking down
in Armageddon shows that Mama joro if
he's one to watch in this tournament
yeah it's going to be an exciting battle
in the Winner's bracket but that is for
later today we do start with the
elimination bracket Hikaru Nakamura
taking on Anish giri and then a battle
between the two youngsters
playing Dennis lazovic II very distinct
styles of play will Clash against each
other and alireza furuja is arguably the
biggest talent of modern chess
oh
alireza faruga needs no introduction
this Superstar burst onto the scene as a
teenager becoming world number two at 18
years old
however since then progress has been
somewhat measured
he's been inconsistent and his love for
chess has at times been questioned
on the board though farrugia is dynamite
he's aggressive he's Dynamic and there's
a Fear Factor about farrugia's play none
of the top players in the world can ever
relax when ferrugia is sat opposite them
I have experienced the power of alireza
ferrugia many times myself
one of the most heartbreaking games of
my career came in the grand Swiss in
2021 when ferrugia beat me and went on
to qualify for the candidates
in this position I thought I was doing
okay with black however farugia is an
attacking Maestro and he shocked Me by
playing Knight takes Pawn sacrificing a
knight and he had calculated everything
perfectly the idea is that when the
Knight is recaptured suddenly this white
light squared Bishop is opened up to
capture the Black Knight and black has
too many things hanging this bishop is
suddenly attacked in the center the
black king is open and for example after
a capture of Bishops in the center white
can calmly recapture because the Black
Knight is undefended if you give
alvareza farusha a tactical shot he will
find it and he will punish you as I
found out for myself
and David you described alireza furuja's
style as Dynamite he's playing against
Dennis last week we've been talking
about Dan Laz as being the Strategic
wonderkid this doesn't feel like a clash
of stars but a war between two that's
right it's fire meets Ice and alireza
thyroosa did manage to defeat Dennis
lazovic last month they had a crazy
match actually Dennis lazovic had
alarator at his Mercy but there was a
big turn around and I'm expecting
similar drama today yeah it's gonna be
very exciting I mean I think it depends
how the openings go if again a bit like
yesterday Dennis gets his solid openings
and he's he's got a good chance
that's definitely a very exciting
matchup between these two youngsters
it's going to be war on the board it
will be about who gets there a type of
position they're kind of play going on
it was a close battle the last time they
played and it's going to be a close
battle in our other matchup as well
Hikaru Nakamura taking on Anish giri and
Simon looking at their head-to-head
stats it feels like we've got a big
favorite in this one yeah ikara's
massive favorite on this one I don't
know what it is about the Styles I mean
maybe uh maybe it's just a speed her car
replays where he calculates but yeah
it's got to be favorite right so yeah
every player has a Kryptonite no matter
how strong you are and it seems for
Geary unfortunately that he's up against
his Nemesis here uh it's just one-sided
their head-to-head their history
Nakamura ahead in standard uh kind of
classical chess wrap it down Blitz I
think Gary needs a bit of a miracle
today if he wants to keep his chances
alive for qualifying for the tour finals
David both of them really struggled
yesterday it felt as if both Hikaru and
Anish were completely out of form Hikaru
a favorite in this one how does Anish
get by he needs to get out the opening
in good shape I think if he well against
uh Hikaru you can't relax but if he does
bring it to Armageddon Gary will feel a
bit more confident just to survive that
far and uh it's all about confidence
then as we know armaged in a bit of a
lottery I think that might be his best
shot wow but betting against Hikaru in
an Armageddon is a very very bad Simon
yeah it is always Brave to bet against
takaru and um I think again the opening
is key as David was saying there and uh
Anish sometimes he he doesn't like
taking risks and I think he needs to
take more risks than he usually does
here because uh you know Hikaru often
gives chances away and he needs to grasp
them when he can yeah
and we did see a struggling shaky Hikaru
against Magnus Carlsen for me personally
that was a little bit of a disappointing
match I think we were all expecting more
uh from Hikaru a bigger fight but it was
a Magnus Carlsen show in at that one now
this is the elimination bracket the
rules are a little different because it
will be only a best of two rapid game
the margin for era is zero in this one
one and a half points wins a gets you
the match Victory the players start with
15 minutes and a three second increment
every time they make a move you lose a
match and you're out of the AI cup you
win you advance through to the losers
quarterfinals and if it ends in a
one-on-one tie we will have the bidding
Armageddon and if you have to predict
right now in the elimination bracket
will we get an Armageddon today
yeah I reckon so yeah probably probably
the second game of the day I mean we're
bound to its longest day today so we're
bound to get an Armageddon right in
every game yeah yeah and the stakes are
higher we've seen it multiple times
throughout the whole season in the
losers bracket because it's just two
games the price of a mistake is so much
higher and uh sometimes the players they
prefer to keep it safe and prefer to
kind of postpone the tension until uh
the last few seconds as the clock ticks
down in the Armageddon so I'm predicting
that will happen maybe even in both
matchups because they are so close but
we'll see either way
would be fun to watch it's gonna be a
super fun to watch these matchups that
are coming up and as our in-house
Grandmasters are predicting a huge
chance of the bidding Armageddon in
these battles we did see Dennis and
alireza take it to the Armageddon in the
Julius bear generation cup where alireza
won that match and went on to challenge
Magnus in the finals for Hikaru alireza
Dennis the pressure not as much what do
you think is going on in anisha's mind
knowing that his only shot at
qualification is a tournament Victory
well he's only human and nation that
will be on his mind but it's probably
counterproductive as a chess player you
need a kind of a clear empty mind you
need to be kind of able to focus move by
move in the uh in the position and if
the kind of result is playing too much
it might affect its decisions like Simon
says he might play a bit too safe or go
a bit too risky and you've got to be
very objective so
finish it's a long long road ahead to
Toronto yeah I think the niche it kind
of strikes me that he he's quite an
emotional player sometimes
um and maybe hikaru's gone in his head
too much that's the problem so he needs
to break that and I think he needs to uh
just take some risks today yeah if he
does that he's got a chance
and he's walking a tightrope will he be
able to take the much needed risk
against Hikaru Nakamura and Hikaru of
course a beast in online chess yesterday
he lost to Magnus but he's only a
wounded beast and that makes him even
more dangerous
Hikaru Nakamura starts the chessable
Masters as one of the favorites
when he was young Nakamura had a really
aggressive style a really direct style
he wanted to win every game by Checkmate
and many people feared him for that
however as he's got a bit older Hikaru
has slowed things down he plays a very
solid brand of Chess nowadays preferring
to take things to a more strategic level
and to grind down his opponents in Long
games as an example of hikaru's
attacking instincts this is perhaps his
most famous move of all time as black
here against Boris gelfand he played a
queen sacrifice this game stemmed from
his favorite King's Indian defense
something he's also published a course
about unchessable Queen to D3 what a
move trying to deflect away this white
Bishop there are multiple threats
including Queen takes Pawn leading to
Checkmate and of course if the queen is
captured this would end in an immediate
Checkmate this is how Hikaru played as a
young player however as a streamer these
days he has an utterly different
repertoire in recent times Hikaru has
shown his natural talent for the game by
winning the Fisher random World
Championship that shows his flexibility
of course and this is reflected in his
streaming career on chess.com his most
successful opening is
1b3 however he's also very well known
for inventing the bomb cloud
bringing the king out not to be advised
but Hikaru makes it work
the five-time U.S Champion the five-time
speed chess champion he is the reigning
world Fisher random Champion uh so many
achievements currently the world number
three player and uh of course we all
know about the big rivalry between him
and Magnus Carlsen and it does uh
continue well Hikaru plays Anish today
and David you said hikaru's most
successful opening on chess.com is one
B3 are you expecting that to happen
today depends how fruity he's feeling
Hikaru he's come with a kind of very
exotic shirt and if he's in an exotic
mood then maybe one B3 I don't expect
the bomb Cloud to appear or anything uh
too risky but uh Hikaru he can serve
with uh he can kind of play in any
direction steer the game uh however he
wants oh my God we have it wow did this
happen
I literally recorded that video months
ago and uh this is the first time we've
seen him play on the tour he's listening
David the prophet yeah 1b3 and uh we
more used to seeing Hikaru play B3 a bit
later in the game especially in such
high stakes chess but this time uh
opening uh with B3 putting his Bishop on
a long diagonal I'm still stunned I'm
still lost for words
is to clip it and ship it B3 for the win
nicely done so
um yeah and this is an interesting
opening I I love seeing B3 because you
you get quite unique positions that are
not so well analyzed and I think again
someone like a niche uh that's that's a
good thing to do because the niche is
very well prepared so you just want to
get a position you can play here uh I
would be pushing the F Pawn here as well
is there any chart oh look at that we're
on a roll it's happening yeah this is
good we need to go and get a lottery
ticket right after that this is this is
insane stuff it's as if a car can hear
us uh Hikaru play King E2
a little bit over the top of that one
but
um I kind of like what Niche has done as
well I mean against the fianchetto B3
um is it's always good to finish Chateau
on the other side uh it was a niche who
actually said in a new in chess article
that uh the The Chateau Bishop on the
king side when it's defended is better
than the one the queen side just because
it's defended uh so this is this is a
good setup I think for black yeah very
solid stuff no weaknesses black has a
decent control over the center
um and she's gonna be happy with how
this opening has uh unfolded but then
again it is a very Hikaru type of
position he's got enough flexibility to
be able to uh kind of maneuver and uh
kind of Probe on both sides of the board
he's kind of not yet committing the
white king he's not yet showing his hand
in the center and for Anish that means
he's got to kind of play The Guessing
Game a bit and we all know Hikaru is
extremely strong in that department
level so far but early days the one
thing I need to be really struggled on
in day one was his clock management
against Yanda pamushi so he needs to
make sure to keep the clock more
balanced to use time well in a better
way than he did yesterday because
against Hikaru the clock will be indeed
a 17th piece this one still quite a
battle one B3 I'm still getting over
that prediction that it lets her go
ahead and take a look at our other a
match up which is just about to kick off
alireza Dennis lazovic they're ready to
make their first moves what's the
prediction here
E4
I was going to say anything apart from
one B3 uh plays uh more classically
usually and this is a sign of respect
for Russia uh using his favorite opening
I did that video piece on him and we saw
he use the Italian game to defeat me
he's used it to defeat a lot of the best
players in the world
and I think he's maybe the leading
expert in the kind of in the white side
of this setup meanwhile just playing
solo chess yeah he certainly is but when
they played in the last um uh the Julius
bear uh Cup trophy
um I had the same opening except for H3
and Dennis got very good position out
there out the opening by playing an
early D5 an early push in the center so
I wonder if he's gonna I don't know Fury
he doesn't play it uh but it maybe he
could have tried the same thing there
yeah uh farouza seems to have kind of
tricked him in a way he said okay you've
played D6 now you're not exploding open
the center so now I'll take a slower
turn and the maneuvering will begin
white just gaining space on the queen
side now white can play in the center
but of course black has no weaknesses
the Italian game is kind of the opening
that occurs most often in chess
worldwide but it's also the opening that
people know the least about because
there are so many different nuances
so many different move orders and even
the top players seem to get confused
about where to put the pieces and when
to strike in the center this one is
going to explode to life shortly I was
going to say white castling early before
black often is a bit provocative but uh
Dennis is never going to play G5 it's
not not a Dennis move then Dennis likes
it super solid
um most of the time at least so
Ryan we keep saying that he's strategic
he's a positional player and uh very
unique to a young Prodigy but when
chances come and when the opportunities
arise Dennis is fearless in taking them
as well so it's ambitious strategic
player yes that's one way I think to
describe it he's super solid but he's a
fantastic player so if you give him a
tactic if you give him an opportunity he
will grasp that and that that's why he's
got his place in the final and uh that's
why he's playing so well here
um but I like his chess I mean I wish
I'd have learned a more solid style when
I was younger you know just just don't
take any risks get a position and play
yeah I mean you know I want it more
solid now disagree with that 100 we'd
never have Harry the H Barn if that
would have happened it'd be a slow Harry
it'd be a Harry one and then for two
just
one move at a time it'll be Henry
not as aggressive
Harry's better isn't it exactly so we
love the attacking uh Simon and it feels
like alireza he's also eyeing space on
the queen side here so it's Ari the
apron for now grabbing more space on the
queen side can we also David expect to
at some point start going forward with
the Bertie the beep on yeah definitely I
think he's just keeping uh Dennis
guessing here it could be David the Deep
one pushing forward it could be uh
Bertie the B Pawn uh either way black
has to decide how to kind of fight back
against the cramping uh effect of
White's last Pawn push Pawn to A5 means
that Black's pawns over here on the
queen side are pretty much fixed if
black can't strike out in the center
it's a big if
um D5 if that never happens uh then you
simply lack a plan so first he Retreats
preemptively before the white pawns
gained time gained Tempo against that
black bishop and I think his idea Dennis
lazovic is to trade off pieces first
black is slightly cramped as we
mentioned and trading off pieces tends
to be good uh kind of advice here uh
farouza dropping back that does hint
that if black tries to challenge the
Bishops white will either drop back or
maybe use this Square he'll avoid the
trade uh this position now on the board
and there we go he does Dodge that
potential exchange of Bishops and
there's a slightly tricky pin here
slightly annoying pin for black to try
and break out of uh again it's all about
whether white can strike first in the
center or whether black has time to be
active himself still in the balance here
and one or two false moves inaccuracies
could change everything
and once that
starts will be fire on the board we
can't expect this position to heat up
it's just the nature of these Italian uh
positions where it starts really slow
starts really kg it's all about
maneuvering getting more space until we
see a pawn break for now Dennis last
week slides back with the bishop another
nice strategic move making sure that if
there's a capture on C6 the pawn
structure remains intact getting out of
the pin we will use this opportunity to
jump back to our other matchup Hikaru
taking on a niche and wow what is this
position
this has gone wrong for Hikaru I think I
mean I love playing the Dutch and white
sort of got a Dutch set up but the way
that Anish has played this he's got some
great squares for his Knights and center
of the board and could this be his
opportunity David to to start really
strongly here
yeah I think uh this is a golden chance
for Anish giri he couldn't have hoped
for a better opening or at least a
better middle game now I think Nakamura
just taking huge risks it's as if
Nakamura is in a must-win situation but
it's a two-game match you don't need to
kind of go all out like this and I think
we can do a quick recap of what's
happened and uh maybe a highlight of why
we favor Black's position so strongly
this is the current position of course
we left it back around here and uh we
talked about the Bishops and I think you
were right Tanya this defendant black
Bishop is far superior to its
counterpart especially after this last
move Pawn to D4 locking up the center
but also blunting the effect of White's
uh pride and joy this B2 bishop and look
what happened white stepped forward
keeping things closed very sensible but
Anish gaining space on the queen side
first of all and then striking Knight to
E3 is a huge huge threat uh Simon talked
about the holes the squares that black
has access to the white Rook moved and
suddenly look at this black blew open
the position and
here we go Nakamura in deep trouble with
the black Bishop is threatening to come
in with a nasty check the Black Knight
can use the square as a launch pad as
well deep in enemy territory and at the
very least you can simply take back the
pawn you sacrificed I love the fact that
Anish used this Rook because the other
Rook on f8 might come open later with
the pawn to F5 being a big break the
white king potentially in the firing
line do we see any redeeming factors in
uh nakamura's position here
pretty tough right I mean you don't have
much space where you've got the white
pieces here you're very cramped so you
have to try I mean you haven't got any
breaks either the only Pawn breaks you
can try on the queen side but they're
not going to help uh so it's just a bit
worse I mean maybe you have to go super
defensive and try something like Knight
F1 and Bishop C1 just try to get rid of
some of blacks active pieces that's
that's probably what I try here but it
looks a bit Grim though doesn't look
very good
yeah Tanya I'm hating this position uh
Anish she's got to be loving life right
it's a dream position with the black
pieces you've got all your toys to the
party he doesn't even Rush with
recapturing the E5 pawn and as he
pointed out it can be captured with the
Knight on C6 bringing the other piece to
the center of the board towards the king
king side lots of trouble for white but
this idea that Simon pointed out a very
creative way to actually fight White's
activity on the king side the retreating
move to the bishop and C1 because to my
head when David asked the question how
does white produce gun to play I was
thinking about actually creating
pressure against the C5 Pawn do you want
to make a move like Bishop to A3 I want
to provoke white I'm dreaming that you
go B4 uh get tempted to play a move like
before because then and I see the eval
bar still likes Black's position but at
least I get a C4 Square for my knight
a very clever move actually Bishop A3 I
really like that move we we do see a
couple of other moves on the board uh
the the danger of what Hikaru has done
is that he he's opened up a file for
himself because he's got a rook there
but you've got to be careful opening up
areas of the ball where you're you're
weaker and I'd say black is better on
the queen side because his pawns are
really far far Advanced there so it's a
bit risky that
um but Hikari likes activity so he's
trying to gain some activity here but
your bishop move your bishop move I like
that a lot actually looks like a very
clever move there uh just to try and
disrupt black you know I think you need
to go for something like this Tanya's
idea of uh Bishop to A3 there before
it's too late you need to carve out some
squares for your own pieces otherwise
you'll just suffocate you really have
nothing to kind of play with no active
ideas so you need to kind of provoke
black forward in ways that he doesn't
really want to commit yet
but Anish I love the fact that he's
handling his clock uh really well so far
he goes maybe more for Simon's idea
potentially offering a Trader Bishops
but not yet and the evaluation bar does
not approve how does black
uh kind of push the momentum even
further yeah I mean there's a big Square
on E3 I don't know if black can use that
square as you mentioned they were just
taking the pawn in the center is
probably quite nice black black has this
lovely like grip and space advantage and
maybe maybe also some F5 at some point I
I mean this is this could really blast
the position open so
tempting options there attempting
options maybe we can get a clue from the
computer from the engine here uh why
does it favor the uh black side so much
and it gives multiple moves and a huge
advantage in all of those different
directions you'll move Simon Pawn to F5
I'm not sure that's initial style but
very aggressive if it was someone like
Shakira manager if he would play it he
would go for the white king but maybe
this is the opportunity David we were
speaking about this earlier like um a
niche you know it hit one of his slight
failings is not playing the most
aggressive move and if you played F5 now
that that would be like the niche is on
fire so I don't think there's much
possibility to play that but
um it looks a bit odd as well doesn't it
F5 I mean it does look a bit odd you do
allow white to capture this Pawn or to
remain a pawn up by playing on person
taking this Pawn as if it just moved one
square and I guess the idea is that
after the black Rook recaptures all the
evaluation bar moves maybe you throw in
a check first of all after now black
recaptures you have given up a born yes
but you've opened up this file and this
Knight under some severe pressure it's
pretty much pinned because if a black
Rook ever lands on F2 that will spell
the end of the game white is now pretty
much paralyzed and uh yeah it's not
going to be fun watching those black
Brooks double up maybe the queen will
also zoom over and everything
overpowering the f file anishikiri
moment of truth moment of truth and uh
he is taking his time in this critical
critical decision would love to see F5
on the board but for me also what's
really instructive and I think it is for
a lot of people out there watching was
another suggestion by the computer which
was to move the EA truck to a to start
fighting for the a file it's not a very
human approach because you've just put
the Rook from here to the center of the
board but very often from White here we
would think about opening up the A-line
for The Rook for activity but when
you're the one on the defense when you
need your pieces to guard the king side
that open a line can actually become a
Target and for black in this position to
try and control for Invasion because
look at how White's pieces are actually
tied down to defending the king side so
I that was a really interesting approach
by the computer anich goes for something
completely different and very drastic
wow Anish Gary he does wow we were
talking about him maybe lacking that
risk-taking factor but he's really
jumped in Knight F2 what a move he gave
a check first and he's trying to bring
his Queen into the position this would
have been a devastating check this is
actually visually not easy to spot so
fair play to Anish for trying to
initiate this threat Nakamura dropped
back he'd spotted this he immediately
recruited his Knight to cover H3 but now
of course the Knight is really passive
and uh now Anish simply takes the pawn
back lever material and still a big
attack incoming look at White's pieces
how passive they are the Knight on G1
Rook on E1 Bishop one C1 it's as if he's
retreating his pieces setting them up
ready for the next game yeah and if
black gets one more move you can play
this F5 move straight away because he's
uh he's got his Pawn back now I mean uh
so white has to play Knight to F1
White's got to try and eliminate those
pieces and uh there's many tempting
moves here I mean maybe F5 is still
possible uh if you can open up your
Rooks there uh all hell could break
loose against the waste King so maybe F5
all hell has already broken loose I mean
have you seen the position this is a
nightmare with white all of like speeds
is towards the white gang your idea of
F5 looks super solid you can decide
whether you want to trade on C1 first
just to get out of any ideas or white
picking up a Pawn on E3 and then F5 this
is huge trouble for Hikaru Nakamura here
yeah I kind of like the idea of black
playing Knight to F3 because then all
the knights are just cuddling you see
they make nice L shape there wouldn't be
a very good move though but I think F5
it's gonna be F5 on the board wow you
think sacrifice this piece oh yeah Queen
F2 and I see four maybe it's a brilliant
idea to Open up The Rook better it looks
actually pretty good I'm not sure it'll
take courage now the White Queen doesn't
have many squares and now I guess at the
very least you push this Pawn he's gone
for it David yeah wow sacrifice done it
this is what we need to see a niche play
he needs to take risks uh like this if
he's going to defeat Hikaru so well done
a niche he's taking yeah he's going for
it wow beautiful play inspired play from
Anish giri and really opportunistic here
Hikari is going to start regretting all
of those Pawn pushers he uh used in
front of the white king a bit earlier on
and this is a rule in general don't
retreat your Knights back when things
are about to open up look at those white
Knights unable to participate in the
defense beautiful sacrifice and he plays
it so quickly he's in the groove he's in
the flow right now in ichigiri I've
rarely seen him this focused on the
camera and let's remember I mean Hikaru
could be going home right I mean if
Hikaru loses uh this game and uh he's
got a win with the black pieces in the
next one so uh that that'll be quite
shocking I don't think anyone thought
that would happen so quick in the
tournament yeah
that it is the best of two in the
elimination bracket things have gone
horribly wrong for Hikaru with the white
pieces uh Anish giri just on beast mode
right now sacrificing that Knight on F2
and David do you want to quickly look at
some lines because it is a peace
sacrifice uh I'm gonna be honest when I
tested F5 even the thought that white
can pick up that night on F2 just didn't
exist in my head because of the X-ray
along the the F line but is it really
that strong what happens how does black
finish this off yeah I think the problem
for White is you don't have too many
options if you take this Pawn uh you're
going to walk in some real issues
firstly along this diagonal with some
nasty checks secondly black at the very
least can just recapture the pawn no
sacrifices and an ongoing attack I think
you have to take the material Cross Your
Heart uh cross your fingers here and
just hope to survive and uh Queen takes
Knight of course met by a discovered
attack against the White Queen not many
squares to escape to let's say I move
and I think the most tempting human
approach would be Pawn to E3 with
threats of Rook F2 check winning the
White Queen but also a nasty check on
the diagonal and the King just nothing
to do I don't see how to continue even
Knight H3 you've got your queen D5 idea
coming in David yeah and this is going
to end badly for the white king it
Retreats and the Black Knight jumps in
uh this will be a devastating check and
a Checkmate okay he's going for this uh
Hikaru who's played Queen to D2 instead
after taking that white knight and now
the key question is is E3 just winning
on the spot
points E3 his idea his Saving Grace
might be Knight takes E3 but he's giving
back the material and again another
check will force the white king to the
edge of the board potentially
this cannot end well for the that white
monarch request five swing The Rook
looks like Checkmate that looks very
risky this I mean he should just be
losing the white the white king is just
too weaker
and all white has for all of this is one
extra Bond
that's right it's not a lot it's only a
pawn so uh yeah and he's playing great
in this game it's a really bad opening
for Hikaru uh he let the pieces in but
uh he's got to play at E3 right I mean
there's not really any other moves that
you play here exactly yeah that line was
very forcing you go E3 you have to take
the pawn uh maybe Black's got an even
stronger move there but uh the line you
pointed out was it is it just simply
Checkmate after Rook F5 I think so I
think that would have ended in Checkmate
there is actually one trick uh I'll just
jump in very quickly to point this out
and then we might check out the other
game but in this variation the one thing
that Anish has to spot is that after
Pawn to E3 after a trade here Queen D5
check after Rook to E4 blocking instead
of running with the white king to the
side of the board where where you will
get chat mated Rook to E4 and winning
move Simon tactic trick Knight takes D3
crashing through on this diagonal and
you're utilizing the fact that this
white Rook is pinned overwhelmed and if
the white Pawn recaptures Rook takes
Rook white can no longer take back due
to the White Queen being undefended and
suddenly we would see Checkmate uh in
the next few turns so Knight takes D3
this would be the winning bloat
anishagiri just has to calculate that
it's three or four moves in the future
but I'm pretty sure he will see it and
now he's getting ready to make his move
he is reaching out for the mouse and
it's E3 on the board Hikaru has to take
cannot allow The Rook from fa jumping on
to F2 he can't allow that e-pawn to last
on that square for too long we might be
seeing the lines that we've been looking
at Knight takes E3 and Hikaru he looks
pretty disgusted with his position
yeah it all shows his motions doesn't he
Hikaru and uh it's just gone horribly
wrong for him and uh I doubt he expected
that he'd be in so much danger after
only three games in this competition uh
there's also ideas here I mean I don't
know throwing a check in it helps it
does force the king to go to H3 uh and
uh but maybe there's not a good fellow
up there but yeah it just looks
disgusting for white everything about
this position is is horrendous
and we were talking about at the start
of this match that Hikaru is a favorite
we saw the head-to-head and it felt like
a dominating performance so far in their
matchup by Hikaru Terry what happened
today what went wrong
maybe it was 1b3 maybe uh maybe a jinxed
and commentator's curse with the opening
somehow as soon as Anish got that space
Advantage he just pushed and pushed and
uh it's as if he woke the Beast Hikaru
he provoked Anish into playing these
kind of Genius sacrifices these really
uh kind of accurate attacking moves dare
I say it kind of went wrong when he
moved to zephorm right I mean uh that
that was the position started to get
worse and worse and he was weakening
everything so uh uh but anisha's play
kind of perfectly I mean Niche played uh
all the right ideas in the opening he
played this really good D4 move to to
cut the board in two as well so uh yeah
so he's playing great Anish has this
huge motivation in this tournament right
he needs that tournament Victory to make
it to Toronto while for Hikaru he's
already booked his spot with the win at
the adjustable Masters do you think that
also affects uh the form that the
players bring in the ambition that they
get into uh the gameplay
I think definitely for Hikaru if winning
this tournament was the only path now to
the tour finals then he would have maybe
chosen different openings he would be
taking fewer risks but he knows he's
kind of backed his spot there in Toronto
in December so now he can play
just kind of free chess relaxed chess
and sometimes it back first as we're
seeing in this game but it does lead to
entertainment for us for all the fans so
as you mentioned Simon black didn't need
to capture that white knight he first
gave a check and now he takes so the
white king is fixed on the side of the
board the only question is how to trap
it there I'm expecting hikara to take
this Pawn back with his Rook there we go
and the killer blow is all that Anish
giri needs no immediate knockout Maybe
some attempting moves yeah if you'll
recap five at some point it's very
tempting and I'm just wondering after
Rook F5 they only wear white fights
Checkmate is actually the Jeep on
advancing forward to control the H5
Square because I don't see another way
to fight Rook to H5 Checkmate I agree
yeah I mean uh it's always nice to
frighten Checkmate as well but I mean
Rook F5 I think you have to play G4 I
mean you have to stop that check and uh
I've Niche going for a slightly
different move order first but I really
like what nisha's just done because his
Queen is now just slightly improved
right David I mean uh but this G4 sorry
yeah it's gonna be he's gone for the
exact same idea uh actually we've
transposed into that variation we saw
earlier uh King H3 by Nakamura if he had
played rookie for Knight takes D3 was
the variation we showed uh winning
material but King H3 and wow Anish giri
plays Knight G4 oh and I think that's it
yeah that's it hikaras resigned
beautiful move if King takes Knight the
white king is trapped this is Checkmate
Queen to H5 uh for example if the Rook
moves as well first you give a check the
king drops back Checkmate Hikaru
Nakamura wow crashed and burned to
defeat but fair play Anish giri
beautiful attack and I think you're
ready
my two four what a move what a fan what
a game
like pizza is Anish guy in a best of two
takes the first win is the first to draw
blood in that one and in Grand style
Hikaru Nakamura has to win their second
game on demand to take it into
Armageddon but wow he will be playing
with the black pieces what a show by
Anish and this one this show is still on
still a complex position the one thing
that I don't like about Black's position
is that Bishop on A7 and when I say the
bishop on A7 I ask myself what Bishop
because that just looks like a big Pawn
I still don't see a bishop Tanya black
has a light Square Bishop I didn't see
the other one where is it where is it
and uh this move for example white bring
the Rook to G3 would not be possible if
the black Bishop was opened up there
would have been some nasty pins but
black is essentially playing this
position without a piece and you just
can't afford that interest suddenly if
play switches over to the king side
where I think uh alarito ferugia is
focusing zeroing in on uh then suddenly
lazovic yeah he won't be able to fight
he's just going to be a whole piece down
and yeah right now it looks like
everything's worked out perfectly for
him yeah I think it you know if you want
to learn a sudden opening uh and uh a
great way to do that obviously you've
got chessboard you've got like loads of
resources out there you can use but
um pick a player who's an expert in that
opening so you mentioned the Italian and
uh Ali razor must be the best Italian
player in the world I mean uh he even
beat you in the Italian I'm sorry
it does you have to be you have to I
mean you're a very good Italian player
but it you know just look at how they
move look at their sort of plans that
they're playing and uh he's dominating
this position and uh it's just horrible
that Bishop on A7 isn't it this nasty
piece that's a really good point that
you make Simon that when you study games
like these you understand these plans
using those Bonds on the queen side they
actually really clamp down the dark
Squad Bishop which is such an important
piece for black in the Italian to create
pressure against the F Dupont also
notice how alireza has managed to get
that Queen side Rook all the way to the
king side with a rook lift to create
player against black skin we can also
see the light Squad Bishop from C2 might
find itself on B3 at some point for now
he's joined the queen into the attack
but imagine wants the Bishop from C2
does come to B3 you're also pinning that
pawn on F7 putting pressure on that
night on G6 and suddenly we're talking
about a real Attack
yeah for example if black just makes a
move all white needs to do is move this
bishop improve this bishop and if you
just do a quick comparison it's that
simple as you mentioned Tanya this
bishop beautiful glorious doing great
work and this bishop a dead piece uh
White can even afford to get away with a
sacrifice here Rook takes Knight would
be met by the devastating Queen takes
Knight and utilizing this pin uh really
instructive maneuver and
okay I think on the board now Rook d8
the most natural move Bishop to B3 looks
like it gives a winning Advantage look
at that evaluation bar and foruga he
always seems to crash through in the
Italian on the G6 or H6 squares uh that
video I showed earlier where he
basically went for a mating attack
against me it happened on H6 but here
it's G6 that is the uh Square that's
creaking right now for black Bishop to
B3 I'm expecting it no need to delay
that yeah those Bishops are so strong I
mean compared into blacks Bishops which
uh which are doing absolutely nothing
there and there's other moves as well he
has played it I mean uh he he spots
these things pretty quickly he's playing
great chess today alireza Queen takes
Knight the big threat and it's going to
be a hard one to stop for lazovic
where do you hide how do you hide with
the black king and you've got three
squares to pick from you have to
sidestep the pin you can't allow that
Queen to land on G6 threatening mate on
G7 it's not a happy Choice do you move
it to F it do you move it to H it do you
move into H7 and you've got about two
and a half minutes to take that call
when the house is on fire yeah that's
that's not great and there's a problem
if you move it to H7
um you know white can bring in more
pieces to the attack I I I don't get a
chance to look at that but
um this Square I mean one great thing to
do when you're trying to attack in a
position is just to look at your pieces
can you do anything with your active
pieces well not really your root can't
do anything your queen so you so you
bring in reinforcements and moving the
Knight around to G5 just looks
absolutely crushing here black can
probably resign there so the King has
gone towards the center king f8 that's
not a move you want to play that looks
so so dodgy there maybe you can get the
Knight to H7 here that's I don't know
this just looks like a fun idea uh but I
don't see black surviving here uh for
long surely on the bright side for
Dennis he is attacking this Knight maybe
gaining a Tempo and he will uh jump into
F4 if he can get away with it I say if
because uh it would allow the White
Queen some access to squares but uh he
will gain time against the White Queen
too so from a human point of view
they're not aware of the evaluation bar
and at least Dennis will have some hope
but there we see actually the engine
confirming there's only two winning
moves for white anything else and the
kind of evaluation is manageable for
black the problem is one of those moves
a very strong move is the most natural
Knight to F3 getting the White Knight
out of Dodge out of the eye line of the
black rook and bringing the Knight
towards the king side as Simon points
out the other move may be more difficult
Rook to F3 but it's the same idea we've
been talking about crashing through
zeroing and on the F7 point and maybe
this is something that Ferris is
calculating yeah but what happens after
Knight F4 here yeah this is the big
question it feels like a sacrifice uh I
think you try and bring your queen in
I'm not sure whether this works but if
for example you take this Knight look at
the power of these two Bishops combined
suddenly uh I think there's going to be
some big threats against the black king
even if he just moves the White Knight a
long form attack here and I think the
threat is simply to come in like King
side lacking Defenders but this is very
difficult to evaluate in a rapid game
for a human uh so Aller is a fruit I'm
expecting him to move the White Knight
and as we see there just below the board
also giving a decisive Advantage yeah
it's a really nice line if you move the
Knight you might be threatening to go
Rook takes G6 Pawn takes Knight H4 uh or
something like that or Knight takes C5
we gotta show that it's it's just one of
those flashy kind of lines which you you
might you want to play you want to
finish a game like that don't you you
want to finish a bit of flare so Bishop
B8 improving to Bishop and Knight H4 is
just a fun move I don't know my queen
has gone but oh oh no my queen here we
go oh yeah
Checkmate wow this bishop is the Jailer
look at that x-ray vision uh beautiful
threat there on the board as Simon
points out Knight F4 played and now the
White Queen doesn't have too many
squares but both squares she can use
have powerful threats either she drops
back attacking G7 or she uses this
Square as a Launchpad trying to sneak in
Behind Enemy Lines to Checkmate this
black king looks like one-way traffic
farooja also with more time this is his
type of position this is a dream for him
well Knight F4 but it had to be played
by a Dennis in this position and I
really like how you pointed out David
that the other line with the Rook
sliding onto F5 it just felt that that
wasn't the human approach Knight F3 just
such a nice movement there's a third
option that the queen has he just gets
greedy with the central pawns but there
are some checks that the Black Knight is
looking at where are these complications
flowing first question you have to
decide which piece grabs that E5 pawn
and then what happens if black actually
comes in with a fork yeah I just forgot
about this option because I thought it's
so counter-intuitive to trade Queens
when you're attacking I thought for Asia
was going for checkmate it's up his
alley as well it's his style but no he
wants to convert this in with a material
advantage he grabs a pawn and you're
right Tanya Knight to E2 check is on the
radar here Black's Knight attacked the
problem was white would give up some
material and G7 the G7 Pawn would have
dropped uh so Dennis lazovic plays
safety first he drops back asking
awkward questions of this white Rook
sitting on G3 doesn't have too many
square us to save itself from and okay
at least the game goes on it's not over
yet just one Pawn deficit for Dennis
lazovic yeah I preferred your idea Davey
just keeping the Queens on the board uh
this this seems a little bit greedy
White's doing well here but
um keeping the Queens on that that just
made a lot more sense going for the
black king on its weakened position
some chances here some chances to hold
on
yeah if that black Bishop was on any
other Square any better Square uh then
maybe some serious chances promise
you're still playing this kind of middle
game end game type of position now
without a piece relax dust Squad
bishop's still a uh bystander and I
think David that last move had to be
played because the Rook from D3 was not
only hitting that Bishop on B3 but also
had the idea that if you move back with
the bishop you can actually capture the
Knight which is defending a key Central
Bishop on E5 so Rook E3 by alireza
ferrugia a really nice tactical
awareness there as you're as you're
showing on the board this was a little
trick that Dennis had set up
they have a really nice tactic there
attacking this bishop but also
threatening to take this Knight and that
idea yeah
stopped prevented and even though white
structure now has been wrecked while
having doubled e pawns is all about the
fact that this bishop on A7 is still not
going to join the party anytime soon it
should be a matter of technique now for
for Russia if as long as he's careful as
long as he doesn't get his uh Rook
trapped
still from a human point of view you
would say some chances one minute now
against two minutes will ferrugia think
that maybe he's let some chances slip
feels like that another line that the
time when you were pointing out it
almost felt as a Black's about to get
checkmated in the next five moves with a
knight jumping in the queen jumping in
and now at least the worst is over you
can still fight move by move you're down
upon but it's far from uh from a result
being called out also you made a really
cool point about the white Rook being
trapped being out of place there so I
didn't have time to capture that C7 Pawn
because the knight from H5 can do a
little yo-yo go back to F6 come back to
H5 and very few pieces left for the
white truck but this last move the eval
bar doesn't approve what's going on
after Bishop E2 yeah yo-yo or YOLO uh
you only live once and right now I think
he's really struggling on his life on
his last life of course in this
tournament Dennis lazovic Bishop to E2
that's a threat uh on that white dot
Square Bishop but the problem is it just
moves out the way takes a pawn and
Black's Knight can drop back now
attacking this white Rook but I don't
think that's gonna last forever we'll
see it happen I'm pretty sure on the
board uh we'll see if farusha goes for
this but some tactics in yeah now maybe
white can just even ignore it can you
actually just get greedy with all the
queen side bonds and start grabbing on
B7 he first starts with a check
yep makes sense I think you'll move
Tanya or wherever the black king goes
just white is going to ignore his Rook
it's a little bit of material but it's
all about the pawns and black is running
out of them
yeah he's just grabbing them there you
go so uh
this is looking very bad it's the name
of the Seaborn Simon Charlie Charlie
yep so uh
gonna be a queen isn't that c Pawn so
and uh yeah at least has the extra Brook
on the bright side but he's still got
that stupid Bishop hasn't he so uh uh on
on A7 and uh white White's pawns are
just too strong here uh White's pieces
are dominating and you can see the White
Knight now centralizing itself into the
middle and uh there may well be Charlie
just coming up the board here uh as well
as lots of attempting options so yeah
this is gonna be winning quite soon it's
too many pawns you can push the E Pawn
you can push the C Pawn you can goblet
Black's a pawn all of White's uh pawns
now are potential queens and they're
running well they're not even running
they're just slowly walking uh towards
the promotion squares it's now going to
be slow but inevitable and that Bishop
is going to be lost on on A7 because uh
White is threading to play B6 and uh
that pawn will probably become a queen
but Black's Bishop has no squares to go
to so there you go B6 played and I think
Dennis can probably just uh his time
right it's time to do that special thing
which we call in chess just resign just
resign and we do have a result as Dennis
lazovic does indeed resign what about
the performance here by alibraza ferruga
with the white pieces we've seen two
smashing victories in this first round
tanislavik now has to win the second
game just like Hikaru Nakamura to take
the match into uh an Armageddon but the
fight does continue for Dennis and for
Hikaru it is a tough tough task it's not
just a scoreline but the style in which
they lost what impressed you the most
about these two games David I'm gonna
say it's Anish giri's Killer Instinct
it's the one thing we sometimes question
about Anish such a great all-round
player but risk taking is uh when he
really shines when he goes for his
opponent someone is here uh kind of
trapping his opponent's king on H3 where
Anish really shined first he gave a
check improving the black queen the
white king drops back another check but
the killer blow was unexpected and
beautiful no right to G4 just creating
this devastating Unstoppable thread of
Queen H5 was The Knockout blow if the
king takes the Knight it is checkmated
on G4 and of course if the white Rook
moves as well still Checkmate guaranteed
Queen takes H2 beautiful win by Anish
giri
stunning Victory claiming a very very
important point in this match against
Hikaru and that we have with our results
have to win on demand they are in a must
win a situation in their final final
rapid game otherwise it will be the end
of the road for these two players and of
course the action does continue as uh as
Anish giri and Ali zafirusha claimed
their points you can claim a 30 off on a
new Subs on Twitch subscribers gain
access to exclusive break time content
during broadcasts you can unlock new
emotes and score an ad-free experience
on chess.com don't miss out on the deals
this September you've got to subscribe
now it runs through till the entire end
of this month and of course the action
does run through as you've got a big
second rapid game coming up in just a
few moments don't go anywhere
[Music]
something new join us for the variants
Community series
every two months we'll be featuring a
different variant in a series of events
and competitions learn a new variant and
compete against other players for prize
money or just play for fun look for
Community Arenas streamer Arenas and
Championship events six weekly Arena
tournaments held every Thursday will be
followed by a championship event with
cash prizes including a one thousand
dollar first place prize the third and
final weekly Arenas will be streamer
Arenas featuring gifted Subs as prizes
when any of these events to qualify for
the championship the variants Community
series kicks off on September 7th with
King of the Hill we're the first to
occupy the center wins the game but
getting checkmated still loses and join
the variants club today to learn more
about upcoming events how to participate
and much much more see you in the arena
on chess.com
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
we're so excited to announce that this
tournament that chess.com is partnering
with browser maker Opera we're thrilled
about this collaboration it's something
for chess lovers everywhere it truly
puts the game right at your fingertips
no matter where you are definitely check
out the Opera browser comes in with some
very cool chess features and we did ask
our players some very fun questions with
the Opera AI you don't want to miss this
take a look
[Music]
giri is one of the most colorful
characters on The Champions chess tour
he has an innate understanding in a
variety of middle game and end game
positions he understands those positions
so well he's also famous for his opening
preparation
in the opening he knows pretty much
everything there is to know
that being said against the very top
players he does sometimes lack a Killer
Instinct he gets promising positions but
can't quite finish them off
if Anish giri can ReDiscover that
attacking Killer Instinct he can go
right to the top of World Chess in
recent years Anish giri has favored deep
strategic maneuvering positions where he
can slowly outplay his opponents
but in his younger days he was more of
an attacking player
in this position Anish giri had the
white pieces and he was only 15 years
old
he found an incredible attacking
resource when he was a piece down he
brought his Rook to the end of the board
sacrificing it on an empty Square black
king was forced to capture this rook and
now the killer idea White's Bishop took
this Pawn trapping the black king now
the bishop covering its only Escape
Square
white has a winning idea next move and
it's inevitable that white will win the
game White's Rook will come to this open
line and Checkmate the black king
opponent tried a very desperate last
ditch attempt he took this Pawn
counter-attacking against the white king
but Anish giri just sidestepped that a
very cool calm sophisticated move and if
his opponent continues giving checks
then we see Anish giri's idea he will
trade the queens and when the Queens
leave the board white is left to give
checkmate with his room the black king
is helpless on this open line
[Music]
and for future reference that is not AI
that is our very own David Howell with
what makes Anish Guri such a versatile
chess player and such a Powerhouse and
he has been a power pack performance by
him against
game one by the five-time Dodge champion
and of course the big victory in the
2023 Tata steel a masters he's won so
many events and for Hikaru Nakamura it
is his task is clear he has to win a
must win situation with the black pieces
how do you do that against the niche
with the form that he showed in game one
uh well her car has got loads of
openings up his sleeve we saw him
playing a king's uh Indian defense
earlier so
um it didn't work so well against Magnus
yesterday he got crushed but he's got to
get the right opening so if he gets the
right opening he gets some Dynamic
chances then uh he can do it but uh
anisha's first game was so impressive
wasn't it he just played so well in that
game it's gonna be tough so yeah yeah so
it's an uphill struggle with black
against the world's uh kind of the
world's Elite when you need to win the
one thing I will say is hecologist needs
to get out the opening with a solid
position I actually think the longer the
game goes on the more nervous anishagiri
will get recently however at the World
Cup in recent Tournaments hikara has
been taking big risks as black in the
opening and I think as we saw in that
first game that would backfire I suggest
a solid start
but he's got only one game the margin
for error in the elimination bracket is
nothing losing that losing the first
game means that Hikaru has to win the
next one it's not just Hikaru Dennis
also has to make that happen now while
alireza and Anish did win their first
game it was still very distinct Styles
Anish with the black pieces crashing
through aggressive chess while alireza
he started with a positional strategic
approach and then a Killer attack in the
end what about dunlas how does he get
that win in in the next one
I I mean he's so solid um so I I think
he should just stick to his normal style
you know try to try to grind Ali razor
down don't do anything particularly uh
crazy because that that doesn't seem to
be him uh just trying to get an edge out
of the opening and uh grind away that's
what we say grinder grind like a grand
monster right so uh your famous
best-selling book thanks Simon thanks uh
and that's right I totally agree if you
look on the bright side he does have
white Dennis lazovic he will be able to
dictate the opening kind of Steel it
will be the end so it's a big chance for
them and it is a big chance for everyone
watching this is your chance to bid for
the NFD the AI Cup nft trophy and it's
right there in front of us and the AI
generated trophy for this event it comes
in a fun Edition as well as for the
winner of the AI cup and getting this
trophy also gets you a very cool VIP
ticket to the Toronto finals in Canada
and we know it's just how strong that
final is shaping up the biggest names in
the Chess World already booking their
ticket so this is your opportunity to
watch them in action live how cool is it
going to be to be in Toronto for the
Grand Final this could be awesome right
and you get to meet the players you get
to go cool town and uh we get to meet
this player yeah I mean that's that's
that on its own is worth uh worth the
ticket right so uh and uh probably his
shirts as well so you get the
combination and uh yeah we see a niche
and um yeah this is going to be an
interesting game what's the open gonna
be here because you got it so right last
time one B3 I mean uh I don't think so
right I can guarantee it won't be 1v3
for a Ministry uh it will be either E4
or D Thor or D4 D Thor if you're
watching Marvel again
watch The Avengers the other night yeah
um but uh Thor will not appear on this
board it won't be that thunderous E4 I'm
expecting from anishagiri and something
quieter Nakamura really struggling uh I
think his opening repertoire is geared
towards a kind of safety first and then
uh going for it later but yeah
struggling to kind of strike being super
aggressive as black in recent times
Hikaru they're keeping us guessing
keeping us waiting okay I say E4
yeah E4 e4's a good guess because if you
only need to draw as many drawing lines
of E4 as well so uh I think it'd be yeah
most top players play E5 and that can be
a bit stale at times so yeah and I like
it also because it doesn't give like a
new opportunity it doesn't give Hikari
the opportunity to get in any crazy
things the Indians set up to where D4
Knight F6 uh the king's Indian defense
that Hikaru does often employ in a
must-win situation so E4 does uh feel
like it's going to be the opening of
choice for a niche and there it is on
the board now the big question will
Hikaru go for a sicilian trying to
create a chaos but he does choose
another approach G6 David are you going
to see some kind of hip-hop structures
again a line that we've been seeing by
players in must win situations I fear so
and this last move does indicate that
black is heading in that direction uh
the hippo defense the hippopotamus
defense is uh kind of signaled when
black finches both Bishops black just
kind of camps out within his first three
lines so on the sixth seventh and 8th
black will just hide wallow in his mud
there and like a hippo tries to pounce a
bit later on but uh right now white has
all the space in the center and the
downside of the hippo Simon is that uh
White does get a free hand to dictate
how he sets up yeah um I mean the hip
house is quite a cool opening because
you keep all the pieces on the ball with
black but uh you're very cramped as well
that that's the problem white gains the
space and Center straight away and uh a
niche well he's well aware of the best
setups against the hippo and I think the
best setup is to try and get three or
four Pawns in the center but if you
can't do that uh this Knight on the
queen side will do the route uh around
to G3 uh you can move that all the way
around and uh that that is an ideal kind
of setup to go for but he's he's
pressing a little bit on on the queen
side here uh first of all and uh Hikaru
not looking not looking too happy there
he's trying to work out a way to uh make
it uh make it complex and okay C4 so
anisha's got another idea in mind here
and this is this is very interesting
yeah hunting down this hippo going
straight for it uh not giving black time
to develop or rest really ambitious play
Anish giri he's clearly in the zone
clearly in the mood to attack and we see
the evaluation bar really hating this
opening uh Simon you've written the
chessable course on this what do you
think who's the happier player of the
opening I am I think generally when the
hippo is played it's normally white but
I mean the hippo is a lot of fun uh
because you do keep those Dynamic
chances alive but
um when the position opens up it nearly
always favors white because he's got
that extra space and we can already see
the queen ciders opened up a little bit
here and uh this move uh it is is a
standard idea and you've got to meet
that like this as black you've got to
try to keep it closed and at least
Hikaru has this F5 move now he doesn't
that's the big idea but for now both
these fan cutter Bishops for black have
been a stock they are stuck inside the
camp the d51 blocking the bishop and B7
the E5 I'm blocking the bishop in G7
while ago looks for his chances Dennis
lazovic has to look for his chances
against the alireza firuja Dennis does
start with the white pieces and in game
one he had some Bishop problems as well
to do deal with Dennis against ferrugia
about to start any moment as the players
are ready he needs to make sure that
this time he plays with all his pieces
he will try and play with all his pieces
Dennis last week he normally opens the
game with one D4 we were talking about
E4 openings in the previous one and
Dennis last week he's got a very
predictable opening repertoire there we
go of course for one kind of so young
that's only a good thing he knows uh
kind of his home territory he knows his
comfort zone really really well and
there we go it is the Catalan opening
something that served him so well
throughout this whole season of the tour
and black grabs upon still up for
theoretical stuff for Russia going for
Black's most direct attempt at
equalizing that means try and trade off
as many pieces as possible try to force
the issue no slow maneuvering battles
here especially in such a tense
situation that makes logical sense
yeah I like borussia's opening Choice it
has forced lots of it to pause as well
yeah yeah it seems like a good choice
here I mean uh just try to get get the
Queens off the board hold on to the draw
uh probably suits Dennis's welder
because Dennis likes a little nibble he
likes having a small advantage and uh
you should get a small advantage in the
Catalan because that that beautiful
Bishop the light squared Bishop uh
striking striking across the center of
the board and all the way to the queen
side so
um probably both quite happy here I'd
imagine and I also like this approach by
furuja not just for what you mentioned
the Donovan situation trying to get the
pieces of the board but this approach
against the against the Catalan is not
the most topical it's not the most
popular approach so when fuja is
preparing against a player like Dennis
last week who's known to play the cat
line he tries to get him into a little
more unfamiliar territories where it
might be a bit more difficult for uh
Dennis to find his chances given the
math situation so really nice opening
approach based on the player as well as
being up a point in this battle
yeah a great approach here but it will
come down to who knows more theoretical
knowledge of course really important at
this level and this position is uh very
topical in terms of uh some kind of high
level clashes Magnus Carlson's been on
the white side of this recently Jan
Christoph Duda as black has been trying
to defend this multiple times but has
actually been on the wrong end of two or
three Miniatures losing very quickly
from the black side so there will be
tactics due to the fact that black king
hasn't quite castled yet
but then again if black survives the
next five six moves intact then it's a
symmetrical Pawn structure there will be
minimal tension we're heading straight
down towards the end game uh so the
states are already high at an early
stage and ferruger he's played every
move instantly
kind of hints towards the fact he knows
what he's doing
yeah I think unless lazovic has
something special up his sleeve this one
might fizzle out quite soon
yeah he's got he's got to keep the
pressure on here I mean um the one thing
you mentioned there is blast King it
hasn't castles so you could bring your
dark Square Bishop out pin the Knight
try to get a rook to the open file uh
there's still quite a lot of ideas uh
you can you can go for here because most
of the pieces remain on the board but
he's got to play something a bit
aggressive right he can't keep swapping
off pieces and uh playing the position
very dry because uh he's not going to
get anywhere if he does that so he's got
it he's got to find a little bit of
oomph in this position a little bit of
uh dynamism
yeah but with that last move uh the
Catalan Bishop on G2 has been challenged
and usually when that happens it is good
news for black we see the queen getting
out of the way of the white truck uh for
Dennis last week it's not going to be
easy to try and create chances in this
one with the center being dissolved and
pieces being traded we will come back to
this David you're pointing out
highlighting some development ideas uh
that do put that do put concrete
questions into Black's position but I
want to straight away jump on to the
other game because that's already
getting very concrete with the play by
Anish giri and I see our eval bar also
hinting at Hikaru Nakamura being in
trouble one more time and what is that
pawn doing on A7 it's supposed to be a
black Ponder wow Harry that is yeah he's
run all the way up the ball there isn't
he I mean uh that is just really weird
how it got there but this was anisha's
idea right right from uh when he played
uh the a porn up and he he sort of
opened up the position he wanted to get
this Pawn to that square I I mean will
will hikara would be worried here I mean
maybe a little bit but he's got some
chances on the king side I mean he's
generated a bit of initiative there with
his F Pawn coming forwards and that was
g-pawn coming forwards and this is kind
of like typical in one of his favorite
openings the king's in the defense and
this is the kind of position he needs
right I mean it might be bad but he
doesn't need a bad position but he needs
to get some uh chances against Gary's
King yeah this is a crazy position uh
let's just do a quick action replay to
show how this white porn managed to make
its way all the way uh to A7 one square
away from promotion now and it was here
where we left it a bit earlier this
black pawn looks like it's doing a good
job of blockading but again by Brute
Force Anish Gary saying no I'm not going
to give you a moment's rest pushing
forward to B5 and a few moments later
trading off uh the blockader and
suddenly this passport was free to run
and here we go it lands on A7 it's as if
black has left one of his most uh kind
of well one of his strongest most
valuable Warriors one of his best
soldiers in the battle fighting
everything stemming the tide uh fighting
on his own here but he's saying okay
while you're distracted on the queen
side I'm going to switch Focus to the
other side of the board and I love G5 uh
just big threat potentially of a pawn
storm towards the white king after all
even if your army collapses even if the
flank of your uh kind of your position
collapses if you go for the king if you
Checkmate that ends things so he's going
all in Hikaru Nakamura of the evaluation
bar the computer does not approve but
humans are not called uh cold-blooded
Defenders like engines and for Anish
this one he's lost a bit of control he
might be feeling slightly nervous
yes kind of position I don't think he
enjoys he doesn't enjoy really murky
messy positions and uh his last move is
uh getting ready to possibly defend uh
The Rook can come across if it's needed
so maybe a useful move but
um I think hikara should be happy even
though the evaluation bar does not like
his position uh he can start throwing
his Knights over to the king side as
well maybe what was that a Pawn's a pain
though isn't it at some point that a
pawn uh you might have to sacrifice your
Rook for it so you've got to hope to get
some kind of big attack on the king side
before before that happens
this is looking like a lot of fun and
the ideas that we've been pointing out
of advancing the pawn it does come in
with a Tempo you want to start pushing
G4 F4 immediately and very thematic in
these positions is to not even care
about
material as much so David for example
the move that you're pointing out
highlighting let's start with G4 here
Kick That Knight and you want to put
that Knight to H4 right putting pressure
on F5 and I was just wondering here like
can you actually just not care about the
G4 pawn and continue with the pawn star
I want to get my F Pawn to F3 so I go F4
and the point is that if you take on G4
and I'm not sure which is a good night
jump but I want to move that knight from
D7 I want to hit your queen and I'm also
dreaming of advancing that F Pawn giving
up another Pawn potentially just to open
up your king and maybe now the more I
look at this position I think I want to
start with Knight B6 and things could
get really really tricky for Anisha are
you a bit of a hacker I don't know do
you like it do you approve I love it I
love that I love the style but I don't
think you're I don't know I I don't
really know your style of play just good
just good moves is that is that your
style of play or is it like do you love
this is exactly we call it hacking where
you just you don't care about your
points you just hack away I feel I would
care a lot more if it was my game yeah
yeah so yeah if it's your own points it
might be a bit more
I might go G4 but might not go F4 but
what is your style because we talked
about David's he's uh the grind Master
maybe
yeah yours let's say that I need to pick
up David's book I need to learn how to
grind like a Grandmaster yeah
but I do uh I think uh Simon missile is
not as crazy as yours but it's inspired
it's a bit bonkey bit Bonkers bonkey did
I say oh that is but yeah Simon family
friendly show yeah donkey style
I would say Tanya is universal if she if
she's given a chance to attack she won't
let it slip I do but have you been
studying my games I have actually I was
uh admiring your games at the Olympiad
last year oh very mutual admiration
there David you won the gold medal as
well so it's a Love Fest
Reykjavik open I remember you got your
Grandmaster Norm that was that was
beautiful stuff and do you remember our
Blitz Games in Gibraltars oh have you
blocked that out my eyes drunk
all right well right now no drunk chess
here as G4 at least has been stopped by
Anish he says I'm not allowing any of
that happening on the king side and he
goes for H3 but that does give black a
big hook to actually Target because now
when G4 comes it comes with even more
power that's right we call it a hook
when your opponent has pushed a pawn in
front of their King meaning that any
time a pawn trade happens for example if
black gets tied to play Knight F6 and G4
for example then open lines will occur
so you use a hook to wrench open uh the
position and this potentially will be an
open Line towards that white king first
Hikaru does sidestep with his own King
the black king did not feel comfortable
on this diagonal and he's also going to
use the square for the black rook and uh
watch out for that attack to be
kind of prepared over the next few turns
first Anish steps his Bishop out I'm
really not sure what his plan is it
looks so beautiful for white on the
queen side but how do you get rid of
this blockader the problem is your
Bishop can't quite sneak in the Black
Knight will cover this really important
C6 square and it feels like you're
you've kind of been blocked at least
there's a bit of a traffic jam on the
queen side and now hikaru's attentions
are focusing uh on this G4 break note
how he's opened up his Bishop to protect
this Square G4 might happen next and
then it will be just uh pure Chaos on
the board so down from both points of
view reasons to be happy evaluation bar
irrelevant right now it's just that type
of position that could
switch in just one move Simon would you
well you're the hippo player would you
take black here I I would take black in
a Blitz game but in a longer time limit
game I I probably wouldn't actually I
mean I love attacking but uh only when
I'm not losing as well so I just I I
don't really believe it I have to say
because you've only got this one break
and and White's gonna cover that break
and you can't really ever use your your
queen side pieces because they're
covering that pawn and that that's the
problem you can't maybe move the Knight
on E7 because you allow the bishop to
sneak into that square that you
mentioned so it's uh is it's a bit tough
but we'll see he's gone in with a knight
though so what's the idea here where's
that where's that Knight heading
a bit mysterious I guess he's just
defending this Pawn maybe trying to free
up his Rook on the third rank a bit
later on maybe he's saying okay for
example if you take my Bishop right now
which of course Nakamura won't do then
at least this Pawn is immediately
targeted
but this is the question after Bishop to
D7 played by Nakamura this Knight is
kind of hanging in midair it's stared at
as well uh really kind of awkwardly by
this bishop
feels like both players will make
inaccuracies in the next few moves it's
that type of position where it's just so
hard to find the correct plan to
calculate correctly and there will be
twists and turns ahead
perfect position for a must-wing game at
least for Hikaru so he couldn't have
asked for a better position against the
niche
um so yeah good chances still only two
sets of Pawns been traded as well
everything else remaining on the board
and I think that's just good wisdom for
anyone in a must-win situation keep
pieces on the board
because the more pieces that remain the
more tricks there will be and speaking
of tricks you know we're so focused in
Black's position on the king side and
the play against White's gang and I'm
just wondering if Hikaru can potentially
have a sneaky idea of actually even
starting to Target that a pawn that
we're talking about is a big strength in
white scam the last move Bishop to D7
hints at one of the Defenders under
attack and imagine if the knight from B6
or from E7 one of these two knights does
fall back to see it I do see that you
can't double up on the airline and
defend everything but you have to watch
out for actually making sure that that
big strength A7 doesn't actually end up
becoming a big weakness
yeah you certainly and and here you go
the Knight comes back to attack it and
uh uh you're right yeah I mean white
white has to defend that pawn now
um so it's it's looking very interesting
actually I mean maybe I was a bit too
pessimistic about Black's chances yeah
it's the you shall not pass approach for
the black pieces on the queen side the
black Rook on A8 the two black knights
hold everything together and now it's
time to switch attention to the other
flank and I'm really surprised by the
restraint that Hikaru is showing I think
uh I would have been too tempted to pull
the trigger and go for the attack
immediately against the white king but
he's just slow playing it maybe your
idea Tanya that black Rook on the
seventh rank if black ever plays C7 to
C6 something clearing uh things on the
seventh that black Rook on F7 maybe uh
eyeing a whites fire Advanced past born
but
okay I need to keep in control for now
clock times could play a factor maybe
Hikaru is just playing the waiting game
he's gonna say I will eventually go for
your king but only when you're down
under three or four minutes
so tense incredibly tense right because
hikar was playing on both sides of the
board Anish has to be careful he doesn't
only have to watch out for any potential
G4 which like you said such a tempting
move at every single given opportunity
but also all these ideas and tricks that
exist against the A7 Pawn so you have to
keep the whole position under control
and not that easy the last move by Anish
it stops any of the C6 points that you
were making because now the bishop and
the Knight are hitting on the D6 spawn
yeah maybe for example you could play a
move like C5 hoping for white to capture
on passant and uh suddenly as you
mentioned Tanya this uh a pawn is
potentially going to drop the black
Bishop will eradicate her will remove
this white knight and suddenly one
attacker two attackers three attackers
this a pawn might just drop off the
board so this would be really cunning
from Nakamura I guess the niche would
not be tempted to take this Pawn he
would just drop his Bishop back or maybe
uh try to pin maybe this is the reason
that Nakamura would hesitate from
pushing his ball to C5 but either way
this Pawn is where both players are
focusing right now it's all happening on
the queen side not yet switching Focus
Hikaru towards the white king
six minutes and against eight minutes
it's yeah anyone's game here I love what
Hikaru is doing I'm ignoring the bar
it's just one of those positions and I
think if this was seen 20 30 years ago
everyone would say oh what a well played
game black keeping tension keeping
everything alive
computers just
teasing us Yeah Yeah because sometimes
annoying aren't they computers but uh
what's he gonna play though here I mean
he's he's spending quite a lot of time
and also as you mentioned they were just
going for that outright attack on the
king side it is quite tempting right I
mean you could you could maybe move the
Rook over first but something like G4 I
mean you know there's nothing wrong with
going Full Speed Ahead sometimes and and
that would at least open up some lines
over there so that's the possible idea
spot a cool tactic actually if G4 does
happen it might be premature at the
moment in this exact position if you
open up lines if you try to go for the
uh white king and suddenly boom Knight
takes E5 loose pieces drop off this Rook
undefended this bishop undefended if you
take the White Queen now then White's
Knight jumps forward takes a rook and uh
you'll end with interest here after you
take the black queen next move this is a
fork and uh if the Knight is captured
instead then I think this position is
just hopeless for black with the white
Bishop dropping back hitting the black
king okay that's that's why it's like
2700 isn't it that's a fantastic spot
and that's why Anish Guri is a super GM
as well because I don't think this is by
chance David Anish sees this that's why
he's inviting the move G4 uh he knows
that it's not possible so he set up this
trick in this trap for such a human
approach so many of us were just Blitz
at the movie for uh but Anisha has
definitely seen this line through with
this really nice spot that you pointed
out with Knight to E5 uh so Hikaru
spotting it as well both extremely
tactically uh aware players and Bishop
to F6 as you're pointing out the idea is
clear he wants to line up The Rook on
the G line move away from those
potential forks and then eventually
strike with two four yeah and suddenly
both players they have switched their
attention towards this G4 Square this G4
push that we're highlighting because
anisha's dropped his Knight back he's
aiming to control G4 and maybe blockade
G4 with his Knight okay hikaru's face as
well he suddenly realizes that he maybe
had gone wrong somewhere because it's
very hard to play that move now yeah
suddenly some threats like Queen to H5
potentially hitting the Rook hitting the
pawn white can play on both flanks it's
not just black and I think maybe he's
realized that now it's just impossible
to push any of these pawns uh White
Queen just has full uh control over this
diagonal he's really not happy that he's
allowed this I mean I love this queen H5
idea just trying to push on both sides
of the board and this is why why black
has now defending that pawn and where's
where's that where's that one going then
mysterious mysterious Retreat does he
want to get rid of the light Square
Bishops that must be it so he wants to
move his Bishop to where his Knight was
and that will give him more control of
the light squares and uh you should
always be thinking about what pieces to
exchange and White's light Square Bishop
is not a great piece because uh the
Pawns in the middle on light squares
blocking it so that makes sense yeah
okay nice nice position idea from Anisha
he's really combining kind of positional
ideas with aggressive ideas especially
on the queen side Anish giri
um as you say Simon if you just pluck
the two light squared Bishops off the
board both whites and blacks then
suddenly black is left with a kind of
prospectless position there just no
control at all and okay Nakamura he's
risking everything here he's breaking
out as we pointed uh out this was a
possibility just a few moments ago he's
trying to clear the seventh rank for the
black Rook on F7 to capture White's past
porn but what's the evaluation behind
this why is Hikaru shaking his head so
much entirely hates it as well yeah and
he's been shaking his head every single
move that he's making it's like he's
just so unhappy with every decision that
he has to take and every move is a high
responsibility move here in Black's
position but it's not just been about
today right for Hikaru the first game
but it's also the form that we saw
yesterday against Magnus it's like
Hikaru never really got going in this AI
cup
no he didn't now he was struggling
against Magnus right right from the
opening and uh there was a lot even more
head shaking in that match as well and
um I don't know maybe maybe he just
doesn't seem to be on form it's as
simple as that really and you know Simon
it wasn't just the positions it was that
decision of the second game that I still
keep thinking about the fact that he
didn't play that on till the very end it
is so uncharacteristic of Hikaru I mean
when Hikaru was was young one of the
reasons he became so strong he was quite
famous for playing on you know at the
age of 8 10 forever you know he'd
literally play on the most drawn
positions for 100 moves a bit like this
chap here
um but he would do that and and he did
it so well that he'd sometimes get that
extra half point and that determination
was I I hope he hasn't lost that hunger
obviously it's a bit harder when when
you when you're streaming all the time
um maybe that he's qualified for the
final already I think we talked about
that before that puts him in quite a
comfortable uh position and uh maybe
maybe he's just say saving it for the
final
and it's hard he plays so much online
Hikaru a lot of Blitz chess bullet chess
and of course uh this is a longer time
limit and longer time control it takes a
bit of time to adapt and it feels like
he hasn't found his rhythm yet of course
still playing super strong Moves In
general but uh not quite at the high
levels that he expects of himself and
shaking his head a lot I think it's just
because suddenly White's pieces have all
got active on both flanks suddenly the
White Queen is opposing problems maybe
just Knight G4 threatening Knight takes
H6 here is is one once good move that
improves your pieces as long as you
don't get your queen trapped but it
looks pretty safe and uh if the Knight
comes in you're threatening yeah I mean
it just improves it proves your bits
right White's actually taken over on
both sides of the board now he's he's
dominating the queen side because his
Pawn ties everything down and his pieces
are are being very annoying on the king
side as well so this is this is tough
for ikara now this is really tough White
House various Avenues into the black
position as well you could line up
against the backward Pawn here at some
point you might even jump in with the
Knight if there's any capture the white
Bishop will drop back and hit the black
king on on this diagonal just so many
tempting moves maybe that's the one
Pitfall for an ishigiri uh it's easy
here to burn two or three minutes just
choosing uh kind of trying to calculate
a forcing line but you don't need to you
just have full control they say that in
chess one of the hardest things is
winning a winning position and I've felt
that a lot when I've played especially
when you have many Pleasant choices when
you've got little time on the clock you
can start getting a bit of a mess when
it comes to variations and calculating
that ultimate blow and especially having
so much on the line just adds to that
pressure
yeah true I mean uh winning winning one
positions is is a real skill and I I
think at lower levels especially uh and
I was going to suggest this movie I
thought this is really clever again the
bishop into G4 but I mean what kind of
tips can you use
um I mean you you don't want to give
your opponent active play I think that's
the first the first thing to try and
avoid uh and you've got to be willing to
still do tactics but swapping pieces off
and just trying to dominate the board
and I think a niche with that last move
is trying to keep his domination that
looks really clever that move actually I
like it a lot it's a dual purpose move
as well uh he's opening up a new square
for the white knight uh just in case it
wants to use the B5 Square as a
launching pad attacking this week D6
Pawn protecting its own a pawn but the
other key ideas you mentioned Simon
you're just slowly creeping in the light
squares are whites it's full domination
over here and it's not an easy plan to
stop actually slow and simple creeping
into the black position
it's not right
right onto E7 to guard that square with
the D6 Pawn being a thunder spot in the
position and Anisha has done quite uh
quite an impressive dance with this
light Squad Bishop maneuvering it around
at the right moment with different ideas
on the king side and the queen side it's
sort of been that subtle star of White's
position
yeah the star the light squared Bishop
it's rare to say that in the king's
Indian type of structure that we've seen
uh normally the white light Square
Bishop Simon pointed out is the one
that's blocked but what to do now it
looks like you can creep in you can
creep into this Square as well you have
to be careful you don't get your queen
trapped on H5 but uh I don't think
that's a threat right now and I mean
this move looks so tempting first
kicking away The Rook no matter where it
okay played by Anish the most logical
move here no matter where the Rook goes
now you can drop back and give a check
and you've gained a bit of time in the
process you drop back wherever the King
goes your other Knight jumps in your
other Knight jumps in
wow that's a dream position for Anisha
and uh he he has enough time as well
um at the moment so yeah and it's uh is
this entire house falling down on the
king side and let's not forget the A7
Pawn is still alive and kicking there
just making sure all border Black's Army
is tied down to defend that pawn from
actually promoting and as you said David
the Knight has jumped forward now does
white actually get greedy start picking
pawns or do you want to keep the
pressure and just trade the knights and
then potentially jump up with your other
night
I think that would be the sadistic
approach maybe the objectively correct
approach just to trade these Knights and
then decide how to remove these uh kind
of blockadas of the white apron this
should be winning long term for white if
you want to cash in immediately uh then
I was going to say take a pawn but
initial wants even more he jumps in with
his Queen
look those poor black pieces it's just a
traffic jam look at this on the back
rank still it's move 36 now and black
has not traded off a single piece
despite being so cramped uh White has
taken over I don't think a single piece
of Hikaru has actually crossed the
fourth rank in this entire game nice
that's amazing I mean he's just been
hobbling around at the back and uh
um a niche has played so well he's
playing great chess so you've got you've
got to hand it to him
um he's he's turned up and uh pulled
into form straight away and the time wow
it's not I mean they're getting a little
bit short time I always get a bit
nervous when someone gets short against
Hikaru because Hikaru is one of the
fastest players in the world and can
suddenly switch into a real Speedy uh
sort of time thing but it just looks
horrible you can get no activity here
there's nothing that black can do and
okay the Queens are now I mean you could
take them off safely if you want you can
do anything as white here it's actually
really hard to lose this position I I I
would do a good job but it's not easy to
lose this position
just by playing normal moves wow and one
normal move that comes to mind is now
jump in with the other Knight the D6
point is weak and you can go from the
night from Knight to C3 and go over to
that B5 Square start targeting the D6
weakness black just has no counter play
in this position you want to try to find
ways for black to keep the game going
but you're just so much on the defense
and the biggest problem is that for
Hikaru a draw is not enough he needs to
win this game
he needs to win this game and uh just in
recent times I remember the World Cup
just a couple of months ago where Hikaru
was on the brink of defeat against
Prague uh pragnananda he needed to win
with black he used this opening
backfired he's used it again here it's
backfired uh just feels like Anish
Gary's been in full control from move
one night D5 attacking the black Rook
if this Knight is taken there will be
some tactics potentially yeah Anish it's
just been a powerful uh powerful show
from him it's play great I mean you know
um you just gotta hand it to him his
openings have been good today uh he's
he's done some great tactical play and
he's done everything maneuvering as well
and uh while the Bishop does take and
there was a big fret of white going
Bishop takes Knight here and it's that
pawn on A7 still which is a real issue
here I mean black is just groveling and
there you go I mean
I think Hikaru Soul realizes he's going
home now and he's starting to play
quicker at this moment in time yeah he's
got a hustle on the clock because
position uh it looking pretty hopeless
right now White's a pawn has survived
they've been all these trades where it
has cashed in uh transformed the
advantage into a positional uh from the
positional Advantage into something
material but yeah white won't get
distracted by this e-pawn this e-pawn is
actually easily blockaded first he gives
a check
maybe he's going for checkmate here
against the black king oh
it's always nice to do that so next week
if you can just take the e-born safely
yeah it's horrible I mean we could see
resigns any second here I feel from
Hikaru which means he is out of the
competition anisha's two pawns up and
he's got that big a pawn as well so
yeah yeah and the first real threat that
a guy who's actually put in this entire
game that Bishop from F6 it guides it
stops the mate on the background but
also threatens to pin along the D4
Square Bishop D4 is coming up so Anisha
just blocks it all
get rid of the only active piece is that
a mouse slip and Hikari says you know
what Bishop E7 blunder but everything
had fallen apart already and that is it
uh hika unakamura with a disappointing
performance at the AI cop resigns and
we're seeing a whole new Anish giri from
day one with the two zero Victory
against Hikaru not just the scoreline
but very impressive chess this was
vintage Anish giri in his prime at his
best attacking fearless and uh Nakamura
just struggling to compete there but
he'll be back he'll be there in the tour
finals uh in Toronto in December
and uh okay this is the other Clash of
course in the losers bracket right now
level material we talked about the
Catalan opening earlier lots of pieces
got traded off right now there's only
two real imbalances black has a slightly
fractured Pawn structure and black has
doubled f1s and white has the more
active pieces White's King more advanced
White's Rook on the open file
I don't know if that adds up to enough
to win this game the clock not in
lazovic's favor here Simon do you think
uh he can turn on the style and equalize
the score or is it going to be too much
to ask I mean this is this is the kind
of position he he excels in Dennis and
uh We've mentioned this before but for
someone so young uh to play in such a
mature style it's still quite peculiar
when you're young you you like attacking
normally
um and I don't know if he's able to get
his rook in then obviously he will have
some great chances and black is very
passive here there's a bit of danger if
black ever moves his Rook he's gonna
he's gonna give sang away and if he
moves his King he'll allow Pawn break so
this move
this move has uh looks a bit odd and uh
I don't know I think I think there's
some chances here for white still
it feels like a dream position for white
right you're playing for two results
your king is more active you've got the
better Pawn structure but the only
problem for Dennis is that the draw is
not enough you've got to have a position
where you're fighting for one result and
that is to try and get the win in but
that said achieving this against alireza
faruja with the white pieces he might
grind like a grand master in this one
yeah he's a great grinder uh Dennis
lazovic here and he's done all the right
things he's kept enough pieces on the
board he's kept the right pieces he's
kept a good Pawn structure and also he's
taken his opponent outside of his
comfort zone alireza we were praising
his opening choices black but he does
not like defending these types of kind
of slightly worse end games with no
winning prospects and we say no winning
prospects because
think nothing at all can go wrong for
white hair white is not going to lose
this game unless uh something special
happens but for black it would be easy
to lose if you Retreat if you allow the
white rook in if white is allowed to
push too many pawns on the king side
um still hard to find moves I mean if he
how old is Dynasty 17 16 16. so if he's
grinding like this at the age of 16
imagine what he's going to be like when
he's like 50 yeah he's going to be he's
gonna be worse than you he's gonna be
playing two 300 Move games every every
game it's scary uh and this is the only
thing that alireza can do you just just
go backwards and forwards there's not
not much else so uh yeah white needs to
find a way through her definitely that's
the problem and here he goes pushing
those Pawns
full pawn attack hornstorm has been
initiated it's not clear what white does
next with these uh beautiful uh with
this beautiful line of Pawns but it's
impressive looking and it is enough to
scare farooja
potentially any King and Pauline game
now might be very promising for white
because white has the kind of option to
create a past Pawn on that flank so any
Rook trade now uh farusha has to really
calculate that one accuracy uh kind of
accurately but uh yeah right now he's
just kind of keeping control one minute
against two minutes should be enough uh
to kind of play here to at least set
some problems but objectively the
evaluation bar still says should be a
draw that's the issue for Richard's just
waiting where's the Breakthrough
this one's going to come down to those
final seconds critical decisions will be
made it will be about the time scramble
here uh Dennis lazovic controlling the
only open file in the position active
pieces he's looking for a break on the
king side he needs to try to create
those winning chances it might be time
for black to start advancing the queen
side pawns as well but for us are just
keeping the position as is keeping the
status quo there uh shuffling around
with the rook and asking Dennis to show
his hand what is the winning plan furuja
not committing with any pawn moves
certainly more of a David position than
an assignment position but maybe maybe
you have to look at Pawn breaks and
maybe it's a well-timed G5 uh but yeah
go and tell us David how'd you win this
uh or do you maybe not I'm not so sure I
yeah don't approve of Dennis pushing his
H Pawn to H5 it's kind of locked up the
structure maybe it's because I have
commitment commitment issues
uh just mostly on the chessboard don't
worry but uh I don't want to commit I
don't want to fix the pawn structure and
take away potential Pawn breaks and
right now white has kind of rid himself
of the opportunity of playing G5 where
he can take back with a pawn now if
black just brings The Rook back to G8
it's unclear how Dennis is going to uh
kind of create that passer
I think I would have maneuvered around a
bit more first kind of hinted that G5
might be played before pushing the other
Pawn It's gotta he's gotta learn off the
great grinder
yeah I take your time it's a great thing
you don't need to brush if you see your
opponent just moving the pieces
backwards and forwards uh you might as
well give them the opportunity of going
wrong
and uh that that made sense I was
wondering if the white king can now come
the other way and maybe try to get over
to B4 but that seems very very slow and
um at the moment alirez is just holding
everything together so he only needs a
draw to go through to the next round and
should be quite close to that
okay I like what Dennis was doing there
he just waited with the white Rook doing
nothing but uh asking a question of his
opponent forced farushi to burn some
time on the clock the problem is he's
still not making any inroads the black
king keeps all the lines all the squares
on the open files covered so white Rook
has no breakthrough there Black's Rook
keeps all the pawn breaks covered and
right now just struggling to gain ground
and he's just repeating here Dennis and
ferrugia he's just happy to say okay I'm
just going to yo-yo back and forth back
and forth with the Black Brook what are
you doing it might be to do with E5 for
example in this position uh pushing the
white Pawn to E5 and uh kind of changing
the nature of the pawn structure first
he changes the queen side he does have a
threat for the first time since we
jumped in here white wants to play Rook
C5 there attacking black spawn so we saw
on passion trade of Pawns more open
lines new avenues of attack potentially
but also another Avenue for black to try
and find counter play with the open a
line now and the B3 Pawn can become a
Target that white needs to watch out for
yeah certainly black Black's record
could get very active now um so I think
uh Dennis is trying to put his rook in
front of his Pawn on the queen side uh
attacking Black's Pawn there and uh this
may well tie black down a little bit but
no okay going as active as he can a key
a key way to play any Rook ending is
just to get your Rook even if it costs
you a pawn keep your Rook active and I
think this exchange of Pawns is actually
probably if anything helped Ali razor
about five seconds therefore Dennis he's
got to move and he's got to move faster
and what black wants to do with this
Rook activity is actually to put that
Rook on the fifth rank defend that beep
on and eventually come forward with the
King if white Rook was to move to that
B4 Square so not so easy for Dennis to
actually create counter player against
the B5 weakness you could give a check
on C3 but white just intends to block it
with his own joke and any King Pawn
endings will give white real chances
yeah if you take the Rooks off the board
then suddenly white does have this Pawn
lever Ponto G5 5 and White's age porn
the most far Advanced Pawn right now
would run through to Glory so king of
Portland games are just Unthinkable for
black right now he's trying to fix the
structure in a different way he's forced
white through it to commit and now he
gives a check and White's King drops
back I think there the offer of a trade
of Rooks wouldn't have worked out and we
see pawns disappear instead but not in
the way that lazovic wants here even
without Black's b-pawn this this
position should be a draw white simply
has no past pawns to push
and the black kings found a very very
safe home there as well
um and well okay the more pawns that get
exchanged the nearer to a draw at the
bishop the position becomes white it's
only got two pawns left that you can try
to make a queen from I guess the H pawns
is best bet but it's not going anywhere
at the moment yeah end games don't get
much more drawn than this Rook end games
do have that tendency and unfortunately
the white King has to look after the
black B Pawn and blacks Rook will go
Pawn hunting everything is just
disappearing from the board now uh the
Hoover the vacuum is out and this one
will be a draw any moment now
yeah and there we have it the bonds are
off the board if we're going to go into
a king versus King and that is it Ali
Reza firuja does advance true does not
need an Armageddon and with that win it
is the end of the road for 16 year old
Dennis lazovic while alireza goes
through survives elimination in this one
we were predicting armageddon's we
didn't get any too convincing
performances there David what was the
big highlight again Anish giri just in
top form sparkling form well done to
ferrugia as well for uh kind of guiding
that game to safety but Anish giri
showed what to do in games where only a
draw is sufficient you shouldn't alter
your playing style you should play for
the win and that's what Anish did after
the dust had settled from a very
promising middle game he found himself
in the same game the black rook in the
corner tied down due to White's apron
and the killer technique here from an
ishigiri was impressive Rook to B1 just
improving The Rook trying to maybe give
a check or even sneak in to the eighth
rank and not falling for any tricks here
Rook takes Pawn would have allowed black
to take the white Acorn so first he gave
a check and he prevented the final
threat the final trap of Bishop D4 by
offering a bishop exchange we saw a
final Mouse clip here from Nakamura but
white had two extra pawns and Anish had
showed perfect technique
this perfect technique from start to
finish there by the Dutch number one
Anisha takes to win as the alireza let's
bring up our bracket for the losers
round one and there we see it is goodbye
to Hikaru Nakamura and Dennis lasvik as
Anish and alireza do Advance through in
the loser's bracket and we are
being joined the banish in the studio hi
Niche congratulations on that win
thank you I'm just as surprised as you
are
hero performance against Hikaru fan of
success but it's not just
discussion games how did you do it
no real things just really went my way
um in the first game he played you know
what the kind of thing he does sometimes
the sort of Queen side fan Shadow thing
and usually he's successful with that
against me because the game sort of
drags on and it's like he postpones the
crisis you know until I'm in time
trouble and then I lose but um in this
particular case I I think well the
version was good for me I found a few
good moves and
very very careful and at some point I
was also up on the clock and I think he
felt under pressure and he missed this
uh well it's easy to miss from the white
side my knight is hanging basically and
it has to go back but suddenly I
realized that I mean I was actually
these five ideas they were I felt at
some point five could win somewhere so I
was sort of keeping it in in mind but at
that particular moment it was really
really strong and once I've got that at
five which you probably missed uh the
the good thing for me is that I'm just
winning I mean he's a great defender but
when it's just sort of completely
winning there's nothing even he can do I
mean I guess even against the engine at
that point I can already convert it so
that was a bit unfortunate for him that
he couldn't really show his defensive
skills because once he made a mistake it
was just uh kind of over I think
it was really impressive to see not just
the games and Niche but also the mindset
shift right you had a tough day on day
one against Yan and then you come in and
cruise through this Victory how did you
how did you recover and how did you up
talk yourself with this big battle
against the Hikaru
well you know in the professional the
high level chess it's a lot is about
just the little things circumstances the
way the game starts yesterday somehow uh
I was also in a great mindset I was
looking forward to the match I was ready
I had certain plans for the game you
know I Was preparing for it for a few
days I like keeping in mind it goes this
is because that I had some options and
uh but somehow just the position I got
I got I get in the first game so
it felt very logical what I do but I
kind of stumbled into some sort of
either prep or just I guess some sort of
prep because uh he played very fast and
suddenly my position is kind of it gets
forcing and suddenly I'm in a very bad
spot and then I'm also slow and the only
you know the only moment I got a chance
for a draw in the first and the second
game uh was when I had like 10 seconds
against like 10 minutes and the problem
also is that um it feels like a rapid
tournament but there's a very big
difference is that there's three second
increments not ten and when you are in a
rapid mode you usually you are used to
the fact that you get 10 second
increment and I'm not saying I would
have helped this game
10 seconds and you make a move you have
20 you know and then again you can think
for 10 seconds again you have 20 seconds
but now when you have three second
increments 10 seconds is just nothing
like you you think you drop to two and
then plus three is already five and it
just disappears you know so yeah I just
wasn't able to defend and somehow you
know it was just from bad to worse uh
but today it went the opposite uh so
it's not like you know yesterday uh I
was under the table and today I got up
but it's just sometimes um things work
work out I think at this point I'm so
sort of experienced that I my mindset is
always okay but sometimes the position
is not very good
uh that is awesome to hear and speaking
of mindset Denise how much of an
ambition is it for you to make it to
Toronto in this one
well you know uh in tears like in terms
of rival Rivals for Magnus I'm in like
tier five at the moment so I I think a
lot has to happen for me to to win this
tournament in this format uh I I think
in hindsight uh obviously if I had
um Ambitions to qualify to Toronto I had
to do it the long way I had to be fit
for every single qualifier I had to try
to grind it and collect points because I
think winning these uh events well it's
a long long shot
um it's possible but it's very hard and
the only Tour Tournament that I won
actually
um I did beat Magnus there in the
prelims um but there it was not this
year it was the other year and somehow
the system was one elimination and Nepal
kicked out uh Magnus and I had to beat
Nepal which I managed with also a lot of
vloggers as usual but in that tournament
basically I didn't have to even have to
beat Magnus to win uh while here I mean
okay yeah like you know I was lucky
today I was able to beat Hikaru but
there is at some point that will be
magnificent so to win and qualify this
way it's possible but it's a long shot
and again I think I had to try and
collect these points but the schedule
this year for me was very tough and
whenever I was showing up for many
qualifiers but I was just not I was just
very tired most of the time and I had a
little over the board tournaments uh
World Championship cycle is a big thing
this year for me as well so it was hard
to be fit and I was able to qualify
Twice first Division and because of
schedule I could only play one so yeah
this final is unlikely uh which is a
Pity because I enjoyed the you know the
cgc final last time I made it at that
time I was a great event but you know
still surprisingly in the running so
well you know always open for a miracle
it would be awesome to see you Danish
and the speaking of Tears would you
agree with the what Magnus said that he
has no Tier 1 drivers
honestly I'm a little bit
um always surprised sort of um it's very
hard for me to understand like the level
difference between Magnus and the rest
and obviously stronger is proved that
with numbers and everything and he also
proves that when you sort of look at
commentary when he on or when he streams
you can see he understands things fast
but somehow it feels to me that the
margin is pretty small
yet
um he wins almost everything
in a larger
stuff in the World Cup you see the game
with uh camera like it's always close
but of course if you if you're stronger
and you play a long game you play chess
for 20 30 years yeah you're gonna
collect most trophies and um
but that said I think in a particular
event in in particular game in a
particular move anyone can outsmart him
so you know it's like like today also I
was kind of happy we play a two-game
match I think the shorter the match um
the better the chances of an underdog
and I I mean I I was kind of looking
forward to today's match more than if it
would be a four game matching SD card
because okay I once beat him in a Four
game match too but uh then you need even
more things to happen you know you win
the first game second game he wouldn't
go For Broke maybe and you know it kind
of keeps accumulating the odds are
stacked against you but yeah and on a
short uh short term I think everybody is
magnus's rival
including noobs like myself but of
course yeah if you if you speak like uh
career we look at Legacy and I guess at
this point in his career he's trying to
cement his legacy and he's fighting for
the spot of the greatest player of all
time with Kasparov uh at least my
understanding is that it's pretty close
I think as far as been doing great
things as well in his career yeah in
terms of his legacy um yeah he's
fighting with Kasparov not not with us
but in terms of this tournament or one
game or I think it's it's open
I really love to see these rivalries
being uh played out and finally before
you go Anish you just tweeted dear X I
just beat Hikaru uh one when did you
come up with this and how quickly did
you manage to get this out is there
something that you had at the back of
your mind
no I know but uh at this point uh just
like my chest I'm so experienced you
know it's just uh I just uh look at when
it comes to chess I sort of look at the
position and I see the right move and
when it comes to Twitter I just take
um take my phone and type type some
rubbish so it's it's been like that it
will be like that and
it will always be like that and if you
entertain us on the board and off here
as well great performance today and all
the best for tomorrow
thank you
anishagiri with a power pack performance
taking down Hikaru with two back-to-back
wins and alireza gets the job done as
well into rapid games we will be back in
just a few minutes as the Winner's
bracket is about to kick off
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
laughs
this is the 2021 World Chess
Championship
[Music]
we have broken history here in the 2021
World Chess Championship because the
move Rook to D2 officially makes this
game the longest game in World Chess
Championship history
thank you
[Music]
foreign
wait a second we have a resignation we
have history
and this rivalry does continue as it is
the big winner semi-finals Magnus
Carlsen will take on his 2021 World
Championship Challenge
and the Magnus there with a huge lead in
their rapid head-to-head with 21 to 9.
with these stats in front of us David
how are you expecting what does Yan need
to do to bring up the fight against
Magnus and get by today well he just
needs to be in top form in every
Department he needs to strike in the
opening like he did yesterday against
Anish giri he needs to be calm in the
middle game and if it does get to the
end game he has to make sure he survives
uh he will get chances Magnus has been
very aggressive very ambitious in recent
times on the tour so he just needs to
take them when they come yeah I think so
I mean he's really instinctively a great
player at nepo probably one of the best
in the world and uh I mean he's just got
to try to get the initiative as well I
think that's very important so get the
right kind of positions where he can put
a little bit of pressure on Magnus and I
think that's a really key point because
when we talk about these top players we
talk about how versatile and Universal
they are but for Jana publisher you can
really tell the distinct aggressive
style that he has he also has uh the
upper hand when it comes to speed I
think from against Magnus it will do him
a world of good if he can actually put
pressure both on the position that's
probably harder but on the clock as well
so a big task ahead of uh against Magnus
but that's not the only matchup we also
have a very entertaining fight as Maxine
Russia takes on the shock attack chakra
mom and the arrow I think this one's
going to be an out and out king hunt
yeah it is yeah
I was just getting a chocolate in there
and I got caught out so um I I think it
will be I mean this is going to be a
fascinating match uh
um they're both just such interesting
players I mean we saw Shaq yesterday
went through against Dennis by creating
that really really crazy attack and that
really interesting uh initiative there
and mvl also had this great game against
Sally Razer the great match against him
where uh he was playing really sharp
tactical chess I'm expecting lots of
explosions and their pieces being
whipped around in that match oh that
one's going to be a fun battle and uh
Magnus Carlton getting ready for his fun
match against the Yan and she there wow
the lights are out what's going on there
David it's been a long day for of just
for Jana from the she couldn't either
player afford electricity but yeah right
now uh maybe it's a psychological thing
he's playing with the black pieces he's
sitting in the dark and these top
players are very superstitious he is the
Dark Horse in this match she's the Dark
Horse oh nice one Tanya maybe that's why
but uh okay this is World Championship
level opening theory he uses the Petrov
defense here uh janaponishi an opening
disgust in that uh big match in 2021 and
there it worked out quite well uh he
often got good positions healthy
positions out of the opening uh Jan
against Magnus and Magnus is showing a
lot of respect here early Queen trade is
very likely and wow we're gonna head
into a queenless middle game position
Jan doesn't look too happy here we
actually saw kind of various different
spins on this in the speed Chess
Championship uh quarterfinals they
played against each other just a couple
of weeks ago and there Magnus was often
kind of winning the opening battle
despite the absence of Queens
strange how a lot of people assume that
one E4 the opening played here is most
exciting
um it's just not is it it makes it be
quite boring if you I say boring but I
mean uh you often lead to very
symmetrical positions where the Queens
come off and uh you have to play a lot
of technical chess so uh one E4 maybe
not the most exciting move to play
nowadays at top level but this one
White's got a little bit extra
development but that's all all the
whites got right it's a symmetrical Pawn
structure so you're relying on your
pieces here and Magnus will will need to
use them to try and try and create some
weaknesses in Black's position but I
don't know this opening but to my eyes
black looks absolutely fine I don't see
why black should be in any trouble at
all here yeah it's a totally symmetrical
position the only difference being that
white has this extra move white tonight
on C3 having been developed it's also
white to play now so you could argue
that white is kind of one move up one
and a half moves up but with Queens off
the board with it so symmetrical no
tactics no open lines really it's hard
to imagine this being anything
significant and this is where chess has
changed like you say Simon modern chess
plays no longer uh go straight for the
king for move one often they're just
happy to go for these innocuous looking
types of positions they lull their
opponents into a false sense of security
and they just try to kind of keep the
game going kind of kind of as Anish said
in his interview postpone the tension uh
postpone the climax of the game until
later on and that seems to be magnus's
strategy here
as he goes and snacks on something
at least it's opposite side castling so
we can see both players now trying to
use their pawns uh to to send an
avalanche towards their opponent's king
try to create some weaknesses like that
um that I suppose that's that's the idea
but I still feel like a queen last
middle game the Queens are off the board
but still everything to play for and
even though now we've got these opposite
side gasoline we can expect Dynamics and
we talk about end games uh well with
Magnus we know what he can create in
endgame so for yeah he still has to be
extremely alert despite the uh symmetry
in The Possession and this one is
underway as well well I'm not expecting
any Queen trades early on in this
matchup yeah this one is going to be far
more exciting at least in the opening
phase of the game it's the Spanish the
Roy Lopez opening and uh both players
actually renowned for their expertise
here often manager grabs the white Pawn
in the center he goes for the open
Spanish but no he chooses a slower
approach uh first for a surprise here he
often kind of sticks to his guns Mama
jarov very principled but Maxim is the
kind of one of the world's leading
experts on the white side of this
position so now we head into the
mainline Spanish until this move Bishop
to E6 a older variation offering a
Trader Bishops early but at the cost
potentially of Black's Pawn structure
being ruined and Maxine there a little
bit of a reaction to Bishop E6 as you
said it is uh a lot of options here for
black Bishop E6 perhaps not the absolute
Main Line in the position and Maxime
goes into think of how you want to react
here do you want to keep the Bishops on
the board by simply falling back to that
C2 Square so that then you can look at
an advance in the center but then you
have to calculate what really happens if
black actually sacrifices a pawn in the
center with his own deep on advancing
forward yeah I I really like this this
mood that Mama jar has played because it
is so important to play in your style
even if you don't play the best move in
the position you you want to play
positions you enjoy playing and I think
the whole point of this move is as David
mentioned if the Bishops are removed
from the board black does have maybe a
slightly weakened Pawn structure in the
long term but he also gains a lot of
dynamic features on the open f file for
his work and that that is a key thing to
start an attack you get an open Line
against your opponent's king and this is
just the kind of thing that Mama jar
falling enjoy having okay we see this on
the board actually and mvl were already
shaking things up in the center but it
just seems to be his style and that's
something really important to bear in
mind when you're playing try to get
positions you enjoy playing otherwise
also what the hell are you doing why are
you playing chess if you don't enjoy it
you know got the wrong game yeah words
to live by and uh right now vashirag is
arguing that okay yes he's allowing
black to undouble his pawns he's
allowing a trade here but white will
have the center white will have the pawn
breaks uh White will hold the key uh to
the position opening up and I like my
Majora's last move very consistent as
you mentioned Simon with his style of
play he moves his Queen to E8 getting
out of the island of the White Queen so
no early coin trades you called it you
predicted that but also hinting that it
might come to G6 or H5 and start
sniffing out some opportunities against
the white king a really tense position
right now neither side really wants to
clarify the center if white tries to
ruin the black structure then after a
trade of knights suddenly we see that
white king lacks to Defenders there
might be ideas of the bishop coming out
to a really active diagonal and this
powerful idea of Queen landing on G6 and
we'll just gain in power uh Ashley grab
doesn't want to touch the center
therefore and uh he plays the move
Bishop to G5 this is not a pin as we're
used to seeing when the bishop lands on
this Square maybe just aimed at trading
off and uh playing Safety First chess
maybe just afraid of the initiative that
the black queen was trying to achieve
returns when one trades are offered you
often have to think about which minor
pieces you want on the board and which
ones you want off the board and what
actually remains who does it favor so
for shock the big question is does he
want that last move Bishop to G5 to
trade it off with the Knight or will he
be considering to actually fall back
with the Knight to D7 uh and that's one
move that I really like in these kind of
positions playing these structures with
the black pieces where I can trade my
black my dark Squad Bishop with white
stock Squad Bishop just simply because I
think black's Bishop is a worse Beast
than White's Bishop so 97 would be on my
radar here rather than allowing the
bishop and nitrate and being stuck with
that well not such a great Bishop on the
board it's a lot of Bishops that I've
just said looks like a nice move I mean
uh I think you'd also like to play
Knight H5 wouldn't you go fours but I
don't think that quite Works maybe
tactically there might be some problem
with the Knight going to that square uh
your Center might sort of start start
collapsing after an exchange of Bishops
95 yeah 95 might just work here
otherwise if you get your knight to F4
that is the ideal kind of position you
want for your knight just hanging around
White's King so 90 sounds very
interesting I mean uh yeah I like I like
right there there just trying to get rid
of bad pieces of course he doesn't play
it but I mean which is good news from
acting probably do not go for a 97 he
instead just attacks the bishop yeah now
uh that Dilemma to take this Knight or
not to take this knight uh it also makes
some sense to kind of come around and
put some pressure on black center but
taking this Knight would be the most
logical continuation and after black
recaptures I'm assuming with the bishop
uh just to control this square with two
pieces then Maxime has the opportunity
to try and shut things down and this is
where we talk about uh well Tanya was
mentioning the kind of dilemma of which
minor pieces to trade off suddenly this
black Bishop might be stuck behind its
own Pawn chain really kind of passive
diagonal here uh not looking like a
great piece so this has some kind of
reasons speaking for it but it's
vashilograph he has to choose what suits
his style and of course he keeps the
tension these players not rushing like
we saw in the Magnus Castle against the
punishy battle
this one maximum tension in the sensor
and now Simon maybe your idea coming in
maybe just activating the queen lots of
choice for black
yeah yeah I mean uh it kind of maybe
revolves a little bit around black
center as well because white white does
have a lot of pressure in in the center
of the board there attacking those pawns
and you don't really want to as you as I
think you mentioned David exchange if
you're black here the pawn because you
give up a lot of space and you kind of
lose the F the hold on the F4 Square so
uh if if uh manager can kind of keep
that tension then uh yeah he's gonna
he's gonna have some fun here eventually
yeah but I don't know what I don't
actually know what his next move is I
say that and I'm like hmm what did I
actually play here I don't think Knight
H5 works because the same tactics might
do maybe it's changed but I can't get it
to work I don't really want to go G5
because it pushes the bishop to a better
square and you have that problem with
the center maybe I do play G5 but I'm
just the lit I mean I love these moves
normally but a little bit dubious powder
um yeah in my head I was kind of I had
this counter on like how long will it
take Simon to mention G5 I was like come
on Simon
you know I like attacking and maybe it
is playable with Knight H5 afterwards
now now I'm actually starting to like it
right so that's all for a night coming
in but it makes some sense makes some
sense yeah I wouldn't like coming in but
it looks a bit odd somehow
it's on shark's reader G5 is a Simon
move but it's also a chakra armor I'm
like a poor man's Shaq basically you
know like I'm like a weak version of
Shaq Shack Shack sees all these tactics
and I just like see half of them so you
know I'd love to see two five on the
board well this one is definitely going
to be a complex complex middle game a
lot of tactics uh that we're gonna see
on the board with these two fighting it
out but let's check in with our
queenless end game in the Magnus Yan
match up uh it started with Queens being
traded early on but then uh opposite
side castling
by Magnus Carlsen and Jana bom Nishi so
still a lot of battle and wow we've had
a structural change and even the Queens
are off the board I'm just wondering if
Magnus is actually eyeing a doubling up
on the G line and putting pressure on a
Black's King regardless of the fact that
Queens are are off the board he might be
going for Attack on the king side look
at the bar look at the bar white is
doing well in this last move by black
potentially inaccurate I can barely see
on the punish it right now and it's
looking Grim for him dark on the board
as well and uh like you said Tanya I
think we have to jump in and illustrate
why this position is so promising for
white okay he just plays C3 Magnus I was
expecting your move and I'm just going
straight for the kill despite the
absence of Queens crashing through on
this square if the pawn steps forward
you can continue the momentum uh you can
really break down this structure if
black tries to block you throw all of
the pawns forward this is why it's used
for having doubled f-bones and
eventually you will break through
against the black king uh instead maybe
the black Bishop would have dropped back
to F6 this is why Magnus defended his
deep Pawn first he plays the move C3 but
this is definitely his plan next
Rook to G1 and yeah I just don't see
what black can do really if you just
kind of wait and play a random move then
this idea uh kind of using the White
Knight to act as a battering ram uh
breaking through whoops me and my arrows
I heard breaking through against this
bishop uh well I really can't know my
arrows here getting this bishop will be
key yeah wow I really like that idea and
it reminds me of what Magnus did against
Hikaru getting his Knight to H5 on day
one which actually did seal the deal for
him and we might be seeing it in this
position so Bishop has gone back to F6
is it time for white to reroute that
night uh land where it did yesterday
sketch yeah but the sun doesn't shine
and um I I like that maneuver yeah put
it put it around there and uh Yan is
trying and we can see this actually on
the live board these moves have been
played he's trying to limit that Knight
by by moving to pull one square but
there's a couple of ways you can now
yeah I mean you're attacking here as
well aren't you so it's not as boring as
I first had said and we see young
shaking his head and the night lands on
this Square anyway this spawn push
didn't stop it remember the pawn on G6
is pinned against the black king so it's
illegal right now to go and take this
Knight therefore the bishop is hit if it
Retreats if it steps back to any safe
Square then this Pawn push that we
mentioned earlier even with the absence
of Queens the black king in serious
trouble this danger that you might be
checkmated in the next few turns by the
way mamacharov did play G5 and it was a
bad move
we don't have to go there but I just you
know he did play and it is given a
dubious Mark so it's kind of typical
right
um it was it was really interesting to
hear what Niche said about Magnus
because I you know you asked him is his
that you know in a league of his own
basically and uh Anisha was like well
you can really work out because he's
like is he I don't know but he's like
I'm not sure and um that's what Magnus
does right I mean he he gets he wins
quite easily you know uh sometimes
against the best players and no one
really knows how he does it and look at
this he's just storming through in the G
file and Black's complete lost and how
did he do it you know it's just it's
just magic right and that's the whole
question right because last we left this
position it was absolutely fine we were
talking about how it's so symmetrical
and how is white going to create any
chances and Jan is absolutely fine out
of the opening and then we check in five
minutes later and Magnus is crashing
through on the king side where did it
all go so wrong for Jan uh David and now
be sacrificed only to break through on
the G line yeah and it was just a
temporary sacrifice he wins the material
back here with interest Magnus it's
still Level material now after that kind
of strange uh kind of trade of knights
but look at the black Bishop trapped
look at why it's beautiful Bishop her uh
he used the bishop head to defeat
Nakamura yesterday yes today as well I
guess it's just the type of position
here Magnus despite it looking so
innocent so innocuous uh he knows where
the pieces belong he's clearly done
homework on these level types of
positions and he knows them better than
his opponent I think I've cracked it you
just gone trade Queens against Magnus
that's the big blunder yeah I mean ever
never yeah that's quite tough right so
and
um yeah there should be a killer blow
here I mean Bishop H6 is not quite
working but it's so pretty yeah if you
move your king first it kind of becomes
a threat
um I guess trying to yeah I mean he
doesn't you don't allow the old check no
time for G7 yeah but if you can do it
and then play G7 maybe it's a good idea
here uh but magnus's other ideas here
what's he doing with that Rook David
it's just slow and steady just come
round and uh you have food ah we know
Magnus likes his snacks just yeah to
move kind of maneuver and that's so easy
you know he's playing like one of the
best players in the world and it's kind
of like I just you know too easy and he
does this all the time it's incredible
it's just insane I mean this year the
kind of performance that we've been
seeing from Magnus the wins that we've
been seeing it really reminds me of 2019
for Magnus where wherever he played
whoever he played he was just winning he
had that huge winning streak winning
tournament after tournament uh and it
feels like I'm seeing that 2019 Magnus
this year
incidentally that was the first time he
ever defeated Jana publishing classical
chess 2019 until then I think Magnus was
losing their head to head four nil uh
four to zero and suddenly things have
turned around I mean I think he holds
that uh himself as his big big year
despite uh already having been world
champion for uh several years up until
that point that was where like you say
just things aligned everything fell into
place and again it feels like he's just
Unstoppable uh right now Magnus Carlson
it's as if he's in everyone's head Anish
was saying he didn't understand I guess
nobody understands otherwise they would
be able to beat him but he's just got
this extra gear this extra level and uh
I mean you complete confidence you know
Magnus pretty well right so I mean
you're good friends and you wrote this
book together grind like a grand master
so you've got to buy it everyone uh
quality book not that I've actually read
it yet but I'm sure it is okay but it's
uh it's a great book and I mean what you
know what is it I mean because you know
you've got that close contact to him is
there something I mean what special
Factor well I think Anish kind of hinted
at it there's nothing Magnus does that
other people can't do it's just he does
everything slightly better he's slightly
better than everyone in the end game
he's slightly kind of more flexible with
all of his openings he understands his
style his opponent's weaknesses slightly
more than uh everyone else and all of
these things they add up and that's why
the longer the games the longer the
tournaments uh the more these advantages
show and meanwhile Jan naponishi looks
like he's getting ready psychologically
to uh to just throw in the towel and
raise the white flag now white can kind
of win this position in multiple ways
you can move back the white light Square
bishop or you can just get greedy and
take start kind of gobbling up Pawns
yeah if again just Magnus doing Magnus
things out of nowhere creating a
position where he's got this huge
Advantage starting and opening a slow
start trading off Queens an absolutely
symmetrical upon structure and suddenly
Magnus Carlsen is winning against one of
the best players in the world how he
does it is just it continues to amaze us
but it's still not over and of course
the eval bar gives this huge Advantage
it's the bishop pair it's the pawn on G6
it's the horrible Pawn structure that
Ian has on the king side but is there
any hope for counter play are there any
breaks that black can look at on the
queen side here oh gosh this seems to
get worse
I like the way you said that and you're
like
um I mean
no what to do basically I think I mean
Magnus is going to get to an ending with
a couple of extra pawns minimum uh he
can take on H5 take on H6 and you know
what happens when you're a pawn or two
down against Magnus in an ending it's
it's not fun so there's nothing black
can do there's no activity here at all
you can try to centralize your rook and
put some pressure against the pawn but
you know it's it's going to be too slow
so yeah I think it's time to do that you
know just resign I mean I wouldn't
bother messing around here right I mean
just just get it over with and the
problem is there are multiple ways here
to win as Simon says you can just take
this ball and followed by this pawn and
white will have two extra pawns and be
winning the game uh Jan defends his H
Pawn uh very clever he's also stopped
the white Rook from coming into G6 uh
there is this plan if he gets two more
moves maybe there's some Fighting Chance
but I just don't really see what to do
if the white Rook kind of comes into the
position right now
um for example actually it looks like
black is going for a double attack here
hitting the white Rook hitting this Pawn
as well but if white just steps back
there's no time to take on F7 I think
we'll see this play out actually because
now White's Rook switches back where it
came from with a check kicking the king
away from the defense of its Rook on F7
and uh this would just spell the end
this is actually going to happen now and
you saw it you saw it all along there
David so it says actually on the board
it's logical
snacks really well yeah too well but uh
six I did not spot uh really clever
resource there he's blocked the f file
so now the black king can uh grab on F7
next move so look so dangerous right if
you give a check you put that King on F7
it's still a pinning that Bishop on F6
and maybe you've got even time to grab
that at six spawn hitting that Rook on
f8 and I'm threatening to come back with
my Bishop on G5 uh Ben and win this
still looks like trouble for black still
looks like trouble I can offer to trade
Rooks but I think you will block uh as
you mentioned Tanya and you're a pawn up
and you're attacking uh this position is
just hopeless but okay still have to put
them finishing touches on we mentioned
it earlier just ending things converting
against these top players never a
straightforward task and I like the fact
that Jan is still posing questions uh
resigning maybe would have been slightly
premature Simon ah maybe yeah he will
lose I say maybe maybe not it's not
about the result it's about the journey
it's apparent result don't fool yourself
so it's about winning and uh yeah Magnus
now just thinking thinking about and
this week was also very interesting just
taking her straight away and yeah he
just spent a bit of extra time there
just trying to work out the right way to
break through and um
now even like rookie six but okay he
moves the bishop back simple chest
pulling up a good position
and you still can't untangle yourself
with the King bishop and Rook with the
check on G1 coming in the bishop and F6
spin it's very difficult to actually get
any freedom on the king side for the
pieces
yeah just really kind of kind of Safety
First straightforward chess here from
Magnus just the time usage as well maybe
that's the part that surprised me the
most we expected Yan to be bashing out
his moves kind of accumulating a Time
advantage and hoping to use that later
but it's just been Magnus from move one
and yeah Rook G1 just looks like a
devastating threat it's an attack and an
extra Pawn right now uh kind of as if
facing Magnus in a pawn down end game
wasn't bad enough just no real way to
untangle Black's pieces yeah and I I
just point out one resource that if
black was to actually bring that ah real
because you want to bring that Rook out
and you try to defend your F7 Rook with
a move like Rook Cafe to just show The
Dangers that exist you can go in with
the check Force the king to that eight
seven and you can feel that the King has
been boxed up and now the Rook from F3
can actually slide up to F5 and you're
hitting the H5 Bond and you're not only
hitting a pawn you're actually hitting
that King because Rook H5 will be
checkmate
nice nice line yeah and there's not much
black can do there again against that
see yeah just losing another Pawn
instead he plays uh Rook to G8 so he's
hoping to meet Rook check with the King
dropping back and at least now the uh
black king defends this Rook looks like
you might be able to escape bailout uh
trade off a set of pieces but uh Magnus
doesn't necessarily need to go for that
he just improves his King oh wow this is
kind of just another level of kind of
self-control he's keeping the threat up
his sleeve for later that's what they
say uh the thread is stronger than the
execution just keeping the uh a kind of
idea afloat just keeps your opponent
guessing and black can never ever relax
just how do you meet this check you just
have to calculate it on every single
move okay he does drop back but now
there's going to be other problems this
is now a proper pin and uh because the
Black Brook on F7 isn't defended I'm
expecting Magnus to for example uh
infiltrate rookie six you might even
just start bringing his King in knowing
Magnus
um just slowly improving his position
while black suffers
this is just yeah it's so hard to offer
advice in uh situations games like this
I just don't see a single blunder from
napoleonishi it was just two or three
very very small inaccuracies almost
imperceptible and Magnus jumps on them
just ruthless and for a player like who
really thrives in active positions who's
looking for those initiative it's so
frustrating to defend these kind of end
games
it is yeah I mean uh uh it's frustrating
defending at the best of times but when
you're pulling down and you're groveling
away uh you lose a bit of motivation as
well you kind of like well okay you
start playing worse moves at the same
time so it's a frustrating style uh to
play against and and again I I actually
think that the genius thing that Magnus
did in this game was uh maybe his
opening choice I mean at the time I was
like this is kind of ridiculous you know
you're never going to get any advantage
out of this and he's winning like 10
moves later I mean he just got rid uh of
nepo's fun yeah and he realizes the
opponent so well to do that he realized
nepo loves the activity so he's playing
against the opponent as well as against
the board which is very clever
yeah I must admit Simon I'm so scared of
your attacking skills that I try to do
the same I try to make it as boring as
possible I don't think you have to be
that scared I mean you you know I think
whenever I most the time when I try to
attack you you just take my Pawns of the
night then I have to resign so uh uh
yeah but you're right I mean knowing
someone's style and these two have known
each other since they were literally
eight or nine years old so so was it
true in world championships Magnus won
did you come second and nepo third or no
I wish
I've got that mixed up there was one
picture of you yeah I'm trying to think
what the picture was but famous
tournament uh in 2002 Yanda upon she
came first he got gold in the world
Under 12 Championship Magnus got silver
I got France
that's all right I mean it's not the end
of the world some pretty strong players
uh who are now 2700 I think Maxi vashi
degrath played in that tournament in
some other
kind of really strong players but I mean
kind of of this era Yan was regarded as
the big talent and just you know it took
him a while it took him a few years to
kind of Click into gear to break into
the top 10 in the world but uh he's just
been a Mainstay and he's been so
impressive ever since he's always been
sharp always been
yeah just so good at calculating yeah
not many players can boast if winning
the candidates twice in a row playing
the world championship match so
impressive me and did it as well quite
recently didn't he which is really
impressive but Jan doing it twice and he
just seems he just seems to have uh you
say naturally gifted and that's I don't
know it's becoming a lot harder to to
see that because everyone trains so much
for computers but yeah and you can see
it you play so quickly you play so
confidently and he plays so well
um but it just didn't go his way because
in in this in this game
after this game
one and still
sure but Jan has managed to untangle his
pieces gotten out of the pin and Magnus
with the last move lining up the Rooks
against the bishop which needs to be
defended but is it as easy a convert as
we're thinking to me it feels like Jan
Is Still Holding On The Rook on G2
activate it putting some pressure The
Rook on 87 defending that H5 Pawn uh
David any chances for Yan to hold this
some they're still slim there are still
minimal chances here but he's done kind
of Step One really really well in any
losing position in any difficult
position especially when you're material
down or being attacked you just have to
survive the longer that you keep the
game going the more frustrated more
nervous your opponent gets and he's done
a good job of that I agree Tanya um he's
kind of at least stopped the white
threats uh it's not clear what to do
next the problem is Black's King is
always slightly vulnerable blacks Rook
on H7 always a bit stuck but uh he has
survived and he just has to continue to
try to do that here we go just try and
tickle that white king uh maybe give it
a check from behind go Pawn hunting with
this one active black Rook a small hope
here and tickle the clock as well right
because if the clocks do become level
and uh playing on seconds things can get
random so Jana banoshi holding on still
it's it's not completely over
no I I I I you know maybe I was maybe I
was wrong and uh the value I'm surprised
the valuation bar is so much up in
White's favorite because that's like
plus three or something probably but in
actual fact there's only one Pawn up and
there's no obvious uh you know obvious
reason why he should be more than like
plus one and one in a bit really uh I
guess it's just due to like black has
activate that one Rook but he can't
really do much his Bishop's very bad his
rook's bad his King is always exposed uh
there is a little tactic here though uh
if it's Black's move black black now has
a first fret probably in the in the game
here yeah for example if white is
careless and just pushes a pawn gaining
space then uh talk us through it Simon
there's a trick on the board yeah you
can just go Rook takes pawn and you just
uh discombobulate uh the two Rooks and
how they're coordinating with each other
and uh that that yeah something Magnus
will avoid
yeah suddenly black would have the
advantage to use this outside passport
and maybe marching down the board later
so uh Magnus wow look at The Bravery
here uh King of the Hill the white King
enters the center a really nice uh
square and note how it was defending
both of its Rooks so that tactic didn't
work Rook to G1 and magnus's King is
safe uh in the middle of the board I
wouldn't be surprised if it starts
marching in a bit later on
maybe now maybe not go for it you know
put it put it on E6 and get mated if
you're feeling really Brave yeah why not
the evaluation bar does not go down so
this will actually be a good idea yeah
and then your idea of getting that King
there is that you want to actually offer
a trade to that defensive Rook of black
on 87 once the ginger is D6 Rook F7 and
then everything falls apart what's been
also really impressive to watch is just
the Precision of Magnus in the technique
that he's shown we haven't seen the eval
bar dip down even once well as soon as
you say that he makes a mistakes
maybe makes a mistake I I mean it's fine
but he's done but not the most Optimum
maybe so yeah it has become slightly
more difficult to press this Advantage I
think he was just a bit nervous about
the king understandably when the clocks
are ticking you don't really want to
take uh such huge chances of even
getting checkmated here but suddenly by
trading these Rooks by playing Rook to
G3 there was a huge threat of Rook to E7
checking this King and suddenly what has
been forced to retreat and this has
allowed the black pawns to step forward
to light squares Suddenly It's about the
Bishops this bishop is suddenly inferior
to its counterpart because White's
Bishop stuck behind its own pawns and
it's actually hard to kind of step
forward with your passport and decide
where you're stronger because you'll
only create weaknesses Magnus still
should win this but Jan putting up a
fight here fighting like a real lion and
it's also the side that Black's King is
really strong and so creating a passer
on the king side will only put it on the
big pressure with all of Black's pieces
uh on that side of the board one thing
let's point out the newer chess audience
here that if if this if all the heavy
pieces if all the pieces get traded off
the King Pawn ending is winning for
white so black needs to keep the Rooks
on the board
yeah or at least the Bishops I wonder if
wow he's actually offered a rook trade
so he's keeping the Bishops on and look
at this the Rooks are pretty much forced
off because black is gaining time now
against this Pawn on A5 if Magnus for
example defends it then this end game is
it actually winning for white it's
unclear because yes you can create a
past Pawn but black will set up a
defense a blockade on the light squares
look how bad your Bishop is you cannot
never attack anything and wow this end
game might suddenly be a draw yeah the
valuation bar is has said it's a draw
and uh we we were saying how how great
Magnus is and
soon as we said that of course he he's
really let this slip and I was wrong I
said just resign but I mean uh never
resign I never resigned is is the new
wow just resign yeah never resign as the
new just resign wow this has been an
incredible turnaround and we had written
this game off right and everyone had
saying that Magnus Carlsen is going to
win this and it looks so close and it
comes down to that point that Rook trade
that was offered on G3 which actually
gave New Life to Jana Palmer's position
but really committal an accurate
decision to trade the second pair of
Rooks on that F line because you'd
always be afraid of going into the sun
game down upon but yeah she looks like
he's done his endgame manual really well
he knows exactly what to do he knows he
has full control over the light squares
and there's just no way forward for
white any time white gives a check kind
of pushes his passport and tries to
advance with the white king you just get
checked back and uh yeah suddenly an
inferior bishop and oh things are really
turning Black's Bishop now on the
perfect square white can never move
watch out for that black Bishop to jump
in it has a lot of targets on the queen
side this one is just a dead draw now
and uh Jan we saw him smiling actually
laughing a moment ago he knows he's
gotten out of jail here miracles do
happen great safe even against Magnus
Carlsen apparently so CR just
unbelievable stuff really an important
save because if you lose the first round
to Magnus it really sets the Dawn would
have made things so much more difficult
and the one thing working in yeah
is that all of magnus's pond on the
queen side are stuck on the dark squares
making them a big Target for Yan's
Bishop in case white gets very active
with the king so things working out this
one looks like it is a got to end in a
draw we're also getting a big big update
from our division to action the one
player who's in the race to make it to
Toronto who's fighting it out in
division two is Vladimir fellowship and
Pharisee does win his
second match today as well against
Vincent kaima and Professor it is so
important to win division two to get
those 50 tour points he would need some
other results to go his way in division
one but he does have a path to Toronto
but first he needs to do his job which
is Win division two right now and he
starts with a fantastic performance
yeah winning that's the only way to keep
your fate in your own hands and whatever
other results happened fair to say if
he's doing what he needs to do meanwhile
Magnus is still trying to work his and
game magic he's traded off a set of
Pawns this hasn't really changed too
much White's still left with lots of
Pawns on Dart squares some potential
weaknesses but you could imagine a world
where white breaks with uh pushing his
Pawn to B5 and sneaks in with the white
King still napomnia she has some work to
do he has to defend accurately to ensure
that doesn't happen Black's King throws
in defending against White's past Pawn
on the G file the black Bishop is the
one that will try to fight and uh keep
white out
and he's going for that pawn of the pawn
break on a B5 and also notice how that
white Bishop on D2 is stopping Black
skiing from any activity getting to that
G5 Square to put pressure on G4 uh Jan
saying he I don't need to react on the
queen side keeping it as is because that
A6 Pawn is such a key pawn and making
sure that white skin doesn't get through
the coordination between the D5 pawn and
the A6 Pawn take away a lot of key
squares from White
yeah I can't see a way through here I
thought he might try Bishop B4 and try
to get his King to C5 but
um they they are just dancing around at
the moment here and uh Jan playing
really really quickly there uh with his
Bishop moves and white needs to get his
King into the position this is the
problem his Bishop on its own can't do
any damage because as you mentioned
Black's pawns are all on light squares
you've got a dark Square Bishop so you
need to get your king into opponent's
half but you just can't do that the the
black Bishop is always going to stop the
white king from moving in to the
position so this is uh very very
impressive defensive play uh from nepo I
think we might be seeing a result very
soon uh Jan doesn't even bother bringing
the king forward he's just shuffling
around with the bishop the weaknesses in
magnus's Camp with all the Pawns in the
dark squares and black skin always
threatening to move forward to attack
the G4 Pawn even though Magnus is an
extra Pawn
it's just not enough and black stops any
King counter play with that last check
that we saw yeah I think this is just
one to remember not only in uh these end
games but also middle games if you have
a dark Square Bishop pawns on light
squares you need to control both color
complexes and that's what Jan is doing
here he has a fortress as black because
the pawns uh stop the white king using
light squares the bishop kicks back the
white king uh anytime it lands on a dark
Square just perfect control over the
whole board despite being a pawn down
and this one as you say Tanya it's in
its final throws now any moment we'll
see the position repeat itself might be
now yeah or Magnus acquiesce to the draw
yeah I think he's uh he knows that he's
tried everything and it all comes down
to that wrong Rook trade uh that Magnus
went for which gave
yeah and all the chances to hold this
position and we see the king shuffling
around and a repetition here and that
should be the end of it and that's it
yeah should be relieved while its Magnus
Carlsen you should be feeling the
frustration right now such a fantastic
play out of the opening getting that big
Advantage uh getting that extra Pawn in
but in positions where usually you see
Magnus crashing through and showing
Flawless technique one mistake and then
yeah got his chances uh David wow what a
game that was uh what was the highlight
for you and we see Yan there he's got to
be feeling good about this draw yeah
yeah using all of his tenacity his uh
resourcefulness to save that draw and I
just want to point out the instructive
moment where Magnus let the wind slip it
was here where he had full control
whites Rooks very very active here and
he didn't need to rush he could simply
push pawns on the queen side if he was
feeling brave maybe even infiltrate with
the white king Behind Enemy Lines but it
was going for the wrong type of end game
that cost Magnus he traded off first
Black's active Rook this made sense but
the problem was he was forced to retreat
the white king now vulnerable to checks
and it was here that uh Jan clinched
that he put his pawns on light squares
we saw this being great strategy long
term and Rook to F7 trading off the
Rooks as well and black was safe full
control and a draw very instructive
player by both these players yeah
getting that one opportunity and making
sure that he keeps the position under
control as soon as he got the activity
for his pieces that one ended in a draw
it is a best of four in the winner
semi-finals Maxine Basha legrath chakra
Mama yarov also ended in a draw two
peaceful games but big big fights and
they do continue as we will be having
game two action in the AI cup the winner
semi-finals we will be back in just a
few moments
thank you
[Music]
this chorus is about white playing D4
all the tools you need to get an
advantage with Wyatt and not be tricked
early in the opening
now it has a really long complicated
name
pronounced now
fun of me they don't make fun of me too
much I'm trying to help you here it's
called the cello binsk variation and I'm
probably mispronouncing cello bins
that's why I call it the A6 sloth
[Music]
but she's not gonna move it because it's
defended oh she did it
looks just don't go
we need a compilation chest.com social
media crew look through the podcast
games
[Music]
how many times I called the Moon
okay Levy you asked for it here we go
it's almost a Salesman knows what he's
doing he's gonna try to Andrea Andrea
there's a stalemate coming Pawn here
take King G4 he pushes and it's a
stalemate oh my goodness well you
clearly you I'm sure you taught Frank
about stalemate no okay
[Applause]
this I blame you for all of this this is
oh my goodness
Bishop takes Pawn takes Queen takes
loses the bishop and if that happens I
will be heartbroken because you could
have just
that was your heart heavy
is it feeling okay
her heart how is it you can't even
script this stuff my man
defend the bishop again I just forgot
hey okay
his position is is hard to lose as long
as it stays how it is
yeah for sure unless he starts going
totally crazy with something like
pontaji
[Music]
at in real time
and the excitement continues and we are
also so thrilled to announce uh at the
AI cop chess.com is partnering with
browser maker Opera and we're so excited
about this collaboration because it
really is the first ever chess themed
browser it's something for chess lovers
everywhere
putting the game right at your
fingertips no matter where you are
modern chess has been so much about
technology about computers the Beloved
evaluation bar and it continues to
evolve and change the world and it all
started it all happened in 1997 when
Gary Kasparov played a match against
IBM's deep blue the rematch which Gary
eventually lost and that was the turning
point before that
humans were playing fighting competing
against computers but after that match
you had to be on the same team you
couldn't fight against Brute Force
anymore and it all changed suddenly from
playing against them computers were used
for Preparation on the same side to
better the game and we spoke to Magnus
Carlsen and Jana publisher who are
fighting it out today in the winner
semi-final how AI how computers have
influenced their preparation for the
world championship match
I I think uh probably Fabi had some
access to to Lila before
um before the 2018 match but we didn't
well I would say that a lot of lines he
played back in this match what Magnus
did was not the top choice of uh let's
say stockfish and surely the evolution
of Lila would be way more positive in
the evolution of stockfish so it seems
to me that Carlson team was using uh
this a lot and starting from 2019 I
think
um pretty much every professional chess
players also started to to work and in
2021 it was Jana pomyachi's turn to
challenge Magnus Carlsen in the world
championship match a few months before
it started we paid the visit to
Carlson's training camp with his team in
Spain at this point they knew that this
time they definitely were up against
artificial intelligence computers has
always been a factor in World
Championships matches at least the last
20 years and such but this will be the
first match where you yeah neural
network which is sort of real artificial
intelligence will be sort of easily
available to both sides and such so
that's interesting how that plays out
and of course well we're using it
obviously as such but um so so are they
we know so it's oh I mean it should be
more difficult to surprise the opponent
we think I think Magnus was quite quite
smart
um you know decreasing the possibility
of uh running to some some deep
preparation from from our team
is getting help from the scholco
University in Moscow on social
specializing in that so and getting
access to the huge super computers you
can read about that so no of course
they're going to be cutting edge there
and that could worry us a bit but well
we have our own plans uh this one loses
yeah okay this one loses so this those
plans were solid enough to get Magnus is
Fifth and quite possibly last world
champion title in the end one could say
that artificial intelligence played such
a big part in both teams that it didn't
become a decisive Factor it was decided
more at the board not in the into the
laboratory when I got my first when you
know I knew that that was more or less
it because I didn't feel that he could
he could really beat me so my victory in
that much didn't have didn't have to do
with with neural networks you know if
the engine would suggest me like how to
fix my my you know my schedule in my
sleep it will be quite uh quite nice but
this sort of engine you know I didn't
use it back then and I'm not sure if
it's uh already invented
an AI continues to change the Chess
World and you can experience it by
downloading the first in the World Chess
browser powered by Opera you can do that
by going on go.chess.com Opera the first
ever chess team Opera and we've got some
fun uh for all of you here you've got to
go on chess.com and challenge David
Howell who's left the commentator seat
right now currently getting ready he's
doing a little bit of a workout just
before we got on I saw that floss David
the floss stance he's ready for your
challenges he's got his Opera browser
open he wants to play bullet against you
so go on challenge David Howell on
chess.com that's right uh I've been so
inspired by the chess today that I
decided to play a bullet game myself
short break here so let's jump in this
is my home screen don't peek I hear this
is the Opera browser look how smooth it
is of course you can personalize I'm
going to jump straight in chess shortcut
straight to the game I'm going to play
unrated as usual because I'm a coward I
don't want to lose my rating I know you
guys uh your viewers at home are pretty
strong and okay I've got a game and I'm
gonna go for checkmate I'm gonna
okay this doesn't work but uh don't try
this at home kids I'm gonna bring my
Bishop out now does he see the threat
giving up my knight he sees it oh wow
okay now I'm attacking the rook in the
corner Rook on h8
my opponent's not going down without a
fight
I'm trying to break through okay this is
uh I hope I can win this in time this
would be an embarrassing way to retire
uh okay my opponent's playing really
really well
over
stop attacking my pieces oh my gosh I'm
not using the quickest mouse ever either
so okay let's try and come in
a castle Queen side all my pieces to the
party
Simon what do you think of my play so
far
um yeah
didn't you lose the other day as well no
comment I might have lost yesterday but
I mean it'd be nice be nice to see you
win one game maybe what would Anish do
here a niche a niche will attack he's
been doing some good attacking stuff
come on David you're getting there now
getting closer you come in you come
where's my point oh wow I nearly Blended
a piece they're right there but you've
got 20 seconds as well he's defending
well what's his rating my opponent is
1300. and I'm getting outplayed okay use
your real rating 1200 David is that what
you're saying this is my last ever
commentary gig wow okay my opponent's
just playing Super well right now yeah
I'm scared and I've got no time and this
is the worst Mouse I've ever used a a
bad tour okay let's bad Tradesman always
complain about his tours grind it out
like a Grandmaster my opponent just
Blended a rook but I didn't take it
whoops and we'll first down to 13
seconds now oh my gosh
ah
this is
[Music]
oh my God but it's pre-moving okay I'm
gonna get it I'm gonna get it am I gonna
get it
wow what a game what a fight our viewers
are too strong that was not fair I feel
like I was stitched up but there you go
the Opera browser try it at home
you're gonna go download the first ever
chest themed browser and it's all on on
Opera and right now action is on as
Magnus Carlsen failed to win that first
game against Jana Palm Nashi a golden
opportunity and it all came down to dust
as Jan managed to survive that one he's
ready to go and there we have it Ian
starts with the white pieces goes with
the King spawn opening and we've got a
sicilian David with a big smile yeah so
still for the kill that's our good
friend James Canty would say and it's a
bishop B5 check Sicilian it's actually
quite rare to see Magnus play the move
D6 on the last turn but napoleonishi not
surprised perhaps having prepared this
for the world championship match back in
2021 and gives a check with this bishop
he had success remember against Anish
giri using this yesterday and Simon
surprised by magnus's opening choice
um I'm glad he's played the Sicilian I
mean we've seen him play it now and
again in the tour and we often get
really exciting positions I was hoping
that Yan would have pushed for D4 and we
got you know we were got an open
Sicilian but this is a very sensible
approach from Jan and uh I'm kind of
expecting Jan to have a bit more energy
in this game after saving that draw I
mean when when you save a game like that
you're like well you feel un you know
undefeatable because uh what what can be
you know what can beat you
um and D3 now played I I mean seems very
very standard stuff so far yeah very
standard stuff uh not the open Sicilian
that we're used to seeing that we really
enjoy commentating on uh where both
sides kind of Castle and opposite flanks
and start going through each other's
Kings D3 hints had a slower approach I
think you're right napongi just really
confident after the last game and
already one minute up on the clock
meaning he has maybe won the opening
battle Magnus just deciding how to
develop his pieces I'm wondering what
about the plans for both sides obviously
it's about a fight for the center it is
the opening after all but this last move
maybe it's just going to build up really
slowly maybe he's going to move his
Knight back and go for like a weird
Grand Prix uh potentially because uh
yeah possibly for the f4s
Yeah you mentioned David the big
question for Magnus is how does he want
to develop the basis and for the queen
side Bishop it's clear you want it on B7
by advancing the B Pawn e to B6 or B5
but I think what Magnus is really
thinking about where does he want his
King side Bishop does he want to advance
the e-pawn to E6 and then develop it
towards the center of the board or will
we see a fan cattle and that's why he's
slowed down because that will determine
the kind of middle games that we get
where he places that King side Bishop
yeah slow down being the kind of
operatives words that Magnus Carlson
very rarely slows down in positions he's
comfortable in or the positions he likes
especially this early in the game uh so
a bit strange to see Magnus in the tank
here for almost two minutes uh like you
said to Tanya all of those plans very
logical very healthy moves uh you just
have to move at some point and remember
napoleonishi is so fast he's lightning
quick when he wants to be Magnus needs
to speed up yeah he needs to speed up
but while he is in the think about his
approach and he does take a decision we
will jump in on the other game Maxim
washer with the black piece is about to
kick off against the chakra mamajaro of
shark playing with white expecting
another king spawn opening here and
perhaps another Sicilian but it starts
with the Queen spawn it starts with one
D4 and uh Maxine vacher Graf he goes
back towards his beloved grunfeld
defense uh something he was synonymous
with throughout his career until
recently with Ashley degrath has really
been switching things up he's branched
out he's kind of added more openings to
that repertoire and look at this it
looks very symmetrical so far Simon uh
the only difference being that white
porn on C4 can trade off white with
slightly more space
what do you think of this opening
approach no attack yet for namajara
knife a very very positional approach
from mamajara for mean uh obviously
these players can play in all all sorts
of styles that Elite level
um and he's just moving his Knight out
now uh I guess slightly better for white
because as you said David you've got
these two pawns versus kind of one Pawn
in the center so you have a bit more
flexibility there
um but black has no problems from the
opening either you know black can
develop his pieces uh with ease as well
and um this will be interesting to see
how it develops do you take with a pawn
it and they take with a bishop a dynamic
Choice there from mvl uh he could have
gone for a more symmetrical structure
and this is keeping the game a bit more
alive this move at least yeah I like
this last move from Russia the groove at
least from a uh drama point of view he
does not go for the kind of solid
positional approach of going for
symmetrical Pawn structure as you
mentioned Simon it's all about Styles
and he wants dynamism he wants his
pieces to have energy it also comes at
the cost of weight uh having extra
Central pawns now on the E and D files
it's two versus one it's a white kind of
traditionally would be pretty happy here
with a small Advantage but yeah I think
both sides have reason to be happy looks
very balanced so far
B3 white getting ready to fiancato it's
been a day of fiancatos in all openings
we saw the hippo earlier from
um Nakamura we saw the Catalan from
Dennis lazovic here we see kind of a
hybrid of all these different openings
yeah
yeah and while white is looking at
developing that Bishop for maxim it will
be about also finishing his own
development we can imagine that night
from B8 landing on B4 at a good moment
wire is six and the play developing in
this one let's jump back and get an
update as this heats up we will take a
look at Magnus versus Jana pamushi and
wow there is a blow in the center we
left it last discussing the development
possibilities and Magnus did choose the
ideas that we were looking at E6 Bishop
E7 fan cuttering the queen side bishop
and striking lacks the one that strikes
in the center first
yeah and also napo's used as f porn so
um it's uh it's quite an interesting
position I've had quite a lot of
experience in this kind of position from
the white side because it's kind of what
what you want in a Dutch opening uh
which is one of my favorite openings and
um I I I generally like White's position
in this kind of structure because I I
think those two pawns uh that white has
are very flexible
um you can you can use them at the right
moment to start an attack you can also
bring your queen around
um we saw Mama jarov do this against uh
mvo in the previous game get your Queen
near your opponent's king and if you're
really courageous uh which Snapper is
you might even bring old Gary into the
game and just start shoving him at the
board so it's uh but it is of course
quite solid for black as well I mean
Black's not in any immediate danger but
uh it's just maybe a personal preference
of what side you like and I would take
white here all day long
Simon you're the expert here with this
type of Pawn structure you mentioned a
few plans what do you predict
napoleonishi will play you mentioned
he's Brave is he going to go for the
pawn storm I mean I maybe maybe move the
queen first uh makes sense I I guess E1
but E2 is a good solid Square as well
but yeah I'd like to see him move the G
Port it's happened Gary the DuPont come
on come on Gary and uh I like it I mean
it looks like gamut because the queen
can come to G2 if you want to play
positionally and this last move from
Magnus is an excellent move really good
move for Magnus and uh this is a key
idea you need to get that Central Square
for your pieces and uh one thing you
should always avoid as black I think is
pushing that pawn in the center forwards
because you want to keep uh the D file
the open line in the middle open
um you don't want to close it down
because that gives white a free attack
on the king side uh it looks very
tempting to do that because you gain
space but actually it's not a good idea
keep the lines open uh to get counter
play but great move for Magnus said
really nice move yeah yeah and that's uh
the Mind Games at work here Napoleon
actually he's going for the jugular he's
going for magnus's throat uh for the
black king here he's throwing pawns
forward but Magnus had preempted that
predicted it and he replies immediately
that's where the top players they change
the pace of the game uh okay G5 kicks
back the Black Knight but uh especially
when the opponents play moves that
they're fearful of they often reply
instantly because they're not uh kind of
lying down uh without a fight they just
want to say I'm prepared I'm ready I'm
not scared and right now I would be
scared with black I must admit
especially if all the white porns start
flooding forward but Magnus does have
counter play of his own he will install
a black knight in White's territory on
D4 and he is the one who can open up the
center as well uh at Will D takes E4 and
that's the key point right usually when
you want to do these flank attacks on
the king side especially when you've
castled on the same side as well getting
that ambitious Bond storm rolling
usually usually you want the center to
be blocked so that your king can remain
safe but black having the flexibility at
the right time to open up that Center
and with that open up that powerful
Bishop in B7
this ambitious play by Yan yes it's a
commentators Delight a lot of fun to
watch but it can easily backfire as well
it can be very dangerous with that
knight from B8 heading to that D4 Square
which will tie down White's Queen to
defend the C2 pawn and a potential D
takes E4 I'm liking Black's position
here wow and it's Yan who actually opens
up the center yeah I I kind of like this
movie because he'd love to get his F
Pawn rolling as well but
um I think he made some good points here
Tanya and the Knight on D2 is pretty
ugly right maybe you can go Knight C4
here is that is that is that what he's
trying to do you want to unravel your
pieces somewhat and there if you can
move that nearer the center nearer to
the king side
um it could could give you some more
options that's really creative Simon
Knight C4 just utilizing the fact that
the black Bishop is not defend ended so
Paul takes night met by Bishop takes
Bishop of course but uh okay he went for
something else he played Bishop back to
G2 slightly mysterious and maybe now the
idea Simon that you mentioned Knight C4
bring it into the center and the other
plan would be of course to start
throwing pawns forward anyway but now
that the middle of the board is slightly
more open it makes less sense to go for
a flank attack yeah I mean you could
even try to swing The Rook over if you
want to be really really root one get
the Rook to H3 you get the queen to H5
and threaten Checkmate but
um there's a lot of I mean I wouldn't be
comfortable if I was black here it's
just more fun for white to play and the
kind of position where you can start an
attack in in various ways and that's
what nepo needs nepo is fantastic when
he's attacking so he's got the kind of
position he'd be very happy to have
really dynamically and wow good call
there Simon Knight C4 on the board and
this time it also hits the B6 spawn as
the queen on d8 has been disconnected
defending that pawn because of magnus's
last move so Knight B6 is a threat and
uh if black was to actually move that
knight from C7 to E6 white also has the
option to put more pressure on that
Central Square Magnus just simply
ignores it he's inviting white to
actually capture the B6 pawn and that
feels like a pawn that I would want to
grab his white wow that could be another
Pawn look at magnus's body language I
mean
I I can't miss that I don't know it's
Matt's occasionally Magnus does these
really strange blunders and I think he
missed that somehow I mean blind spot
what happened there I mean Blackness
blunders it's nearly always to do with
knights we've seen it multiple times uh
just in the last year or two one move
blunders and sometimes he forgets his
opponent's Knights are there we saw in
the speed Chess Championship final he
hung his queen against Nakamura in one
game because of the opponent's Knight he
forgot where it was standing what it was
defending and yeah he's lost up one not
just one point two points and uh for me
the strangest thing is that the
evaluation bar hasn't reacted that much
still says that black is fine it's all
about might not have reacted but Magnus
really did react at that moment he was
uh quite disgusted with what just
happened and another strange thing is
that Magnus reacted before he even
blundered uh the pawn on B6 he kind of
went like this after white played Knight
to C4 meaning that okay maybe he just
missed the opponent's move or
well maybe this is a genius and it's
just a bluff
that uh maybe will pay off his two pawns
down but the evaluation Bar says okay
it's still within acceptable you know
what when the best player in the world
blunders
is still not a blunder he's so you know
he blunters two pause and it's actually
just a sacrifice because he seems to
have pretty good compensation from
blundering to pawns he's the only player
in the world who can do that right it's
yeah it's it's crazy you know I mean in
game one he he made that
uncharacteristic mistake with Rook G3
and now this sort of a blind spot giving
away two pawns uh Magnus Carlson is
maybe Human After All yeah let's jump in
maybe do a quick action replay and then
I want to find out uh how much
compensation black has uh for the pawns
here uh we'll go back to Knight to C4 a
nice move suggested by Simon hitting an
undefender porn and Magnus either forgot
or he allowed this Pawn uh to disappear
Knight takes B6 now and was a double
attack hitting the rook in the corner
and hitting the spawn and suddenly if we
fast forward to the game position I
guess the composition lies in this
Knight being so glorious
kind of having influence over a bunch of
squares Black's Bishop as well
potentially has some ideas against the
white king if things open up and what
does white play how much compensation
would you guys say
if you didn't see the evaluation bar for
example if you're one of the players
um maybe like
I don't know yeah enough I think in in a
practical like rapid game enough uh I
would say um because it's quite easy for
black to play I mean maybe black can
just try to put a rook on the open file
improve the pieces generally
um
but yeah I mean I can't it doesn't it
doesn't you know
it's not completely convincing either is
it so and what just plays the most
natural looking move developing a base
and the eval bar drops down further
saying that now black has uh has enough
compensation and I think it comes down
to the to those pawns on the king side
put that F Pawn on F2 the G pawn and G3
if only pawns could move backwards and
then we're talking about two extra pawns
but with the play on the king side and
the B Line open the B2 pawner Target the
D4 square a big weakness black snipe
nicely posted on F5 and D4 I think
enough compensation Simon as you
mentioned yeah she's trying to cash in
now Magnus he's got one of the two
sacrificed pawns back and Rook takes B2
now he's got an active Rook yeah adding
to the mix yes white has a beautiful
Bishop on the light squares but it might
be to do with that King you mentioned
Tanya
well this one's still anyone's game who
will recover oh my gosh what just
happened the evaluation bar has just
turned all black wow
G5 he can sacrifice his Queen and win on
the spot
oh my god well Magnus Carson find this
queen tastes cheese incredible we wow
Magnus Carlson we will show this either
way will he give up his Queen right now
just under 10 minutes he should find
this I mean he would have found it by
now though because it's four straight
mate right so maybe he hasn't seen look
at the publishing his eyes as well
I think nepo sees it sees it and what's
magda's thinking about he hasn't seen it
if he would see it this is a check
checkmate maybe he's looking at Bishop
F4 or something because uh it's a free
full move Checkmate isn't it how many
votes minus 100 yeah that's that's a lot
yeah
forced Checkmate and the problem he can
barely contain his emotions he's trying
to hide it here he's trying to keep a
poker face but practice
he's got to win and there's not even
that much to calculate he doesn't find
it unbelievable
that is Carson missed a Checkmate entry
wow look at the publishing on the camera
he is so relieved can can Magnus see uh
nepo's reactions because uh I mean can
they see each other's cameras because
that might be I think if Magnus would
have he would have known at that moment
because Yan reacted Yan is reacting even
now he's got that smile on his face he
knows what just happen look at that and
uh Queen takes G5 this is the move it's
not easy to spot unless you see the
evaluation bar unless you know there's
something to see but napometry spotted
it Magnus did not Magnus missed it the
whole idea is you give up your queen
Pawn takes Queen the black Bishop swoops
in with a check and the Black Knight
does the business The Rook protects the
bishop the Black Knight traps the king
this would have ended the game
remarkable what what a spot and you know
I think Yan is still the only one who's
who spotted it
look at his reaction there that is oh
he's gone to have a little lay down
after that so uh ah there look at that
he's sitting in the corner like a
naughty child yeah so he narrowed
I missed Queen Dex G5 a Checkmate in
three yeah and Magnus Carlsen can't
believe it
I don't think we've ever seen a reaction
like that we've nearly never seen a
missed opportunity like that from the
world's best player and who's gonna
recover Magnus looks nice draw he's had
enough now
and uh the thing is you can't even move
the King after that check as well I mean
it was force check mate I mean there was
no way to avoid it because the Knight
would have come in at the same time and
uh I I've never seen that before you
know missing a mate in free from the
World Champ you know I stayed a world
champion the best player in the world
oh and now he has to refocus he really
doesn't want to play chess right now
yeah oh my gosh and and the problem is
that it's not
it's not turned around but
it's the one putting pressure now blacks
Knight on E3 is hanging blacks Rook on
B2 is hanging complete disbelief on both
these players David we've got to do an
action replay of what Magnus Carlson
just missed yeah let's jump in again to
show that dramatic moment and to explain
what's going on now because it is a full
turnaround uh here the Black Knight is
jumped in attacking the White Queen
attacking The Rook will come to this
position but Queen takes G5 would have
ended things as we showed Pawn takes
Queen would have ended in a nice brutal
and uh quick Checkmate the king in the
corner uh court but as Simon points out
it's also important to spot that the
white king If It Moves uh this would
have allowed a different type of
trackmate pattern now it's the Knight
that delivers a track opening up lines
for the black queen to use and next it
would have been the black queen this
time delivering a mate using the second
round this game would have been over I
think the match would have been over
psychologically instead Magnus missed
this he jumped in with a very natural
night Fork I think it was just the fact
that this was so uh tempting that uh
tricked him here but suddenly let's
catch up with the current position this
is the position we're left with Magnus
is the exchange down after Knight to E3
the White Queen moved but after Knight
takes Bishop it was the black Rook that
disappeared the key attacker here and uh
Magnus he's still got ideas of Checkmate
but he is so angry at himself and the
White Queen can swoop to the defense
that's the difference uh for example and
the game is going on white is material
up though and Magnus it's gonna be so
hard for him to get over that
disappointment
and I think that's going to be the big
challenge for Magnus to actually forget
what he's missed very often in these
cases it's just best to not even realize
that you've missed something and it took
Magnus a little bit of time uh Jan
spotted it after making that mistake he
knew it he was smiling he was laughing
and if only Magnus Carlson had taken a
look at his camera if only he had seen
his opponent at that moment he would
have known that there's something in
this position what a huge mess and what
a moment we just witnessed
massive massive Miss and that could turn
this match around and maybe you think
about the first game Magnus was
completely winning in the first game and
uh he he didn't like complete that uh he
allowed Yan to get right back into it
and in this game he missed the Checkmate
in like three moves uh I mean how many
times do we see that I mean I know
kramnik missed the one move Checkmate
once against the computer talk about the
AI uh championships but you rarely see
that and uh it happens gives us all a
little bit of Hope
and uh yeah this this position though is
it it's really messy I mean it could go
either way here I mean black can win a
pawn here but you don't really want to
go Queen takes G5 anymore you're
probably sick of that move by now I've
never play in that move anymore uh which
would win a pawn back I mean maybe you
should do I don't know but it this this
really to my eyes just looks completely
random now the white king is weak but
white has more material here so uh yeah
again it's hard to hard to assess what
what will happen yeah and uh I was
wondering whether Magnus could recover
from the disappointment Napoleon looks
uh just so kind of entertained by the
fact that both Players missed that uh he
looks Disturbed as well and yeah who
will recover who will kind of get into
the heart of this new position uh faster
that's the key this is so much Beyond
then what is just happening on the board
now because it really has become a mind
battle it has become an inner game for
these two players with what we just saw
missing a Checkmate in three the game
would have been just over and for Magnus
Carlsen how he reacted it was clear he
was distraught but he needs to now get
that composure back because there is
pressure on the board there is a
material deficit on the board uh Jana
abomishi not only with that exchange but
also that Bishop on B2 a really powerful
Bishop a critical moment for Magnus does
he trade the Queens with the pawn
capture that you're pointing out Queen
G5 making sure that there are no check
mating ideas on the wrong diagonal and
let's just point out that trick Knight
jumps in picks up that queen or does he
play for more does he try to play
against Jan's King but in that bargain
also some weaknesses on his own King
side
yeah I think there's three roads to go
down either you trade off Queens go to
an end game at this point maybe
psychologically uh kind of preferable
for both players just because there
won't be any Checkmate drama here but if
we do a quick count at the end it's
still White having a rook for Black's
night and pawn way ahead there and with
so many open files it's hard to believe
that uh black will be able to survive
this White's Rook maybe we'll use the B
file later on so I don't know if Magnus
really wants to head for this right now
Knight takes Pawn looks very tempting as
well attacking the bishop but if the
bishop just moves then it has only
opened up a line for the white Rooks to
use and still material down for black uh
the Third Kind of option here for me
would be uh going uh for the white king
just keeping the tension as you
mentioned Tanya just keeping protection
of the Black Knight and hoping that it
causes enough of a nuisance
and yeah I'm still smiling
he still can't believe what just
happened
five minutes each though
oh yeah this is gonna be crazy no matter
what happens in this game now I have a
feeling there's going to be a few twists
and turns ahead just because uh it's
pure psychology
how was perhaps the biggest miss that I
have seen in the Champions Chester this
season I was a bit worried with David I
thought he's having a fit yeah because
he said it was like whoa what's going on
I'd love to see that on the camera again
because I've never seen I've never seen
you say animated there David and and
yourself Tanya so it was uh it was yeah
it was and what a spot I mean David so
you see tactics better than the best
player ever but yeah and I'm not sure I
would have done without the help yeah
that that is a major factor isn't it
evaluation and Simon you made such a
good point in that moment because Magnus
he wasn't playing it instantly and
that's the kind of move when you spot it
it's on the board and the more seconds
that he was taking you had a feeling
that Magnus hasn't seen the trick I mean
you either see it or you don't and and
it doesn't it I mean it's I I would I
wouldn't have seen it I mean it's like
Queen takes porn and the and the you
know the pawn is defended by Pawn so you
know why would you see it and uh if you
see it it's like oh my God like I see it
and uh it's clearly just winning so you
play it very quickly uh in the position
but still quite remarkable and the fact
that Magnus did see it a couple of moves
later or move later that is the
heartbreaking thing that's the
Heartbreak you really don't want to know
about that until until the game is well
and truly over because you're going to
think about it for for a long time I
mean not just today I think he'll be
here yeah he'll have Queen takes G5 in
his dreams tonight uh Magnus Carlson and
that's where it's sometimes better not
to see anything than to see everything
uh sometimes it's better to see less
because I think if Magnus hadn't
realized a move later that Queen takes
G5 would have been possible then he'd
just be kind of in this position he'd be
defending and uh pretty kind of happy
pretty confident but uh clearly it's
still on his mind and unreminded uh of a
game from Norway chess where Vichy Anand
he blundered against mamajarov and he
realized that namajarov had a queen
sacrifice to force Checkmate and and
couldn't keep a poker face when manager
got back to the board he just resigned
and my major was like why why did you
resign so uh sometimes these top players
they miss things it's it's credit to
napoleoni that he kept a poke face
didn't react until Magnus had made the
move I mean you don't expect it I
suppose that's the thing isn't it I mean
you don't expect you're a strong player
to to blunder the king blunder the queen
and sometimes it happens then you're not
ready for it but going back to the
position this is this is looking great
for Yan now because he's just a clear
exchange for a porn up his King's a
little bit exposed but
um it looks it looks like he should be
winning now I mean I don't think Magnus
has managed to recover from this
and it is a hard spot to recover from
and Harry the H Pawn goes up the board
H5 a big threat Magnus needs to watch
out for the back rank Magnus Carlton in
on the defense in this one and it's not
going to be an easy task he's also down
on the clock uh the one thing that
Magnus is hoping for is to get that
Knight to E6 to block up the e-line if
Yan can't trade off the Queens the end
game also really favors white simply
because black spawn structure all of the
pawns on the queen side will fall apart
but I think Jan is going for magnus's
King now yeah he could win in multiple
ways here Jan he can win uh maybe even
on the clock but on the board as you say
Tanya by trading off Queens by going for
checkmate black trying to set up a
fortress we know what Magnus thinks
about those but uh it looks like a
far-fetched dream right now
white can kind of bully black with the
inspector of uh Queen trade and maybe
that should be enough but the evaluation
bar dropping it does and you know David
when you're playing against Magnus you
see something he's just Blended upon the
C4 Pawn will not next will drop and
defending the F7 Pawn so the queen
captures in C4 winning the pawn but also
saving his own Pawn on F7 and look at
that Jan laughing oh dear I think they
just want to end this game I think
they've both had enough of this game
they should just offer a draw right just
just get this game over with because uh
there's some remarkable blunders going
on and again now Magnus has full
compensation he has two pawns for The
Rook it's equal and material anyone's
game is he gonna try and win this one
wow why not I mean I might as well yes
white skiing Under Fire the night
jumping to E6 yeah the queen right now
falls back defending that F7 Square the
C Pawn can start marching up Knight
coming from D7 Magnus might get
ambitious now
makes sense I mean uh all right here it
comes I mean like you know black does
have the safer King uh so you you can
certainly play on a bit here yeah some
of the Grand Master games that we've
seen throughout the Champions chess tour
they have incredibly high accuracy
levels uh sometimes we see 96 98 even 99
I don't even want to know this uh this
game like 88 88
but maybe affected by that one miss yeah
looking upon issue still laughing uh he
knows that black has got everything
covered now everything I'm under control
just the drop of that white Seaport
means that actually even end games now
are not uh entirely clear and with white
open King just you cannot go in the
attack White Queen forced to be a
Defender Black's Knight will soon come
in as well I think I prefer to be black
here if I if I had to pick a color
because uh the knight in Queen if they
if they get boogie in together they can
they can start creating loads of
problems so yeah maybe move the night
out or you know the night there not an
f8 no mate that's true yeah it keeps
your king very safe
but yeah maybe push the Black Sea Pawn
or back it up yeah get ready to either
take that remaining white Pawn on A5 or
kind of propel the Black Sea Pawn
forward actually if White's apron drops
there's zero losing chances for black
any end game would be safe then and
there might be winning chances for black
if that Knight now jumps to E6
threatening more checks on that F4
Square so a Yan trying to trade off the
Queens to make sure that the king
remains uh safe but I think it makes a
lot of sense for Magnus to keep the
Queens on the board even if the ending
is fine with that c Pawn you don't want
to take any chances with a weak A6 spawn
you want to go for white skin uh yeah
and offering a repetition I take the
draw I don't think he's gonna do it I
think we're gonna see this game go on I
mean uh they've had enough fun in this
game I think I think they should just
like take the drawer I was just thinking
about it what do you think David is
Magnus going to repeat I think the
practical decision the professional
decision would be to repeat here he's
one minute down after all on the clock
uh White still has enough material to
cause some problems but it is Magnus
Carlson does okay yeah yeah
um
decision has been made
and Magnus Carlson he has to play Queen
C7 and that would be a threefold
repetition both players shaking their
head what a roller coaster game this has
been just unbelievable yeah she still
doesn't believe what has just happened
uh I don't know who should be more
relieved after that one
it's hard to say I mean look at the look
at the body languages there I mean it's
crazier I haven't seen anything like
that in this this tournament so yeah
saw me it was sometimes David I don't
even know which one you're gonna pick
what what was the moment for you I think
we have to recap what we just missed uh
it could have been move of the year
instead it was Miss of the Year from
Magnus Carlson proving that not all
draws are boring Queen takes G5 in this
position after a blunder from
janapomnishi would have ended the game
on the spot a queen sacrifice for the
win forcing for example Pawn takes queen
and the night delivering Checkmate on G3
the white king cut in the corner uh
Queen h35 would have also ended the game
remember after King H1 with a night
sacrifice and this would have been
Elementary stuff for Magnus Carlson
Quinta H2 Checkmate instead he missed
this was lucky to survive with the draw
and both players move on after all of
that drama
drama
crazy moves and this
was survived a mate entry and from
Magnus Carlsen everything was fine he
didn't even spot it until this moment
it's check check and Checkmate and he
cannot believe it
foreign
drama once in a lifetime we'll get these
types of images yeah look at him yeah
very common reacting to that moment
Queen takes G5 when he spotted it
very excitable yeah I was just so
shocked to spot a tactic uh that Magnus
missed it I mean that happened so rarely
uh but yeah what an opportunity and we
talked about recovery I mean both
players managed to get their act
together just about there at the end but
I expect more uh yeah I mean it's going
to be hard to settle down now in the two
remaining games of the day we are
expecting more drama to continue as this
one does end in a draw the score is 1-1
in both these matches the players need
to recover we need to recover you guys
watching need to recover that there is
action that continues and clearly we
can't miss any of it what have we just
seen we will be back with game three of
the AI Cup winners bracket we'll see you
in just a few foreign
[Music]
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
be your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
okay if I lose a game before I go to
sleep I have to play until I win and
once I win a game then I will play
another
why isn't my chess rating going up
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
Crow the game find your local group or
take the lead at meetup.com chess and
set up your chess Community we've had so
much drama and action in these first two
games in the winners semi-finals and
it's been all eyes on the Magnus Yan
match up we've also had a lot of
fighting chess with two draws as Maxine
vashiella Graf takes on a chakra to
aggressive players creative players and
we know that when they meet it is a
fight fire on the board and here's what
chakra mamadarov has to say about the
shock attack about his own style of play
Okay match your style just to play
interesting chess Fighting Chess I never
I you know I every time think about
results here before the game I think
every time it's better not to lose and
better to play safe just but when I go
to chessboard I sit I think okay I need
to play Beautiful very nice yes and I
try to play show my good chess I mean
for me it's a first of all enjoy from my
game and not more interest
to try to find very interesting ideas a
very good sacrifice I mean just to play
very interesting very good chess middle
game yeah I mean middle game because
it's opening is every time okay I try to
play interesting but it's not my good
how to say good part of my chess is
Middle game I love too much but it's 95
not in game in my chest because I lose a
very faster I went very fast
end games I think in one tournament is
maybe maximum one game it will be one
game or not normally I finish in media
games
fantastic now um biggest weakness then
is some very important in games in my
life because how I say every time I play
chess in Middle game so also maybe some
opening ideas because I every time
change my openings every time because I
never
work very serious in one opening I try
to play interesting some another
openings maybe it's two yeah end game
and opening
all about the middle game for chakra or
Mama diaro opening and games just don't
matter when you've got this aggressive
attacking style of play he has been two
times World Junior Champion the sixth
highest rated player in chess history
and a two-time tall Memorial winner in
fact his chest style the kind of tactics
that we see from him the sacrifices that
we see for him for me it's very
reminiscent of
School of chess yeah certainly he's a
really unique uh player you know a lot
lots of players they have the same kind
of style nowadays but uh Shack like
stands out and that's what makes him so
special I mean he loves sacrificing he
loves the initiative he doesn't care too
much about material he never gets to the
ending that's great I love that and um
he should be a lot of people's favorite
player because he's got that
entertaining style and uh you know some
of his best games they're just
incredible I mean he plays he's played
some really amazing stuff in his
lifetime and uh he's almost a joy to
watch right yeah he's a throwback to
those great masters of old where they
just Embrace their style they don't care
about being Universal they don't care
about kind of covering their weaknesses
he just plays to his strengths every
time entertaining us and when he was
world number two I think back in 2018 we
talked about him as a potential uh
Challenger for Magnus Carlson and when
he's in TOT form he can beat anyone he
can Crush anyone in 20 moves and like
you said his best game collection I
recommend to everyone at home yeah such
romantic chess we get to see when chakra
mamajorova plays and it's always a
delight to see his masterpieces and I
think it was a Champions Chester where
we saw and it was against Anish Gary
David if I'm not mistaken why he
sacrificed every single piece a Roka
Bishop a knight and eventually the queen
and went on to win that game yeah poor
Anish just on the wrong side of a
masterpiece that will be one of his kind
of Evergreen Immortal games there uh
manager but that's just one of many I
remember multiple different Queen
sacrifices no doubt he would have
spotted Queen takes G5 in that game uh
yeah too soon but uh yeah attacking
genius attacking genius and I think it
was Queen takes G7 in that game against
the niche where he did sacrifice uh that
Queen incredible Play Always when he
gets his kind of positions but he is
playing against Maxima Sherlock now
Maxime definitely also an aggressive
player but more Universal uh
theoretician very strong opening
preparation and we see that he is also
the 2021 World Blitz Champion a speech
specialist he made it to the semi-finals
of the speed test Championship
he is the number two player from France
currently David he's got a more
Universal style compared to chakriar
where do you feel that this match up
against the two of them what would be
the key area that would be decisive well
if it gets to a position where it's pure
calculation I think Maxine vashilograph
has the advantage any end games I think
he has the advantage as well and if he
catches Mama jarov cold in the opening
uh maybe he can hope because Maxine
knows everything there is to know about
his repertoire then again Shakura if
he's on the front foot if he's with the
initiative the momentum that's where
he's the favorite
and that's the key get it getting the
initiative for shark when he gets his
kind of position he's Unstoppable so uh
he's got to try and make it a bit more
complicated I think in in the opening
and what's the key for the other two
guys uh Magnus Carlson and yeah she is
the key to just forget everything that's
just happened I mean learning how to
Checkmate you're learning how to chat
mate yeah that's right the basics the
basics Go Back to Basics but I had to
take the first two games with very
peculiar you missed you missed a
Checkmate in three both players doing
the first game you're like plus free and
you don't win who knows what's going to
happen in this one right
oh yeah and I think he's still thinking
about what has just happened uh
continues there to react but he's got to
leave that behind as he is playing with
the black pieces uh for Magnus definite
frustration having a winning position in
game one and then missing the Checkmate
in game two he starts with white
and the King spawn opening King's Pawn
opening will it be a repeat of game one
where Magnus very quickly took the
Queens off the board and established a
decisive Advantage no this time it is a
main line of the Petrov far more
theoretical I think far more comfortable
here for napoleonishi who will have
studied this before this was his uh
opening repertoire this was his home
territory for that world championship
match that famous match in 2021 Magnus
now offering a trade of knights it's
very likely that we'll see a lot of
pieces disappear from the board here as
well the punishi just looking off to his
left
often that's when players are in recall
mode trying to remember their opening
Theory or room service chatting with
yeah I think he's chatting with someone
it could be room set this year it's like
uh yes I will have some uh I will have
your uh final stake please you know say
yeah I think he is over in Amsterdam at
the moment right playing in uh 11 12
competitions say
um there we go Knights traded off the
board Bishops will most likely leave as
well there's like Square Bishops staring
at each other uh maybe he's just talking
to himself I often do the same it's like
why didn't you study this what was the
move here why is your memory so bad I've
become a big fan of nepo over the years
you know because I just love his uh you
know I love his chest but I love how
Dynamic he is right you know he he's uh
he's so emotional you know like uh with
his faces and stuff he's really good fun
to watch
so definitely a nepo fan
yeah and I think a lot of us are because
of his style of play and just his
personality as well the last game this
game two that we've been talking about
right Magnus missed that Checkmate but
in the end Jan had his chance it could
have been him actually that takes the
lead in the match he was up in exchange
dominating position but that one move
blunder giving up the pawn so that's
something as well that Jan needs to
forget and probably a little bit of
relief for Magnus in those last moments
yeah we should also mention uh that
levitov tournament uh you reference
there Yan did win that one it did finish
today uh he won the event and he's
played a lot of Chess in the last few
days so maybe fatigue setting in for him
Magnus of course one of the most active
players on the circuit uh maybe
tiredness a factor influencing some of
these decisions I'm surprised that
naponishi's thinking uh this is still a
relatively well-known position as far as
I'm aware maybe just trying to dodge
some of magnus's
opening prep
so yeah just looks very balanced here
slightly different uh imbalance Pawn
structure but
yeah I think both players still
recovering Magnus smiling taking turns
to react to that previous game yeah I've
never seen Magnus react like the way he
did in that last game this entire season
and we see a little kg approaching this
one a more sane position a more calm
approach the other matchup Maxima
Sherlock against chakra Muhammad yarov
is also ready for liftoff this is game
three the score so far is level and
we're seeing a king spawn opening and
the Spanish being blitzed out yeah for
the second time today it is the Spanish
opening between these two and okay new
move to D6
the delayed Steiner stylist yeah the
steinist variation that's right and uh
this is um this is the idea and this can
be quite aggressive because you kind of
delay you can move your F Pawn sometimes
and this is just the kind of thing you
can't you would expect from a major of
something a little bit out of the book
and uh White going for the Roxy bind
trying to just grip the center grip
those squares in the middle which seems
wise against manageroff try to get it to
a slower pace of the game
yeah any opening variation named after a
former world champion like the Stanis
variation uh it's going to be solid but
white does have more space here what
would be the how and the howl opening do
we do we have it
oh love it love it I'm so annoyed at
myself right now I was gonna say G5 is a
possibility that Majora has actually
played G5 after White's uh move C3
rather than C4
I remember him playing a really famous
game just a few years back he's going
for the white king wow but black hasn't
developed so this is extremely risky
look at the evaluation bar as well not
really approving of Black's audacity
this is I mean this must be fairy right
with the speed they're playing at and um
I love these G5 pushers typical Shack
and we were talking about his style and
he just goes and pushes the g-pawn at
the ball like a lunatic you've got to
love it gotta love it right gotta love
it he doesn't care about openings on
what end games you're never gonna get
there T5 G4 what an approach uh and the
maximum instead of saving his Knight
because the Deep one was attacked he
does go for counter offense
yeah I think two solid draws were enough
Acura has had uh his full of all these
uh drawers and now he just wants a
decisive result no matter what and right
now this is a counter-attack white
knight is likely to be captured but then
the Black Knight would disappear it's
gonna be a very odd Pawn structure there
but the key is that white is leading in
development uh Black's kingside pieces
yet to participate in the action white
king relatively safe for now I don't
really like the fact that Mama drip is
thinking right now because it means that
he's in freestyle mode or can't recall
his opening preparation he eventually
Retreats his Knight
but not a good sign white has more space
in the center now white can just move
his Knight and the evalubar reacts and
I'm also thinking is it because you've
already been uh well very committed on
the king side white can also look at
trading the light Squad bishop and once
the Knight does jump onto H4 you've got
this F5 squares as a stronghold a wide
ahead in development 97 a surprising
decision there
yeah I mean I I you get this kind of
position sometimes in in some Sicilians
and uh I've tried this G5 stuff out and
often the the computer really likes
White's position and I'm never really
sure why it likes it so much but I'm
probably a bit biased because I want to
push my G Pawn all the time but it's
it's it is the weakness of like maybe
opening up the FR and that plan you
mentioned Tanya that looks like a
fantastic plan you know just put the
Knight on this beautiful Square try to
open up the f file and who's going to be
attacking who here this is uh this is
the question very yeah really nice plan
yeah and uh something very similar on
the board almost identical the White
Knight lands on H4 first so not trading
Bishops yet I do wonder whether manager
of now will uh just rid white of that
alternative of that option just by
pushing his Pawn to C6 or B5 cutting the
tension between these two Bishops
because Black's lights go Bishop is a
key defender of those uh squares that
you mentioned especially F5
either way I just don't like the way the
black pieces are really struggling for
energy struggling for scope here
feels like Mama jarov is already playing
kind of life on the edge that's how he
lives that's how he plays chess but
um yeah really really high risk uh brand
of Chess right now
H4 looks strong actually graph in the
driver's seat yeah
nice plan really nice plan on that dark
Squad Bishop also coming into the game
you pointed out a break with F3 but of
course shock is the first one to break
with B5 and it makes a lot of sense
because with all these decisions that
chakra has taken he can't suddenly take
a slow approach anymore because there
are so many weaknesses in Black's Camp
once uh give white two moves and after
the f file opens up you're suddenly a
lot better so B5 he needs to play
concretely I like this move I like this
approach
and is white going to capture on B5 open
up the airline how do you what decisions
do you take on the queen side here as
Maxime
I mean you'd like to move the bishop I
think but is there even a tactic there I
mean can black then uh I mean this is
typical Shaq finding weird tactics okay
I think this is why mvl captured here
because if you move the bishop Knight
takes D5 might might be a tactic
um uh might be
it looks really ropey actually the more
I look at it but and if you go Queen
takes like C6 or something but possibly
and you win the night back here I mean
that that might have been his idea hence
why I think uh mvl just says no I'm not
gonna allow you to do any of these these
ideas yeah so by trading pawns first he
means well he at least hopes that Knight
takes D5 is impossible due to the fact
that Queen takes D5 now does have the
bigger threat of uh crashing through on
F7 so my major does have to take a
timeout no tricks yet uh Knight takes D5
doesn't work so Bishop G7 and watch out
for it later this night is kind of
hanging in the air undefended uh we know
that saying lpdo loose pieces drop off
uh Daniel's favorite thing but uh yeah
right now it's just a really crazy
position it really reminds me actually
of that game we saw earlier in the day
feels like hours ago at this point uh
giri against Nakamura with white having
the advantage maybe on the queen side
but black having far Advanced pawns near
the white king and we know that one
worked out in White's favor I wonder if
this one will too
and the more I looked at the position
the more I liked your idea of breaking
with the F Pawn to F3 does anyone maxims
last move inside is that that Knight on
H4 is feeling a little uncomfortable and
the bishop on G7 wasn't only a
developing move but was also hinting at
Bishop to F6 actually targeting that
Knight on H4 so preemptive move by
Maxine making sure that you've got a
retreating Square on G2 for the night
where it can reroute itself to the
center of the board y83 then
makes a lot of sense and uh I mean the
problem Still Remains so how how Black's
going to get the pieces on the king side
uh into the game
um I don't think you want to play F5
here this is the only poor break you
really have and if you don't play F5 how
do you move the Knight on G8 I mean how
do you move the Knight on E7 uh how do
you I mean where are you putting your
pieces white can develop his Queen side
very easily the Knight Will hop out the
bishop will hop out white has very
simple moves to play here but I'm just
not sure actually how how black is gonna
get those pieces into the game here it's
it they look a bit uncomfortable so I'm
actually picking white in this position
which is a bit sad but yeah but what
happened what happens if black actually
just makes a developing move like Knight
to F6 how does white react yeah maybe
you can play Knights or six maybe that
is the way to do it but just it it
doesn't really seem like a great Square
for the night
um because you can't play F5 now if you
Castle your King's gonna be a whip weak
and uh I mean I mean it might be might
be okay but just soccer agrees with you
he doesn't want any of that and he
actually does advance with Harry the H1
defending G uh defending G4 and maybe
also looking at that night David coming
out from 86 and a potential F5 someday
yeah he's definitely keeping the options
open mama jarov will always play the
most ambitious move if given the
opportunity in any position and uh
Knight H6 it might look
counter-intuitive but it does support
the pawn break and when black is ready
it might take a while uh then he will
try to lash out in the main
expecting him to try and play against
this weakness maybe the White Queen can
step forward the White Knight can start
going for this Pawn white has the
advantage on the queen side because the
points of the Pawns in the center are
pointing in this direction and black
spawns are pointing in this direction uh
so often black will try and play on the
king side on the opposite flank again it
resembles a king's Indian despite this
starting as uh one E4 E5
and uh H5 very slow but it looks like he
has the luxury because the center is
blocked right now so the game will take
a slower turn over the next few moves
unless fashion the gruff uh has
something up his sleeve maybe he wants
to push his F Pawn forward but uh I
think he should develop those pieces
first there we go
good wisdom just if in doubt develop
your pieces bring them to Central
squares which Bishop looks nice and
pretty on E3 yeah
really entertaining thoughts this one uh
by uh both players really playing a very
Dynamic chess and we know this is going
to be a fun fight we will come back to
this but let's quickly check in on the
other match up after all the drama and
what a roller coaster ride this has been
between Magnus Carlsen and Jana pomnishi
and there's an epon moving up the board
things are getting tricky I do see the
eval bar it says the position is still
balanced but when you've got a Pawn on
E6 you've got to be feeling the heat
with black yeah that pawn could step
forward to A7 and it's like deja vu I
talked about that Geary against Nakamura
game from earlier in the day again a
white porn Lance one square away from
promotion the difference here is that
there aren't that many pieces left and
that pawn could be attacked maybe the
black queen and Rook will gang up
against it but Magnus he's an expert in
these types of positions with knights on
the board with Queens he's so good at
pushing Brook spawns because Knights do
struggle against them
what do we think are we surprised the
evaluation part is in the middle um how
much of a practical chance would you
give weight of creating something
yeah I think white must be better right
because of that a pawn it's just so
tricky and uh you've got some squares to
your pieces the queen and the Knight I
have a lot of potential so I definitely
take white here I'm a bit surprised the
evaluation bar is just saying black is
absolutely fine uh in this position I
think I think it was Judith Polgar who
mentioned about Magnus that
um he you've got to get rid of his
knights was that right even though he
does blunder with the Knights sometimes
keep your own Knights get rid of his
camera yeah that's right get rid of his
Knights and he's like so good with the
Knights
um so that the knights remain on the
board here so Queen C7 just trying to
win that pawn now I kind of want to play
D5 but I I
don't know maybe maybe that's just gonna
allow black to start using the pawn so
that's coming in okay Rook A6 that's the
most ambitious move Simon uh mamajarov
would probably have played D5 uh
utilizing this pin but black would have
blocked and the question is uh whether
these two pawns are strong or weak black
now having two connected passes so Rook
A6 maybe it's slightly less high risk
approach Rook takes Pawn now would be
met by Rook takes this one and white
would crack through
um breakthrough on the back rank
looks really scary for black so what is
the defense
yeah
okay not okay seven you just can't allow
that idea of white Rook jumping onto the
eighth rank that would be oh that would
be disaster for black so if not you're
okay seven Brooks C6
is in the air D5 in the air how is uh
Jan keeping things in Balance here yeah
I'm surprised with the valbar not
reacting here I would pick white any day
definitely and this is where computers
can be deceptive it might say 0.00 but
black is the one fighting for the draw
with Kind of Perfect play Black can hold
black can defend but humans aren't
perfect and I think white has far more
room for error a lot of leeway to go
wrong if White Once you can probably
just trade off all the pieces and make a
draw anytime so it's a two result game
white the one playing for the initiative
process of elimination Simon this one
looks really bad Knight to B6 blocking
um the attack of White's Rook because
White's Queen can simply step forward uh
removing this Defender and the pawn will
therefore follow uh this Pawn would drop
so surely it has to be Pawn to C5 in
this position
getting confused with my arrows there
but yeah point to C5
looks like the move yeah just trying to
just trying to exchange some pawns off
to to get closer to the draw right so it
makes makes a lot of sense
and uh yeah a good move if he finds this
he should be okay I think he has to find
this nothing else worked and uh let me
get rid of that Arrow uh pull to C5 the
only way to keep the balance but it
should be enough for black probably I
just should find it there's one's I was
just looking at a silly line after Pawn
of C5 it's always nice to look at City
Line now again man jump back in uh I
mean I wanted I mean it doesn't work but
I was thinking of World Championships
how they've been finished and queen E4
uh I wanted to play and then Rook takes
A7 and I wanted to try to make Queen E8
King H7 Rook H6 work but it just I don't
know why I'm looking at this this is
absolute nonsense but I was just
thinking that this is how Magnus won uh
the World Championships against Sergey
karyakin he he played this exact move
and uh if you can remember probably the
most beautiful move of all time it's not
working in any variation but it's uh
it's something maybe you could you know
just look at at least you know
unfortunately King runs away yeah chance
the way to safety and okay he doesn't
play the move C5 he Retreats his Knight
um yeah this one was not on my radar
it's a really nice move we said Knights
on f8 there are no mate uh mirroring the
previous game between these two and the
idea now is rotates Pawn white uh White
taking upon can be met by getting rid of
White's most dangerous Pawn on A7 so
this one still looks relatively level uh
potentially you could start pushing and
hoping again but black snipe will be
able to blockade a bit later on
creative defense there from the punishi
holding things together still and Magnus
can he continue to create the threats
continue to up the pressure up the ante
against still only white who can win but
for now it's holding an upon this is uh
night move yeah
I'm just waiting for the next big twist
the next big reaction from these two
players at this point and just kind of
fixated on their cameras just as much as
the board
but it definitely feels like Magnus has
finally got rid of those demons uh
finally managed to kind of retune his
brain
yeah
so Magnus putting the pressure in this
one with that a pawn and the threats on
the C6 weakness
we will jump back to this but we've got
quite the action on in the Maxi matchup
look at that position this is chakra
Maxima this is exactly the kind of chest
that we expect from these two
David you've got to make sense Simon
what's going on here
okay let's bring up the board and do a
quick recap because the position has
exploded we thought it might take a
slower turn this is the current position
but uh after white brought his Knight to
D2 this is where we last left it
wow he pressed the chaos button Pawn to
F5 forgetting about peace development
don't try this at home kids uh normally
you want to bring your pieces out you
want to get your king castled first but
he threw a pawn forward opening up lines
and fashion legrath said anything you
can do I can do better Pawn to F4 and
look at the tension now between all of
these Pawns in the middle uh black
captured on passant and White's Queen
came out and after black moved Knight to
H4 is the most recent development Simon
you're the attacking Maestro Among Us
who's attacking who that's the big
question
I think I still like white here I mean
um it looks like wise King is a lot
safer uh White has the extra broken in
the game on F1 and black hasn't castled
as you were showing there and a lot of
those light squares are quite weak so
um yeah white white must be doing well
here in this position because those
reasons and blacks blacks black could
easily go wrong as well right one one
bad move here and it just crumbles uh
and this this position totally crumbles
so this is I don't know I mean it's very
dangerous for the black very hard to
find a good move it's like a big direct
threat right you're just going for that
pawn on F5 black doesn't really have the
time to get the king to safety and what
is safety where is safety uh shock
Castle just makes no sense at all once
you've gone ahead with the spawn
structure decisions being taken on how
to handle the pressure on F5 he goes
ahead with the F4 Pawn which has been
recaptured chakra mom and dad knows
nothing about recapturing he's going for
the kill he brings the Knight forward to
G4 putting pressure on that E3 Bishop if
you take on E5 right now black will have
to recapture with the Knight because
there's a Checkmate on F7 oh watch out
for that Scholars mate type of idea
Knight takes E5 however does attack the
queen and defend the square at the same
time so just about safe but wow just
this is just so creative giving up a
porn kind of long term it looks tempting
for white to push forward I guess the
white king will hide in the corner in
the next few moves he's just kind of
gambling here manager of going all in
he's just pushed his chips to the center
saying okay it's Do or Die time yeah
like it but I mean if this kind of Chess
worked it would be quite remarkable
because it generally doesn't work right
I mean it's a bit too creative because
you're King right I mean if the black
king was tucked up on the queen side in
a very nice position then it'd be a
great sacrifice but it's not I I guess
he had to do it though he's got himself
in his position he's finding very
imaginative ways uh to keep the game
alive and that night is a pretty
beautiful piece but I just don't like
Black's King being stuck in the middle
there yeah Stuck In The Middle With You
being on the eight
that's a song right anyway right now
white is a pawn up and the black king
not enjoying life right now my major if
you'll need to work that uh Shack Magic
but it is still possible still enough
ammunition left I'm expecting the White
Queen to just sidestep one square and
things will get sharp things are already
really sharp in the position the one
thing that works for black is that the
knights on E5 and E7 really control some
key Square so not so easy for white to
come in with a check because a check in
this position would be game over it
would be Checkmate and David the idea is
that you're pointing out about white
side stepping with the queen putting
pressure on the G7 Bishop he does it but
that also invites black to actually
Place The Rook on G8 you not only defend
the bishop in G7 but line up your Rook
against the White Queen and the King
threatening some potential Bishop jumps
creating some threats yeah creating some
threats and this time whose King is
weaker you mentioned any check being
fatal maybe for both sides and I'm
looking at White's light squared Bishop
coming back by D1 hitting Black's uh
Harry the h-born over there instead he's
side steps first getting out of Dodge
nice move there nice safety first move I
saw a feature chat there about embryo's
style being uh similar to Fisher's style
of play are we seeing sort of like a
Fisher with a style battle here it's a
very Fisher type of opening playing uh
the Royal post playing the Spanish
opening White's light squared Bishop was
Fisher's favorite piece if that delivers
the killer blue then maybe Fisher yeah
that major off meanwhile not a question
that he tries to embody tile and often
succeeds it's like Fisher versus fishy
it seems like at the moment but you know
what now is turning a little bit right I
mean he's uh it's just the black king if
the black king could get out of the way
uh um black would be starting to get
very happy but that night is beautiful
in the middle of the board you just I
just can't you know I can't understand
Shaq's chest sometimes it's crazy and uh
this position is like giving me a bit of
a headache but I mean it's uh yeah I
don't know any result any result
possible yeah it's another level of
Chess uh totally different brand of
Chess than we're used to and very a few
in the whole world can kind of have the
imagination to come up with these
sacrifices let's just jump in because
there is a big threat on the board Rook
takes Queen this last move jumping out
the way with the bishop has created this
threatened Queen has to be really
careful where she Treads she has to
defend her Knight I just wonder whether
maximum will get tempted by a queen
sacrifice at some point I'm not sure
right now I don't think you want to for
example take this bishop because at the
very end here black might have some nice
nasty notebooks uh hitting the Rook
hitting the bishop Knight to G4
this looks pretty decent for black but I
wouldn't be surprised if he gets tempted
to sacrifice the queen just to go for
the black king in the near future maybe
Queen to F4 wolf where do you go Simon
I'm yeah on the spot here sorry yeah
nice it's not easy I mean if you go
Queen F2 I suppose it's the same idea
isn't it as Queen Queen F4 and uh what
what does black do here Knight to G4 it
seems also very very normal in the
position yeah and that's the problem
right I mean uh that Knight is causing a
lot of
a lot of issues so yeah we're hesitating
here because it's just such a wild
position he goes all the way back great
air quality at least for maximum
playing in great certain kind of great
uh yeah great uh conditions there coming
to E1 not sure he's liking that but
meanwhile yeah well the bar jumps
between Carson and napomnishy what has
happened over there we've got to take a
look let's quickly head back to Magnus
Carlsen against Yan last we left it felt
like Magnus was putting the pressure he
has won the C6 spawn is there a killer
blow here
feels really really shaky for black
white can give a check for example
White's Rook can lift up to C8 and okay
the most natural move is a strong one
you need the follow-up of course uh the
engine as we see below the board does
confirm white has only one winning move
this is just a once uh kind of blink and
you miss it opportunity but what's the
follow-up what is it Rook theater only
move is king287 how do you finish this
off maybe
Queen on the c2c3 yeah
something like that maybe we show this
because it was a blunder from naponishi
uh maybe just taking his eye off the
ball here looks like root C8 suggested
by the computer is best forcing the
black king to the side of the world and
Simon you had an idea I think in Queen
C2 to force G6 and once you go G6 to try
to get the queen in on the dart squares
so you go Queen C3 and that seems to
force like F6 which is a really
ugly move to play you don't want to play
F6 and to assume there'd be something
here I didn't know what but on the board
and here I guess white could just step
the pawn forward maybe bring his Rook to
C7 instead in the punishi defense with
this creative move Knight to F6 but uh
this is ignored of course taking the
Knight would have lost the white Rook so
he just pushes his Pawn forward and huge
threat Rook C7 could be a killer yeah I
like that the pawn joins the party in
Rook C7 with the Knight on F6 hanging
how do you fight that he is going for
the counter offense with the move B4 on
the board uh that is why it keep
everything intact because you've got to
keep the Rook defended on C8
to keep this piece yeah under watchful
gaze I'm wondering whether you can trade
off Queens maybe a move like Queen to C7
it feels like going back would be the
wrong direction suddenly black is going
to start hitting you with this Pawn
and yeah I think quizzes of elimination
and now the problem is after Queen takes
Queen the key is to take back well it's
gonna say with the pawn do you take back
with the pawn here the threat is to jump
out the way with your Rook with a check
giving away The Rook but uh forcing your
Pawn through on that on the next move I
think that might be the Clincher
[Music]
and black would probably have to
sacrifice a beast there with Knight
jumping back to E8 to give that up to
win the C7 Pawn but it shouldn't be
enough you just pick up the knight uh
and having this extra beep on under
control that should be easy Queen C7 on
the board big big trouble for Jana Pam
Nashi uh if not Queen takes E7 can he
find a way to go just Queen but if you
move the Queen the White Queen is
jumping on to d8 with a threat along the
eighth rank yeah I think the publishi
actually when he made that mistake he
calculated four through five moves into
the future but he just stopped one move
too soon I think he missed Queen C7 or
at least underestimated it and Magnus
just saw one move deeper
um that's the kind of stakes at this
level uh often you see enough but if you
take your eye off the ball if you stop
if you don't push your calculation then
sometimes the opponents just see further
and hear this looks like yeah suddenly
Magnus has worked his magic he's really
recovered from that previous game
obviously throughout the match right
starting from game one getting that the
end game and then creating his chances
and getting big advantage in that one
game two as well pushing for the
majority of the game till that oversight
and now this one fully under control
Queen C7 player yeah she's shaking his
head can't get out of this trade you go
Queen A6 Queen d8 looks like game over
if you trade the queen you just go into
an end game down an entire piece a big
trouble here for Yan
yeah basically yeah it looks really
difficult and uh uh can it I mean I
guess Magnus will spot the Checkmate in
this one as well and this this was the
star move right Queen C7 and yang
clearly missed this move it looked like
he he was getting very good compensation
with his B Pawn and uh it's an easy move
to miss because it kind of seems clumsy
putting the queen uh on the Square but I
I can't see a defense at the moment and
after Queen takes Queen David you
pointed out porn takes which is probably
winning maybe Rook taste is also pretty
close to winning you know Queen takes
Queen Rook takes might might be a little
bit cleaner so nepo trying to give his
King uh some some room to breathe here
but that doesn't look like it's gonna I
mean at least the White Knight is pinned
because uh you know if you could start
using the White Knight it'd be tricky
and that does create a threat Pawn G4
don't look windy yet yeah 28 would be a
huge blunder actually a game-changing
blunder full 360. black just plays G4
calls the bluff this is just one check
the black king gonna run and it can
continue running and okay Magnus is
found a stronger move he takes the
Queens off the board no more pin on long
this diagonal and the Clincher Rook C7
same idea that you mentioned Simon but
it takes Rook allows the pawn to promote
no stopping that and if you don't go for
the trade if you move your Rook then the
problem is Rook takes Pawn is a double
attack a fork on the king at night and
if the black king moves then you jump in
with a check defending a rook
simultaneously and there's several ways
to win this position you can just go
ahead and make a new Queen if you want
to be flashy maybe take this Knight and
then give a night Fork but uh yeah I
think this one is game over and okay
he's found a different path for the
black Rook he's holding things together
but Knight E5 has happened anyway and
Magnus wow Knight to G4
what is this
ah King takes night now I guess he wants
to meet by Rook takes a check me yeah
there's a Checkmate wow lovely Rook
takes Pawn now looks like the most
natural move took us a while but look at
this the black king finally caught
Magnus does know his checkmates everyone
even in an end game the black king is
about to be caught on the edge of the
board he's squeezing this big I think
we're going to see a Checkmate on the
board in this one he missed it in game
two but he's gonna play it out this one
the problem in game two was that were
Queens on the board he was so angry he
missed that Checkmate in the last game
he had to prove to everyone that he can
he can do it and this is this is quite a
beautiful beautiful really beautiful and
if you go G4 there's Rook F5 as well
coming in you really can't fight it
white will end up queening and that is
it uh Jana Palmer she does resign after
H3 Magnus Carlson boxing up blacks King
there in the end and finally getting
that win in in a match that he has
managed to have so many advantages
positions in
this one still continues to be
absolutely crazy well Jan his task is
cut up fourth game he needs to win on
demand and this one as well getting out
of hand I
think it's getting more and more crazy
every time we look right I mean what's
the black king doing over there now I
mean it's uh really weird David treats
his Rook giving up his Bishop I mean
this is as if someone's just kind of
kind of shuffled the chess pieces and
thrown them randomly on a board Black's
King's Super weak uh a big Target there
as you mentioned Simon White's King also
slightly vulnerable though
Shuffle chess yeah Shuffle chest but
we've got we've got a little bit of time
David could you do a quick action replay
because when we left it last it was
crazy but this has just gotten crazier
yeah let's jump in and show uh what has
just happened as Maxine vashley Graf
turns the screw brings his Knight to a
good square and uh let's jump back to
well all the way back here at uh this
position where we saw the black Rook
attacking the White Queen the queen
retreated Black's Knight jumped in uh
the black the white Bishop moved and a
few turns down the line we actually saw
a mistake here uh by manager of taking
upon allowing white to storm the center
and crash through on uh the black king
black had to move his Queen and here
white could have won on the spot with a
beautiful move Queen to B1 double attack
attacking the bishop and attacking The
Rook Maxine Vash the grav missed this he
played a very tempting move instead and
uh we were left with pure chaos after a
capture black decided to Castle
queenside and here maybe giving up this
black Rook would have been the superior
option just hoping for some counterplate
later with the black Bishop down this
diagonal but instead he gave up the
wrong peace manager of and it looks like
after the move Knight to D4 White's
Bishop is just coming in decisively a
couple more moves have been played Rook
to f8 and Knight to E6 but
yeah white has full control look at the
power of these minor pieces far superior
to the black Brooks it's rook and bond
for two Bishops on the board but white
amazing Harmony incredible pieces at the
center of the board all you really want
is that Queen from A1 to go to A7 so I'm
looking at Queen D4 Queen A7 idea and
that would be a dream for white yeah it
was good yeah and you can then move your
rook in as well Rook C1 uh it's always
going to be a nice move to play uh just
putting pressure so uh my major off has
to play a move like this so he has to
try to block up both of those ideas stop
the queen coming in Stop The Rook coming
in and uh now well where's the killer
blow you need to sort of wriggle around
don't you here and get in the position I
don't think you can take that on pass on
because you just get your knight taken
and uh Black's defending very
sufficiently here so have to find
another idea yeah maybe you zigzag in he
goes a different route nice Queen to E1
trying to head in Via A5 just full board
awareness as well just covering any
potential night checks Black's only
counter play Black's Queen zigzags over
but now the big question is can you just
kick back this Knight can you snack on
this Pawn
feels like Black's position hanging by a
thread maximum should win this now with
his material advantage two knights or
two pieces are better than a rook uh but
also with the safer King
Queen E2 very sensible very professional
approach here from Russia to grab as
well he's covered all the squares taken
away the opponent's attack no counter
play for black he is under a minute
though so he's he's still got to be a
bit careful and um you know the black
Rooks and the Knight you know they have
some potential to Counter-Strike okay
he's trying to kick that Knight away and
this is uh I like your word professional
professional approach get a rid of
manmadraft's dangerous pieces he had
loads of other interesting options there
but good move yeah black had one idea
right Knight F2 with that combining with
the Rook on G8 could be extremely
dangerous for the white king So pushing
that Knight creating a lift for the for
his own king and the craziness just
continues I thought he's gonna fall back
with the Knight 35 or F6 but obviously
not just jumps in with the Knight to E3
typical and typical uh he's just finding
all these creative moves keep the game
alive but mvl great calculator
calculated this move as well and just
moves his Rook up one square the Knight
goes back I mean it's still if you
didn't know the evaluation you'd still
be very confused about this this
position and the whole game in general
uh it's just really weird and all the
MVR needs to do is get his Queen around
the back and the black king will be uh
will be in too much danger but it's not
it's not okay can the queen now come in
that be the first instinctive move so
take it with the queen and you're
threatening Queen to get yeah I mean I
don't even know if that's
if that's good but I guess it is Queen
G8 looks really powerful but he takes
for the bishop uh also tempting the
queen is attacking the pawn on H5 and
it's very strong on the e-file as well
so
it's looking good isn't it for for nvl
very good for weights and the difference
between these two players uh at least
from my experience is that mvl is pure
calculation that Majora is mostly pure
Instinct and right now it is the type of
position where you can calculate your
way through the map through the mess
through the Maze and uh actually graph
that's how he's defended he's seen okay
I'm going to stop this threat stop this
threat I'm going to calculate uh cover
everything and my major unfortunately
can no longer rely on that instinct he's
running out of pieces to attack with at
time as well time as well for Maxima
Grove it's calculation with
extraordinary speed he plays so well in
these time scrambles and now we do see
the queen come into the attack a threat
on a G8 with the queen penetrating would
be checkmate
it would end in Checkmate in the Black
Knight as well is frozen it wants to
jump back to cover some entry squares
but look at the White Queen also on the
same diagonal as the black king but uh
this one oh it's a nasty check there are
some night forks and tactics Queen takes
Rook here uh would win the game I think
yeah plays it straight away yeah jumping
into d8 with a fork just a temporary
sacrifice he wins a rook and wins the
game socria resigns Queen takes F7 a
nice finish there a final tactical touch
there by the Tactical Maestro Maxim
vashiella grab wrapping it up and for
chakra
craziness Madness on the board he does
uh bring in all the excitement and he
needs to do that in the final rapid game
as he has to win on demand to force the
playoff and it's the same same storyline
so yeah do incredibly exciting games uh
there David two incredible games so many
highlights I'm just going to show one
because it did end in a nice checkmating
pattern and it was here that Magnus
Carlson had already weaved some magic in
the end game he'd won a pawn with white
but the finishing touches were Supreme
here black is attacking this white
knight in the center and the white
d-pawn is vulnerable but Magnus dropped
back with a forcing move utilizing this
pin on the f-file this Black Knight is
overwhelmed now the black king had to
capture the White Knight and after Rook
takes Knight the black king found itself
caught in a mating that there's a threat
to push this King back using the f and g
pawns the king steps back and H3 forced
resignation the whole idea is that G4 is
a mating threat followed by Rook takes
pawn and if black had pushed Pawn his
own Pawn to block this as Tania pointed
out earlier Rook to F5 a nice deflection
tactic forcing the Black Brook away to
make a new Queen White won this game in
nice Style
there Magnus he missed amid in game two
but
the create checkmating pattern in that
game three finish that we just saw and
this is the score line which is one more
rapid game remaining yeah and chakra
momidero has to win to take it into the
Armageddon we haven't had an Armageddon
so far today will we have one in the
winner semi-final matchup we will find
that on the other side of this break
foreign
[Music]
spells jump or freeze the hairs start
with two jump spells and five free
spells which we charge after five moves
you may cast your spare whenever you
wish before making a regular chest move
jump is a spell cast to one square
wherein if there is a piece on that
square other pieces can jump over the
Charmed piece the freeze spell is cashed
over a three by three square area and
the pieces in this area are temporarily
Frozen in place
to defeat your opponent
see what supercell and chess.com have
cooked up in our new variant spell chess
available now on chess.com
[Music]
foreign
memory test two years ago in 2021 I
tested magnus's memory by setting up a
bunch of famous positions and seeing
whether he could recognize them
this is the 24th game from Seville
obviously
now we're going to do the same but with
an added twist we're not even going to
be able to see which pieces are which
every piece will be represented by an
airfix device instead so let's see how
Magnus gets on
first of all I'm thinking like
what are all these pawns on the last
rank but if I'm going to go piece by
piece I'm hoping that this is a king and
these are pawns and that this is a
bishop and hopefully Queen H6 should be
made in two 2016 right yes Carlson
against karyakin
so this test is called has mine has been
following the world championship the
ding is White against the publisher and
here he could have taken the Rook with
the queen eventually green goes back
here
and eventually the king is
running away I think should have found
this thing
is this any more difficult for you uh no
not really the games are too famous
that's the problem this has to be a
casparov to Paulo from 99 in RS what
characteristics make you recognize this
position maybe like it's just the
structure on the queen side nice
[Applause]
so this one is one of my happier early
chess chess memories just from the
world's youth Championship under 14. I'm
playing Black in the first round against
the future Grandmaster Hammer that's the
king over there this and this checkmates
this looks like Checkers
so few pieces but it's definitely a game
I've seen huh almost it's
I don't want to give it away but it you
will have that's the clue you will have
seen it
I'm not sure I should have seen this
in that case I apologize
it's from the Queen's Gambit TV show
when Beth plays what's his name towns in
the first her first ever tournament oh
and this is a rook and it's trapped now
because there's a nice one before and a
king on D2 ah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
remember that sequence from from the
series now but like it was I wasn't even
close to be honest
[Music]
oh
how does he do it it is a peek into the
mind of the genius impressive stuff
there and then David also took to the
Streets of London to look for some
hidden talent check it out
hi everyone here we are today in Sunny
London where I will be approaching
strangers on the streets to figure out
whether they have any chess skill and to
see whether they can crack this code and
solve some tricky puzzles today we're
going to be looking at three positions
if you solve the easy one you get five
pounds Medium Level 10 pounds and the
high level 15 pounds my name is Louis
I'm rated uh 1100 on 10 minutes so I'm
pretty good it's rapid right that's what
it's called yeah rapid let's say it's
rapid we've got the Platinum
subscription so I try to
you know get on top of all of that stuff
as much as possible binge binge it all
out but okay he says all the right
things gotta say white to play and find
the best move
I'll probably check him straight away
with the Rook there's a quicker puff
checkmate
is there like some kind of The Rook
sacrifice or something
um I love the reference but not quite oh
okay it was probably the bishop then
yeah yeah that makes sense what is the
bishop land uh on A6 that is a technical
term wow I think we have an Undiscovered
Prodigy here second puzzle medium level
and it's white to play and again win as
quickly as you can is there a queen
sacrifice
ah there might be a queen sacrifice guys
I'm gonna go Final Answer Queen
sacrifice here wow I'm not joking we
have a genius here Queen takes porn keep
going finish it off viral I'm going
viral uh finish it off so the the king
would take then you move the rook and
then I get I mean he's got nowhere yeah
he's got nowhere to go from there wow
impressive stuff white to play and
Checkmate in two moves hmm you may have
stumped me here 10 seconds here uh
Checkmate in two got to force your
opponent's moves yeah I don't know Rook
to A6 is the correct move okay forcing
black to capture and then you push the
pawn forward
this is for you lovely twitch career
starts here guys if you want to look me
up
the universe will tell you one day yeah
thank you very much chess.com is awesome
that was an impressive tactical spot
there David yeah I've got to say I was
just roaming the streets and this guy
just approaches me he's like you like
chess I was like yeah I do and he wants
the money sell some puzzles impressive
and that reference uh when Gotham chess
with Levy The Rock he knows his stuff I
know he was a big fan of uh of Levy and
the butcher sisters he said he watched a
lot of their streams and it clearly pays
off yeah it does but right now it's got
to be a payoff for two players who are
playing catch up to Magnus Carlson and
Maxima Maxim Israel Magnus is ready he
needs only a draw in that final thoughts
game to wrap up the match it has been a
roller coaster ride between these two a
very topsy-dovey match so much drama in
the first two games but Magnus Carlsen
has been in driver's seat for most part
of this the good news for Jan is that he
does start with the white pieces we will
have Sicily we will have the Sicilian
wow and uh I was expecting Magnus to go
for a more solid E5 approach but we've
got a night off yeah these days Magnus
does not play with the handbrake on he
loves to kind of Fight Fire with Fire
even in situations where he only needs a
draw and this kind of harks back to
Anish giri earlier in the day just
needing a draw against uh Hikaru
Nakamura but not backing down from a
full-blooded fight and the top players
they know their openings well enough to
not take too many risks Simon what do
you think of this last move for quite a
rare position despite the game starting
as a night off
especially this move I mean this this
bishop D2 looks very very rare to me I
mean you don't normally put the bishop
on such a passive Square when you're
playing with white pieces but we're
going to get a very exciting game here
nepo is getting ready to put his Queen
to the queen side and uh he's already
moved his Queen out to go for Turbo
Turbo development
um and yeah very very very exciting
stuff here uh I mean generally in these
kind of positions when you get this open
Sicilian I I love them I think they're
the most interesting openings you can
get
um it's white with the development white
has four pieces developed black only has
one piece developed but it's black with
a pawn structure that's supposed to be
the analogy with these open syrians
Black's got a better Pawn structure so
black wants to counter-attack and get
his chance for his late chances in later
on in the game
um Queen C7 normal move there yeah
interesting stuff really really going to
be a great game this one and I'm so
happy Magnus didn't play some boring
Queen Exchange again we had to get some
action and uh I expect nepo will castle
at some point and game on
yeah game on and especially after this
last move Gary makes an entrance G4
napoleonishi doing the right thing going
all out at this early stage he wants to
attack he will get an attack uh in this
exciting Sicilian Defense
showing his fangs early on with that
move G4 your opponent goes on one side
of the board Magnus responds on the
other side of the board B5 up which
means that if Yan was to get his King to
the queen side Magnus is ready to
counter that the bishop will land on B7
also taking advantage of some of the
week's Quest this last guy the Jeep on
has left behind on the light squares B5
a really nice thematic response and Jan
says your Pawn only stops on the fifth
rank
yeah I'm not really sure I believe like
Yan's play here to be honest because you
can get a very similar position to this
but with your light Square Bishop on uh
the queen side pointing pointing towards
Black's pawns already and Magnus playing
very sensible moves he now puts some
pressure on White's Pawn in the center
of the board he might have a break in
the middle or he can just bring his
other night out and uh you're sort of
homing in on Gary Kasparov right this is
Gary kasparo's favorite opening as well
as Bobby Fischer uh the naidor variation
and what will Yan now do has he got time
to play H4 a then G5 Maybe
that is the big question while you've
gone a you got to go B in this case
you've gone G at some point you've got
to go H and Bishop B7 on the board we
will check back in with Yan's approach
and trying to create chances the other
one is also kicking off a chakra
momidoro is also trailing Maxim he needs
to win a draw would mean Maxim goes
through and a shark will go down to the
losers bracket again in this one as well
shock has got the white pieces uh which
is always a relief for the player in a
must-win situation yeah and he opens
with the ready uh just really really
flexible stuff now he transposes into a
queen's Pawn opening having dodged
vashilograph's beloved grinfeld defense
and here we see it's actually the
Queen's Gambit accepted uh all these
openings transposed to one another but a
quick flurry of moves the center has
disappeared it's symmetrical Pawn
structure white with Superior
development look at that central control
with his pieces but black is very very
solid here I do worry for White's
chances unless he can create something
big in the next few moves to me it feels
like the players have switched up the
Magnus board feels more like the maxim
shark attack board while this one feels
more like the battle between uh Magnus
and Yan a really sane approach out of
the opening something that we're not
used to by shark we see the madness
early on oh and as I said
we just don't play the move G4 in this
position it's just not sure he plays G4
in every position he loves his G Pawn
doesn't he I mean the guy is like a
g-pawn addicts and uh you know he needs
to go to rehab uh he pushes it in every
single position and uh H4 I mean look
he's absolute lunatic uh like the last
game I mean it does gain space it has
some sensibility to it but you also
weaken your king in the long run so it's
risky but he's got to take risks yeah so
would you call yourself an H porn addict
then son I'm I'm yeah H addict that's
right so age porn addict yeah it's just
incredible I mean throwing pawns forward
in front of your king when the center is
so open especially when you've traded a
set of pieces it's counter-intuitive
it's definitely going against uh
classical chess wisdom there but yeah
he's getting away with it he's gaining
space he's hoping that in an end game as
well uh he's clamped down on the king
Side Pawn structure maybe there'll be
some tactics against the black king
Black's piece is still relatively
passive for now so a king is only as
weak as the opponent's pieces that can
attack it and Maxim is pausing for the
first real time in this game is it
surprising to you firstly that uh Mama
jar threw the G Pawn forward here but
also that vashi degrove has reacted
instantly not even uh flinching yeah
after that it really surprised me I mean
it's a critical game and he can I mean
G4 I mean he probably did expect it but
he couldn't have looked at it and and he
spent 30 seconds to come up and answer
and uh when you're surprised you
generally you know you you settle down
and take a bit more time and uh do we
love do we love this Pawn push are we a
fan of it or I mean I'll be honest I
wouldn't do it in this position to go G4
with the King's Castle then you're
really not seeing a big attack it's so
hard to imagine going G4 it is yeah I
mean what about you David yeah uh I
would never ever play chess like this
because uh I prefer my slower types of
positions now the stakes are super high
but you're like the opposite a shack I
mean but you can play like earlier on I
think it was the other day I I was
showing David this incredibly hard
puzzle one of my favorite puzzles all
time took him about five to ten seconds
to solve it I'm like how did you do that
it's like it's like a 10 move
combination and it was like so you can
play All Tied his position and that's
the that's the key thing of all of these
top players even if Shaq loves pushing
his G H Pawn he can grow he can grind
out endings I've seen him do it against
uh top players as well you have to be a
universal player
um to be a top player well I just don't
understand is what's the follow-up you
go G4 you go H4 you get your G5 in you
got your Bishop line that where is the
attack there F4 is coming yeah it's got
to be F4 confidence you know obviously
just pushable
in Shack We Trust in Simon We Trust and
uh F4 does look like The Logical
continuation just throwing all the pawns
forward I mean this last move is so kind
of strange to me that it must be
computer preparation uh why else would
you vacate this diagonal when your
opponent's Bishop is lurking from a far
like like an Archer I wouldn't be
surprised if the black Bishop drops back
at some point and the black queen uh
tries to activate on this diagonal watch
out this would end and Checkmate this
also looks logical because then you free
the black Rook uh to play a role on the
seventh rank I guess the attack does lie
in the fact that uh after Bishop to G4
there might be some tactics on the E6
Square slightly vulnerable for example
if the black queen were to move then
Knight takes E6 I guess would be a
killer tactic because suddenly the
Bishops uh just wreak havoc upon the
lone black king
this would likely end in Checkmate just
to show off here King to h8 I think you
can even give up a second Bishop to
activate the White Queen with a nice
nasty check so this is the type of Shack
Attack that I'm hoping for but of course
Maxine Valley graph will have something
to say about that and he drops back his
Bishop can't defensive move instead
skeptical I've got to say objectively
but here we go
and he wants to play yeah he wants to
undermine the light squares with G6 but
I mean I thought he'd push the F Pawn
first he doesn't even care does he he's
not thinking as well what's going on
they're both playing so quick and it's
crazy GM level Coffee House chess going
on it is yeah yeah that's that's why I
always say I am like you know a weak
Mama jar of I like I love the way he
plays but I just can't I play it a lot
worse than him uh and he's using those
pawns to to great effect now actually I
mean there's a threat G6 is a nasty fret
right yeah and I've actually seen my
major have this opening up until the
moment he played G4
um he's had it before I think against
Dennis lazovic for example
um a quick draw there
um so he knows what he's doing and wow
the evaluation bar reacts actually in
both games but uh this last move by
vashilograph again played quite quickly
at Tempo but hated by the engine I'm
looking at both our eval bars and just
wondering are we heading
going on night five a big mistake first
let's check in with this David what's
wrong with this move
uh frankly I'm not sure it's not obvious
it looks very natural it looks like
black is just trying to trade off pieces
I'm going to cheat it's late in the day
it is the mood that uh White had
prepared it is actually still G6 uh with
the last move H5 white Was preparing
this undermining of the position and uh
you can you can apparently play it now
with with uh very very good position
yeah for example if black takes twice uh
just to get rid of this very dangerous
white Pawn then I guess the idea
assignment is that they're going to
undermine this Black Knight because
otherwise Black's position looks
relatively solid the Black Knight is the
glue holding everything together but you
can kick it away uh either black now is
forced to part with material or after a
trade we would see that this Rook
suddenly really awkward forced back to
this start square and white pieces are
coming the queen is coming I'm not sure
how to uh kind of improve and accelerate
this attack but it looks very very scary
the black king lacking Defenders around
it and E6 extremely weak this is the key
I didn't play it though he didn't he
decides to go for E4 and as things calm
down in this one we have to rush over to
our other game big updates coming in big
big developments it is yeah who has
sacrificed a piece on that B5 Square for
attack against the magnus's king he's
eyeing that D6 Pawn Magnus first has to
Save the Queen and David I'm thinking
that Bishop from D2 will jump to B4 and
big questions for that D6 Pawn Yeah
Napoli really really upping his game
when it matters most uh this could be a
clutch Victory suddenly the black king
uh is in the firing line and White's
kind of controlling and attacking on
both sides it's like a pincer movement
kind of wrapping around with the White
Queen and Rook on the king side and then
the White Knight on the other flank and
wow look at that evaluation the engine
thinks black is already losing by 3.6 if
he doesn't find the move Queen B6 either
not 100 obvious uh then it's just game
over it's Wipeout the advantage would
increase massively for white and
where was Jan he just returned I think
he knows how close he is to this one
David while Magnus thinks should we do a
quick replay and see how we actually got
here let's do that sir let's jump back
just a few more uh a few moves uh I'll
jump to a more normal position here it's
very standard both sides have set up in
a typical way for the Sicilian night off
black with a really strong Knight in the
center of the board but after the White
Queen moved across it was this move
Bishop to F6 a mistake of blunder
because it loosens the protection over
the key D6 square and this was the
trigger for white to jump in sacrifice
quite a thematic uh idea here in the
Sicilian Defense and now not just is the
queen attacked but this D6 Pawn is
collapsing Magnus does find the best
move but it's still looking pretty Grim
after your idea there Tanya Bishop to B4
overwhelming uh this Pawn it's attacked
now three times with a rook with the
Knight and with the bishop and Black's
King is looks doomed right now
nice nice stuff yeah very typical
attacking ideas there as well and uh
when D6 drops uh yeah the black king is
is in serious trouble right
what do you do I I'm at a loss right now
to even suggest a move for Simon Bishop
B4 I don't know but I'm just wondering
that instead of Bishop B4 is the animals
are getting ambitious with perhaps uh
going in with Knight D6 or the tactics
don't work out there because the Rook on
D1 is undefended right yeah it looks
very tempting here you would have some
great discovered attacks if you could
move the bishop but unfortunately The
Rook uh undefended so uh this tempting
idea may be up his sleeve but Bishop's
B4 just looks so natural uh your first
instinct there Tanya on the board and
yeah the key as well is that this Pawn
attacked if it steps forward then
suddenly this queen might have a role to
play you could for example capture this
bishop with your rook and this Knight
now overworked white would swoop in and
suddenly all sorts of threats in the air
and all through a minimal sacrifice so
we do see that black defended the D6
square but why does broken through it's
three pawns for a piece not even a
sacrifice anymore
[Music]
pick up the D6 Pawn with the wrong piece
there what happened yeah he took very
quickly on D6 with the knight uh I will
say the most natural move from a human
point of view for some reason at least
uh when I calculate I always look at
nights before Bishops I think it's
because we're taught nights before
Bishops when we develop uh when we're
young children uh but yeah it would have
been even stronger to potentially take
with the bishop or maybe with the rook
and uh try to break through the night a
key attacker trying to jump in to get at
that black king but Knight takes was
played
still looks very promising especially
after magnus's last move dropping back
the queen and where is the Breakthrough
oh you know yeah yeah we do you know
what I want to do I expect it's just
Bishop B5 but we want to take one of
these don't we we do want to take on E6
oh it might be the moon
wow and um yeah okay and The King The
King uh probably has to come to the
center right so and this is the position
I wasn't
sure where the killer blow is I mean is
it the bishop diesel maybe bishop D6
yeah yeah and this is hard to evaluate
for a human we see that it's winning
with the evaluation bar but white has
sacrificed a rook and a piece uh yes you
have a bunch of Pawns you have an army
of Pawns in return but uh the attack
continues I think it's just the fact
that the black queen has no good squares
actually is the black queen trapped uh
because if she if she moves to the sixth
rank you jump out the way with a check
you pick up the queen
um
Ron wondering where else she goes maybe
to A5 maybe this is what will uh make
Yan pause and the black queen maybe with
some counter play let's go back to the
current position this looks promising
for white it is winning according to the
computer but not easy uh the engine says
taking this Pawn with either Rook
winning but also just uh any other move
pretty much yeah the top two moves are
either Rook from the h file to take on
E6 or from the D file to take on E6 uh
do we reckon he'll find it oh my God
that's not he has to he's got this
opportunity he can't let it go it's the
first move you want to play because
you've sacked a piece you want to sack
your Rook as well
um but that line you just showed like
you said for a human it's really hard to
evaluate even at the end there because
you're so many pieces down right I mean
after Queen A5 you see a check as well
and you're like oh I'm I mean I'm not
sure about this and where's the killer
blow is there even a killer blow we can
find here I mean there's nothing obvious
is there so this is like impossible to
evaluate I let's do it what okay I don't
think he I I hope he does but I have to
say I don't think he will all right so
no rookie six for Simon David will you
say no he won't until I think this is
all predicated on the fact that you do
have a nice tactic just to show off a
bit here I did check the engine so this
isn't me but uh Queen H7 a beautiful
move if the Rook moves uh for example
here then you could even sacrifice I was
gonna say you could sacrifice and
Checkmate that's not right because the
black queen defense but at the very
least you can go before first or saying
yeah yeah attempting Queen A3 I think
you've got a nice Simon then you have a
Checkmate yeah
um so what about you Tanya is he gonna
play her
so David what you're saying is that if
Queen he has to find Queen 87 to go into
this line which actually makes it more
complicated to give an answer to that
but you know what I think rookie 6 is
very happy and uh Ali Annie does it well
done that is that's amazing amazing
stuff from nepo before he finds Queen at
seven but is it's a different position
but he has the idea and look at Magnus
Magnus reacts he can't believe it and
he's
sick of the way this game is gone this
is a brilliant game absolutely brilliant
game he's just sick of the way the whole
match has gone yeah we've seen we've
seen Magnus more emotional in this match
than we've seen him any other time you
know so uh
uh but yeah Queen H7 is the move and and
strong yeah yeah and found it
brilliantly so well done yeah I think
the only way to keep the going the game
going now if your Magnus Carlson is to
throw a piece away uh use the Black
Knight to defend this black Rook uh we
we kind of showed some mating patterns
uh incoming against the black king the
black Rook lacking squares as well so
you just have to give back some material
right now you have an extra Rook you
have an extra night um so yeah you just
have to part with some of that to
survive there's just no good Square for
The Rook if you move it next to the king
black simply white simply slaps it up
and there is a Checkmate on E7 uh so
rookie it is not an option Rook Cafe
loses The Rook on the spot uh and I
think Magnus do you think he just missed
queen ed7 as the resource here
that's strange that he reacted there
okay he does play the best move the only
move to keep the game going but still
Cricket uh looking pretty grim
the White Queen can move the way Bishop
can jump in with the check but yeah are
you are you surprised for me I would
have reacted earlier after Knight takes
B5 after white started the attack let
alone when white is about to put
finishing touches on I I think like you
said earlier as Bishop F6 move allowing
this very typical sacrifice just just
seemed to be uh the the start of where
things went majorly wrong uh because
that is it's a very common sacrificial
idea where you get you get three Pawns
of the piece right
um so I think it I think it did go wrong
for that maybe it's just frustrating
with himself and and the feature chat
question I think that's the big one can
Magnus save this one I would be hesitant
to write it off just yet uh Magnus
finding the most important move in the
position as he said Knight F6 and now a
big decision for Ayan
it's really not over till it's over
against Magnus he's not gonna make this
easy so still a lot to fight for but Jan
making the accurate choice of keeping
the Queens on the board lots of threats
against those two knights he's going to
win some material back there's a lot of
threats against the king as well I mean
Bishop E7 Rook D6 Queen takes Knight
Rook takes even Knight there's a lot of
things to watch out for here uh Bishop
yeah I mean everything right there's
there's too many threats here uh but
it's peculiar because Magnus is a rook
and a piece up so he's got loads of
material but to give back to give back
he's gonna have to give back but his
King is just so weak and uh you know
this is why the Sicilians are so so
exciting uh you get you get these kind
of crazy and and fun positions very
often where's the finish the night drops
back and do you now jump in with the
bishop that looks the most logical right
now the most tempting uh the move we
highlighted earlier Bishop to D6
attacking the black queen there we go
played and I was just doing a bit of
maths not my strong suit but uh I guess
black does have an extra rook and an
extra Knight but if you count the white
pawns white does have five extra pawns
so that kind of balances out one Rook a
rook worth five so black is only one
piece up and one of those pieces is
Baron uh is kind of bound to drop
guaranteed to drop so essentially he's
gonna be attacking for free in a moment
naponishi once he takes one of those
Black Knights
and yeah it's just the fact that White's
King is supremely safe with all that
pawn shelter in front of it and Black's
King bereft of any uh any defense
this one looks over and we've got this
position right where Magnus shaking his
head but he needs to make a move with
the queen you can't place it on the
sixth rank because it'll discover check
that we've been pointing out and white
Rook will pick up that Queen uh he
decides to actually just get rid of that
green gives it up for the bishop but now
it's also the weak black king
when in doubt just sacrifice your queen
seems to be magnus's motto he did
similar against uh Hikaru Nakamura
yesterday he gave up the queen and a
draw was agreed because it looked like
there would be a fortress there is a
trap in the position or is that I was
going to say the White Queen running out
of squares but she does have a couple of
uh safe squares to run to to use what do
you think any chance any remote
possibility of saving this yes but only
because it's Magnus yeah I I would say
the same I mean I think I think there is
some chance there
um see you know his pieces are like
defending each other the knights are
kind of okay
um you can't kick them away with pawns
so uh yeah I mean something like rookie
six although maybe I'll lose my queen
die
f8 yeah but that's going at seven in
those lines I mean H7 is okay but maybe
even better is to put the Queen the
Brook on H6 and oh oh okay that's that's
move that's nice yeah that is that's a
flashy one and again I've been doing my
counting here white has a queen and Five
Pawns in return black has two knights
and a rook so two nights in a rook worth
11 a queen and Five Pawns worth a lot 14
what is three points ahead
it's a rare material imbalance here but
that material lead and the weak black
king all adds up it's 14 verses 11 but
it's also that weekend that you're
pointing out and I think that's going to
be uh Priceless uh for white hair you
have to try to bring your Bishop into
the attack Rook F6 like you said a
flashy move black can't take the Rook
but then ends up losing six points in
return as white will first capture the
central Knight give a check and then
pick up the other night on F6 so this
will not work out for black uh and it
might be time for him to anyway get that
Rook to fa to try to get rid of some of
the pressure on the board because give
white one more move David and if that
light Square Bishop jumps to B5 too many
threats to handle yeah that's game over
if either of the Black Knights
disappears or are dislodged um yeah I
like your move there Tanya at least
you're kind of getting some activity
before you have to resign
um
some activity before you resign
a little bit of fun it's not your game
luckily Tanya but uh Rook takes F3 at
least you get this pawn and maybe this
Pawn next you're attacking the white
Bishop but it's probably a weird
position isn't it very peculiar so
problem is your move I mean even without
this white Bishop on the board I think
white might be uh fancying his chances
here but one Black Knight will be traded
off and the position will collapse
Magnus he has to choose between all
these evils right now and this is the
current position I think he's choosing
his opening for the Armageddon
simply
choosing his time for the bid he's done
well though to get a position which is
like a bit murky and not just getting
checkmated in I mean uh
that's that's all you know the best
thing basically about his position
wow
and uh meanwhile
this one looks like an upon a shoe will
take it the other way in the other game
I was seeing the bar switch
um we will update everyone there in a
bit but yeah this one Magnus praying for
a miracle
but we know Magnus he does end up
finding those Miracles more often than
others goes for the idea with Rook to f8
Jana publishing needs to complete this
job this is his big moment this is his
big chance Krabs upon on G5 and after
Rook F3 the bishop will come out into
the game as you're pointing out David
Bishop B5 played and now the G Pawn will
also start advancing down the boat it
all comes down to those extra pawns
black without a single Pawn in the
position
that's a very strange position it's very
strange I mean well pawns are better
than none yeah and there we go a knight
disappears and black has three pieces
but they don't coordinate well yeah and
white has just simply too many pawns
Agnes needs only a draw if he can get
those pieces to coordinate to put
pressure against white skin again I'm
not writing this one off just yet
he needs a bit of a helping hand from
Jan but it's not 100 easy for example if
white pushes the B4 Pawn forward one
square that could be taken off the board
okay first giving a check
it's got to be very careful he puts his
King because uh the problem when you
when you're playing against the queen
with minor pieces the the most important
rule to to remember is to keep them
guarding each other so you've got to
have the bishop guard in The Rook the
night guarding the bishop and something
guarding the Knight because otherwise
they drop off it's that analogy you said
earlier David there you know and that
Bishop in the middle is is very very
loose here so there's lots of tactics
where it could possibly just drop off
here and you combine that with the pawns
just coming steamrolling up the board as
well
um it's like you're fighting a battle on
several fronts you'll be fighting pawns
marching forward on the king side the
queen side and you'll be having to guard
all your pieces uh right now he's got a
kind of decent setup with good
coordination every single black piece on
a light Square
the problem is how are they going to
stem the tide long term I wouldn't be
surprised if the pawns start marching
now and he's got to do that right he has
to bring the pawns into the game because
the queen alone can't get the job done
unless you manage to pick up one of the
pieces yeah Simon mentioned that all the
pieces need to defend each other the
only undefended piece is the black
Bishop
I'm protected here and you either have
to push it back to a really kind of
really passive Square
or you have to put your pieces where
they might just get hit by that white
Queen there we go a bit loose now from
Magnus on a dark Square this Rook but
he's taking chances and has set up a
threat like he's threatening to move his
Bishop out the way take on C2 with a
check and then win the White Queen yeah
obviously in Napo we'll see this
you would imagine so yeah and uh yeah
Magnus not very happy about his position
here
um nepo should win this one but I mean
there's always tricks I think at some
point he's gonna have to start uh
stretching Black's defenses by by using
his pawns uh use the pawn on the right
hand side get black try and defend it
over there use the pull on the left hand
side and Black's pieces won't be able to
defend all of those pawns coming
forwards on either side of the board I'd
imagine that's that's that's what he
needs to do in this position stranger
things have happened though yeah
especially in this match between these
two today and there we go g Pawn marches
uh meanwhile we have a result in the
other game wow Maxine barcelograph takes
that with another win so no Armageddon
in that one a three one victory for
maxim Russia but the drama continues in
this one
drama continues and Magnus is creating
some threats he's really uh forcing nepo
here forcing Yan to at least worry at
least calculate his way to Victory it's
the C2 Pawn is just going to be captured
but Black's pieces are a bit loose
so what to do here is white the more
pawns that disappear the closer black
gets to that desired draw
chat you've got to get involved tell us
if you think yeah she can make this
comeback it is so close for him but he
still needs to finish the job that he's
managed to start so well he does put the
pressure against the rook and the bishop
Magnus decides not to take on C2 which
would leave a lot of pieces hanging but
first gives a check and picks up the
pawn on a slight head shake there by Yan
it's quite a big Pawn to lose that one I
mean uh you know if you drop any more
pawns it can be very hard to win this uh
so he's got to push these guys and there
he goes he's gonna try to stretch those
defenses I don't like you know magnus's
pieces they're still very loose in
there's no way they can ever get safe
because there's not any stable squares
they can stay on so this is always going
to be an issue uh in in the position
just having unstable pieces so nepo big
big favorite here
favorite but predictions uh David Simon
are we gonna have an Armageddon in this
one yes or no yeah I think so yeah yeah
I'll say no just to be different Tanya
break the tie I'm gonna say no hey you
think Magnus will hold I think he'll
survive this one uh winning that C2 Pawn
definitely gives him counter chances
here yes Jan still in driver's seat uh
Magnus he's
yeah he's hard to beat you have to beat
him from a winning position all over
again you have to beat him in the
opening in the middle game and in the
end game I think that's his famous
saying right you have to beat him Thrice
yeah you have to keep knocking them
knocking them down again they get up you
knock them down again and uh yeah
momentum is on black side he has been
picking off the pawns earlier White had
Five Pawns more than the opponent now
it's only three so some
yeah if if you call me Mr Brightside
that's what I'll say at least it's
moving in the right direction for Magnus
but now the White Queen will simply move
and those two pawns on the queen side
look most menacing they do look at that
Knight on D7 for Magnus it's such a key
piece because it stops any checks for
the White Queen from jumping in it's
really the best friend for Black's King
there Simon you said in these kind of
piece imbalances you want every piece to
sort of defend each other and we see
that night not only guarding the black
king but also the Rook on E5 uh no big
check right now
it's not easy and we see the eval bar it
keeps doing a little bit of a dance
after every move
yeah I mean can you grab enough of them
um if you could then uh you'd be get you
know you'd be getting much closer the
queen H4 is a lovely a lovely move where
you're gonna lose the Rook there uh and
I just don't see how you're gonna stop
these Pawns in the long run so Magnus
trying to pick up the a pawn now uh but
how do you save it you go to A7 all the
way in or do you fall back to the
starting point on D1 oh wow another move
D6 counter offense on the bishop yeah
that's a nice move really nice Square
for the queen there and uh if you take
the Pullman check then then white just
attacks two pieces by moving forward so
you can't actually take the pawn next
move is going to be like A5 or B6 and
they're getting really near cleaning now
yeah they're marching down the board but
Magnus does give a check with his Bishop
uh the bishop drops back and the white
king steps forward
how do you guard against this uh I mean
from a practical point of view it just
looks hope whoops my arrows uh this uh
Pawn to G6 just looks hopeless he gives
a few checks Magnus but he's only
driving the white king forward I think
the white king
oh I see it carefully he doesn't want to
go
careful that would drop the evaluation
yeah oh yeah I mean suddenly the white
king may be checked on the edge of the
board so big question
uh maybe the white King has to go back
but uh if you're going back then how are
you going to hide from these checks on
the third rank draw a match done
come back a check and of course he can't
repeat he falls back all the way so the
king coming from the other side closer
to the black Rook going to zigzag
towards that black Rook but not entering
the fourth rank so the Black Brook will
not be able to take any pawns with a
gain of time meanwhile huge huge uh
potentially winning threat on the board
of G6 uh pushing whites kingside Pawn
forward actually both Pawns
I think in with one minute on the clock
this one is almost hopeless maybe with
an hour on the clock you could post some
problems potentially save it but you
need another piece really don't you in
this in this position at least and uh
um at that G6 move the B6 yeah the pawns
are coming and uh we're gonna get
Armageddon which is great between these
two uh these two brilliant players I
mean who we've seen them in the world
championships and yeah looking forward
to that 30 seconds now for Magnus
Carlson I think I'm going to be eating
my own words on that prediction uh
doing everything right and is it time to
start pushing the pawns and he does it
if you take on G5
B7 game over you have a huge huge
threats and blacks pieces are stretched
to the maximum right now 26 27 seconds
how do you stop B7 do you have to use
the black Bishop but then the other Pawn
will start running yeah you can't you
just can't control both pawns here if
you go rookie six
um then Queen C7 Checkers is very simple
way doing it so now the G Port probably
comes as you said David just just get
stretch those defenses the bishop can
only defend one side
bar drops is this because black is going
to give up his Bishop for two pawns okay
the evaluation bar recorrecting itself
there changing its mind if white takes
the black Bishop now black will take the
B Pawn with the check and then go back
for the other pawn and white is left
with only the a pawn and a queen are we
gonna get down to Queen versus Rook that
that's my prediction which is which is a
technical win but it's not so simple
yeah and wow only one winning move now
for janapomnishi he has just over one
minute he has to resist the temptation
to grab Black's Bishop that would
actually end in a theoretical draw he
has to give a check with the White Queen
Quincy seven and he finds the winning
move the idea is to keep all of the
white pawns intact and but wow the point
the bar drops oh wow it looks like he's
making it all when it goes back up again
what did Magnus Miss there crazy
position I maybe had a check that that
was
a huge drama I will show this in a
moment Magnus did miss a way to draw now
the white apron is simply going to match
up the board if the pawn didn't exist
rook and Knight can hold their own
against Queen but here it's just too
slow insufficient and white will most
likely win this game Let's jump back in
uh just to show what happened there uh
that was a moment where Magnus could
have made a miracle of happen and it was
here after white gambled with G7 he
could have given a check as you
mentioned Simon and the problem is the
white king maybe it just can't dance uh
to a safe square if it marches forward
oh wow I was going to say another check
but actually the black Bishop now is
safe and the difference is that it
covers this Square where it wouldn't
have done if it had landed on D5 first
here white could have promoted to a
knight with a nasty check winning the
game tactics all over the place we can
forgive the players for missing this of
course with no time on their clock and
now the pawn is just marching through to
Glory
this one should be in its final stages
magnificence Falls so well but Jan doing
everything right
and upon just continues it's a March
down the board giving a few checks
looking at that Rook coming back to
attack that Queen on B7 to try to defend
I think Simon this might be a queen
versus rook and Magnus is going to make
Yan prove that one which I think Jan
will
um again yeah I mean if he can get his
if he can gives give his Knight up for
the pawn but it's not so easy to do that
here anyway
um yeah you might have to give you a
rook for that one look at that move
Queen from one all the way it's a long
move that is I love the long ways
they're nice and uh what we can see now
okay doing a bit Rick riggling you still
still needs to win him still needs to
win the black king could not have moved
towards the white Pawn there there would
have been a back rank check uh
devastating check instead magnus's King
has to go the long way around and now
how does he push that pawn forward the
black king is coming it's coming and if
it gets really close to the white Pawn
then we're talking about real chances
for black to hold this one yeah
to be really careful one more move
actually the black king if it just
sidesteps one square closer is in the
Box close to that pawn yeah no under 20
seconds as well so he's got to find a
way to stop that black king surrounding
the white Pawn so he moves his Queen
over and that that is a good move trying
you know just forcing forcing uh the
black king to stay where it is now black
is completely Frozen the black Rook is
stuck in front of the pool and the Black
Knight uh stuck preventing any Jackson
oh look at that oh he missed another
chance wow the Black Knight could have
actually gone back to B8 and ah is he
gonna do it now you can't there's going
to be here that was at one moment
because the King was on B4 oh yeah he's
full of the queen B6 and yeah
that is dirty so dirty from Magnus
Carlson here taking the Rook would have
actually ended in a draw and we'll show
this in a moment the drama is Just
Happening both players with around 10-15
seconds but black is about to take the
white Pawn
wow oh if he takes it now with his Rook
then the white king goes towards that
black knight and blacks pieces are
overwhelmed I'm gonna see it we're gonna
get it we're gonna get it unbelievable
Rook versus queen and this is this is a
technical win but it's actually with the
correct defense quite hard uh if I
remember correctly the but it's really
difficult to defend this because you've
got to put the Rook quite a long way
away from the King and avoid losing it
so
um Magnus is going to best you out now I
didn't this time I'm sure that both
players have looked at this ending quite
a lot of times before because it's one
of those pure endings that you get that
you probably should look at at some
point you will get outside at a moment
in your life and this is the kind of
move you must do you must move the Rook
a long way away that's the kind of key
not drawing way but the key idea to make
it tricky
yeah have you ever had this ending I
have and I've struggled to win actually
once in the world junior Championship
when I was quite young my opponent
defended really well and it took me
about 35-40 moves to win the black Rook
uh so just in time
uh but I think every time I've had this
on the defending side I've lost
including to vashlagraven
a couple of other players they tend to
know the technique especially if the
king gets forced onto one of the sides
of the board yeah
so make it as tricky as possible but
it's not going to be quite enough here
but there were these moments in that end
game when Magnus had his chance and his
opportunity to hold that then maybe
David you will show us where he missed
out it was a tough hold but a big fight
it does continue yeah
doing uh what felt impossible making a
comeback in his match with some
scintillating play out of the opening
Rook takes E6 he made it all happen he's
beaten Magnus in the opening and the
middle game he's on the brink now of
beating him in the end game two I'll do
it Thrice David he's gone the long way
around three times 100 move game almost
now
your specialty David I mean my favorite
not everyone's favorite I don't think
Magnus is enjoying this and I prefer the
more my major of kind of games where he
says he never gets into the ending you
know uh how many moves we won because
obviously if it gets to 50 moves then
the game is declared to draw
automatically
um but the last capture was on move 79
so Magnus needs to survive to move
129. we've just reached the 30 move okay
okay 79 you said
20 moves 30 moves to go before the 50
move Rule and the draw kicks in white
needs to win the black Rook or deliver
Checkmate don't push the white king
forward dirty track there you go yeah
and he nepo is just ready for all of
these Magnus tricks there was a
stalemate idea can we show that on the
board let's show this you have to be
really careful if you advance too fast
too hastily then black can give away the
Rook look at this skewering the King and
King and Queen and taking would lead to
stalemate ignore the bar this would be a
draw Black's King can't move and uh
isn't in check so this would be a force
draw so watch out for this theme to
recur now King E6 rip and Rook D6
doesn't work because there's Queen D6
coming in with a check so you can still
go in with the King if
ah
let's see
still struggling to find the right setup
yeah he's running out most isn't he now
surely so uh I think you have to you
have to play at some point if I remember
correctly it's some weird Zug Swang a
move with the queen where you tie your
opponent's Rook down but no progress has
been made here uh for quite some time
now he's getting frustrated he made a
bit of a gesture there uh yeah naponishi
impressive defense from Magnus Carlsen
to have survived uh what is it now 30
moves uh in this hopeless end game and
you're right Simon he's really running
out of moves now he's got to win within
the next 20.
okay still hard for black to defend
where do you put the Rook without it
being lost to a double attack
he's using the second ranked defense
here just uh here it's the seventh from
black side but keeping his King as close
to each other as possible as soon as
they're separated it will be game over
oh what oh whoa oh unbelievable and
maybe now unbelievable you cannot take
the Rook that's still mate again maybe
now black can hold long enough to uh
move it will happen wow that is that was
an unbelievable check and the king gets
off the back Rank and it forces this
position and you you you're gonna get to
how does he do it he's just a magician
and they reached the 40 move Mark
another 10 moves and Magnus gets through
then it ends in a draw automatically The
Game Stops yeah wow one of the world's
best players yeah napoleonish he's
struggling to win this theoretically one
end game he looks disgusted with himself
yeah oh no I think he realizes it that
he's not going to be in time to convert
this one anymore I think he he needs to
go back and look at the technique as we
all do very easy to forget it but
amazing amazing style mate trick they
had a Magnus pulled off oh my gosh he
really has nine lives Magnus Carson yeah
how does he keep doing this hope of
situations many of us would have
resigned and it's going to happen now
two more moves and it just stops
okay 50 move rule signals no progress no
captures no Pawn pushes and it will be a
draw Magnus just needs not to blunder
his Rook but the next one what happened
okay he's a bit worried but he's made
the draw unbelievable
where's this drama on Magnus Carlton wow
with a smile there he also is in
disbelief and David as you said probably
using up one of his nine lives today
surviving that one and for Jana bamishi
it is heartbreaking what a fantastic
game he played uh from the very
beginning they're creating his chances
again so much to choose from David in
this one yeah I just want to show a cool
tactic where Magnus could have actually
saved the game a bit earlier Yan
deserved to win he dominated the opening
the middle game but the end game is
where Magnus always seems to work his
magic and it was here black could have
used some nice night Forks to save the
game he could have retreated attacking
this Pawn the reason he didn't do this
was because White's Queen could have
given a check but now the black king can
simply move giving up this black rook in
the corner either you take this ball
next or white would have to allow a
nasty night fork and black would save
the game in the end we saw Queen vs rook
and I think everyone out everyone who
watched the show including the panel
need to go and study that theoretical
ending
and their Magnus Carlsen after getting
that 50 move rule in uh he's probably
not only started winning those uh king
and queen versus King and Rick and game
but also has started how to hold them
and we saw their appreciation by
janapamnushi he applauds magnus's effort
great games there by both these players
uh a little roller coaster day of Chess
no Armageddon but so many so much
fireworks there Maxine washer winning
his match 3-1 Magnus Carlsen holding
saving that uh game four with the draw
in a king and Rook versus King and Queen
Simon what a crazy day of chassis it's
been it was a great diet chess yeah I
mean that that last game was just so
entertaining I mean it was going
backwards and forwards Magnus kept
giving himself chances and uh yeah
brilliant brilliant match and you always
get a brilliant match with uh nepo and
Magnus because they're so uh they're so
close to each other aren't they and it
was really fun yeah yeah the good thing
about this format as well we might get a
rematch if Jan bounces back through the
elimination bracket I mean the way they
fought there it was reminiscent of that
world championship match that 2021 uh
game six that they had together where it
was over 130 moves that last Clash was
130 moves in itself they really pushed
each other to the brink and yeah it was
so much fun to watch so much to unpack
there
I found so much drama and it wasn't
enjoyed by Maxime with his 3-1 Victory
Maxim congratulations
yeah thank you that was once again a
very entertaining match uh full of
excitement and tactics what were you
feeling while you were going through
these up and down games
yeah I don't know the first two games I
think we've pretty much neutralized each
other
and then the third game went my way
because I think
Shah from his played the opening
normally after see for you you're not
supposed to go G5 because of D4
then it was a bit topsy-turvy but in
general it looked very good for me
and the last game it looked quite bad
for me at some point but somehow I
managed to
to survive this one push with G5 H5 and
then I have this nice tactic with Knight
F6 and uh
and it just worked out for me
yeah it was uh really quite a match to a
watch and uh chakra also his style of
play we saw him push well we were
calling it Gary the Jeep on throughout
G4 H4 is that something when you're
playing against the player like chakra
you're always prepared for this kind of
chaos on the board
last times and of course there's been a
few occasions where
he played in that style sometimes
punishes me sometimes uh gets punished
so you know
uh I would say business as usual when it
comes to Shah business as usual and the
business continues tomorrow as you will
be playing uh Magnus Carlsen in the
winners final and looking ahead at that
match Maxime or your thoughts going into
that for sure I've just seen that nail
biter
as you and yeah it was up here I found
some
some of the moves for
white and black there but it was really
pretty great defense by Magnus overall
and even if of course Jan should have
won this queen versus work but with
three seconds on the clock I mean the
move it's not so easy and
like
because Magnus put up great resistance
so you know it's always a big challenge
to play Magnus but uh
certainly hope to be up to the task
we're really looking forward to that
match up Maxim uh all the best we'll see
you tomorrow
it will be Maxima Sherlock taking on
Magnus Carlsen after these two have one
uh some some very dramatic games and
these are the post-match stats very high
accuracy there by Maxim at 93 but also
shock with some attacking Chess at
almost 90 percent yeah just incredibly
high level there from both players it
did in the end come down to Maxim's
Superior accuracy and finding those
brilliances when it really matters Shaq
in the end just couldn't keep up with
the tactics and we are being uh joined
by our other winner Magnus Carlson after
his roller coaster match Magnus
congratulations uh that was a crazy one
yeah
I miss
um it wasn't really poor much
to repair like from
in terms of the quality of the chest I'm
sure it was exciting to to watch uh and
um you know
I think neither of us played
particularly well I'm happy to have
pulled through of course but um
oh yeah generally a day to forget
mathematic moments and I I think you
know the one I want to bring up first
game two Magnus uh Queen G5 we saw both
of you react what happened in that
moment
yeah I mean first of all I blundered
through ponds like I just didn't see
that the fun on V6 was hanging I was
just thinking why are you going 94 that
makes no sense I'll go Knight C6 and my
thoughts didn't really go any go any
further like fortunately I had
sort of half reasonable practical
compensation at least there uh but uh
yeah when he played Bishop C3
I sort of had the feeling that this move
was a little bit wrong
that was the thing is I was fairly happy
with Knight E3 that's why I didn't
really look too much further and it was
only like
a little bit after I'd made the move
when he was thinking that I realized
what I could have done
um
I I don't know like how it came to me it
just suddenly I just suddenly realized
that Queen G5 would have would have made
it him so yeah that was um that was in
insane always looks for always look for
captures and checks kids
yeah check sketches and threats uh well
Magnus but you seem to have recovered
really quickly from that because that's
something that we were talking about in
the studio that it can be a bit
difficult to let go of that was that a
challenge at all for you
yeah my main problem was that my brain
was not working so
um so well so like recovering from that
was uh okay especially as it made me
realize
um or enforced my sort of Prior belief
that he was also missing some stuff
because he was even in game one
um
um he basically like stumble into a lost
position there
um in the in the early middle game from
from an opening that's fairly innocuous
so I didn't feel like he was he was
doing great I just yeah afterwards
I just couldn't find the moves there
either I felt like I should be fine but
I I couldn't see it so
for instance a couple of months later
when I took the pawn on D3 and played
Bishop E5 I was thinking to myself that
this has to be wrong this is not the way
to play the position there has to be
something better I just didn't see it uh
which is a really like frustrating
feeling usually I don't want to give up
sort of
um the the battle in that sense just
um
like
you know admit to yourself that you're
not gonna find the right continuation
but this time I did yeah anyway like
later on I was of course considerably
worse but he just blundered upon after
um and after that it was probably but
with nothing third game was the only one
only game that was
um I think quite good
um
I guess I was slightly better from the
opening and later on you know uh he gets
a lot of difficult choices eventually
and
um a lot of times people collapse so I
think that was was a good game but also
the fourth
um well first of all I got Blended in
the opening when I played 95 which is
insane I mean uh you could just go back
four which I realized after I'd made the
move because I can never go Knight C4
because of 1996 B5
um and then I also went for this plan
with G5 which I think is okay but I
played it all the I made all the wrong
moves like Bishop B7 allows uh Rook H6
um and then Queen H2 then I allowed the
second B5 so that was pretty
pretty bad but um
um you know
yeah at least it's made for for a really
exciting game so that's the good part it
really did Magnus it was a it was a
really fascinating match to watch for
many and for us to commentate on on in
the third game a really nice finish
there really beautiful uh checkmating
pattern at the end and finally going on
to game four Jan he also played
fantastic chess created his chances in
that end game the queen Hendrick uh the
king and queen versus King and Rook
getting into that
did you feel like there are real chances
to hold this so how confident were you
that you'd reach the 50 move rule
no I'm
no I will have
I did have an eye on it
um so
I think like getting to
to the to the position where black has
to put up the seventh ranked defense
is fairly easy uh in general but the
seventh rank defense is
not super trivial to to
um to break down I wouldn't say it's
really hard uh but it's it requires like
a little bit of knowledge in general
um
I mean it's not at least with seconds
it's not so easy to find intuitively so
whether he knew how to break it down or
he was just a bit
um exhausted with seconds so he couldn't
really uh remember or figure it out over
the board I don't know but when he was
when he was starting to struggle and I
think
at some point I saw that we'd made a
little over 20 moves I think and he was
still
um not making progress then I started to
think yeah actually
I could perhaps hold it and
uh to also to be honest like the last 10
moves or so my play was a little bit
lackadaisical in the queen versus Rook
ending but that was partly because I
knew at that point he was not going to
make it in time so I thought yeah let's
not blunder The Rook in one move and
then I'll be fine
and uh Magnus congratulations uh what
are your thoughts on the match against
mvl tomorrow
yeah it's exciting to get to play um
Maxim
um he did tremendously well in the speed
Chess Championship
um
crushing
good cash was was sort of expected but
also
um the way he won against nihal was a
little bit unexpected for me and not
that he won but the way he won and
um
sound very impressive
um and also like he was leading against
zakari with um with the bullets
um when the bullet started and I feel
like
even before that he had many chances to
leave lead even more and of course he
beats two very very strong players to to
get there so yeah it's good to get a
crack at him again it's been it's been a
while I feel
um and um yeah I I just I think I gotta
show up with the
um a little bit more energy than I I did
today because yeah today was
and uh Magnus we have a question from
the community chats and uh could you
tell us more about your uh upcoming book
I believe it's called Uh grind like a
grand master uh
what's the book about
I think it's exactly about that it's
about grinding out your
um growning out half points basically in
the end game
um having the the mindset to to never
give up always look for your chances
whether
and be be uh being holding a difficult
position or trying to
um to convert winning positions or
um
or uh press minute edges so
um it's a subject that's very
you know close to both David and Maya
Hart were both
um you know accomplished Grinders on the
chessboard so
um yeah that's basically that's
basically it's it's um
our our thoughts and and how to
Outlast your opponents and just so
Magnus you're basically saying if the
viewers buy the book they can hold queen
versus Rook against the under punishi
it's it's a bit funny
because I actually did win Quinn and
Rook
a queen versus Rook against him also
with very limited time and um Global
chess League earlier this year so um
yeah I feel like I sort of definitely
maxed out that one that little little
match up
um but I probably can't promise such a
thing but it will help you
not get into going in
green lives yeah
Grandmaster that's a book that I think
we'll all be picking up
before we let you go in our last
tournament it was carrots that was your
secret recipe and this one is by
Community Patrol and he wants to know
what is your go-to breakfast on
tournament day
I usually don't eat breakfast
so that's the simple answer
and uh Magnus I'm going to hit you with
one more this is a question from knee
hill 2501 will you log on to play title
Tuesday now
couple of games just to get a good
feeling
all right well good luck go for title
Tuesday and for your winners final
tomorrow against maximum
it is going to be Magnus Carlsen taking
on Maxime Bashar legrov in the winners
final after a lot of dramatic chess
action that we had and this was his
match against Jana pomnishi an accuracy
for both these players under 90 not
something that we get to see very often
by Magnus but it meant a lot of
entertainment for us
yeah just incredible games topsy-turvy
roller coasters full of tactics full of
nuances in the end game
um just it was a real blessing to watch
that one I'm gonna go home and play
through uh especially that last game uh
yeah in more detail
queen versus Rook how'd you save that
and how to win that both by Magnus
Carlton might be the next uh course as
you mentioned he's done it against
janafam Nishi and of course it wasn't
only in the winners bracket we had
dramatic chess in the losers bracket as
well it was Anish giri with a power
performance with a 2-0 victory against
Simon not many would have predicted this
at the start of the day yeah Hikaru
wasn't on great form in this tournament
but you have to admire anishikiri he
played he played great chess I expected
his accuracy to be higher than that
because uh it seemed like he played two
really powerful games but if he keeps
playing like that you know he could uh
he could have a chance of winning as
well the whole thing
and that's exactly what Anish giri needs
to do he needs that tournament Victory
to make it through to Toronto a
tournament Victory would confirm his
seat and we also had action between
Dennis lazowick and alireza ferrugia it
is the end of the road for Dennis
lazovic as alireza took it with one and
a half points and a very high accuracy
rate in this one 96 for alirez at 92
still extremely high by Dennis as well
that David yeah Dennis didn't do too
much wrong there but ferrugio was just
uh he had more gears he was able to get
his type of position in the first game
and then shut things down in the second
lasvik will be back he's qualified for
the tour finals and Russia moves on yeah
we will see Dennis last week back in the
Toronto finals uh alireza as well has
booked his ticket into that one and
going into our day three this is our
bracket this is the action that's coming
up tomorrow we will start with the
losers quarterfinal chakra are taking on
Anish giri yeah versus
these four players it is their last life
it is their final strike they need to
win to continue into the loser
semi-finals while the big Winners final
will be Magnus Carlsen against Maxim
Simon which one are you most excited
about uh quite interesting to see nepo
versus ferugia
um because they've both got very
exciting style and it'll be interesting
to see how nepo bounces back as well
after after his loss against Magnus sir
now for me the main course of Carlson
against fascia legrath that's going to
be a lot of fun but the starter of
mamajarov against Gary they always seem
to bring out the best in each other
mamajarov has had some spectacular games
against Gary in the past so uh yeah tune
in tomorrow everyone yeah absolutely
lots of appetizers and Main Course
coming up tomorrow right now it's time
for all of us to get desserts here what
a day of Chess we've had incredible
action and it all continues tomorrow we
will see you then same time same place
[Music]
he doesn't find it
that is shocked
[Applause]
he's seen it now
[Music]
oh
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome
[Music]
back
foreign
[Music]
thank you